foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
chess the weight of a win draw or loss
is all on one's shoulders it's easy to
feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
that's a win for ABI Mani Mishra and you
see that he is pumped up welcome back
PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh my gosh Rooks the game
first no it's mate and look at the smile
on Alexi Serrano's face
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
let's go let's go
today is Thursday what does that mean
it's another day of the pro chess League
I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me
today is the chess boxing sensation
Grand Master Iman Hamilton Amman great
to see you back man how you enjoying
yourself you ready for today in the
protest League hey Robert what's up to
everyone watching I am very excited for
some more PCL action Robert mostly
because I know that you know the matches
today are going to be breath of fresh
air after a rather disastrous uh
Canadian chess bra result recently
yeah the chess Bros did not have the
best week nor did the Norway gnomes or
the Spanish Maniac shrimps those were
our two losers of the mattress from
yesterday but I'm on the levitov chess
wizards they seem borderline invincible
and the Garden State passers led by our
good friend James Canyon III he's the
team captain they also look like a force
to be reckoned with you said it best I
mean the levitov Wizards to have uh
castenia there I mean it just brings
such a benefit to the average rating and
you know one of the strongest uh you
know woman players on the planet Robert
so I was watching some of her games and
just blown away I mean you have her on
board or was it and she's scoring like
50 I mean it's hard to go wrong with a
lineup like that
it certainly is and she beat the board
one for the opposing team so did Baylor
hotel is really on the passers Sam Sevin
he did the heavy lifting we know Sam I
Am he takes down these Spanish Maniac
shrimps it was not their best day and
for the maniac shrimps they are one of
those teams that's getting closer to
elimination reminder to everybody three
wins and you're into the playoffs and so
two teams have secured two match
victories Indian yogis and the levitov
chess wizards but I'm on the Brazil
Cappy bars they also were sporting a new
lineup and a new look to that Squad yeah
and I think you bring up one of the most
important things that people need to
remember when they're watching these
seams if you watch the Capybaras you
know in in week one you might have
thought oh we can count this team out
you know they don't look very good but
then all of a sudden week two comes
around and you have to remember Robert
these rosters that these teams have
they're so deep they have so many
lineups to try so if you see a lineup
that's just not working one week doesn't
mean that you count that team out I mean
they came back next week artemiev up
there I mean just incredible incredible
depth to their roster and we see the
chess Bros there at one and one and
you're mentioning lineup changes certain
Magnus Carlson lost the game just you
need to be removed from the lineup I
mean one loss I mean what do we hire
this guy for anyway we're supposed to
get perfect scores every week that was
my understanding
um but you you bring up a good point
we've used the same roster both weeks
thus far we definitely have some more
names that we want to get busy in our
lineup as well
yes some teams may need to switch their
lineups because with every match that
has a winner there is a team that loses
that matchup and as we look at some of
the teams that have struggled of course
the California unicorns the blitz they
still have their second match ahead of
them but down on the bottom of the
standings the Spanish Maniac shrimps and
the Charlotte cobras are you surprised
at all to see Charlotte led by Daniel
nerdinski down at the bottom
well you know it's it's interesting
about these lineups first of all you
know the Charlotte team Gotta Have you
know one of the bigger fan bases uh
certainly a very popular team but uh one
thing about their lineup is you know
they don't have as many like 27.50 plus
kind of players on their uh on their
roster
um that they're able to rotate in and
I'm not saying that those are the
lineups that that absolutely win but you
know the way this ecl uh format Works
Robert you are you get benefits for
having players that are well over 2 700
you know it helps you have that even
stronger lineup there's a 2800 player
counts as a 2700 so that could be one
thing with that Charlotte roster that
they just don't have any of those 2750s
that they're they're maximizing and of
the teams that have not won a match at
which do you see as maybe the biggest
player in the league a team that can
make its presence felt and maybe do some
Destruction come playoff time
well definitely you know looking at uh
what we see right here on the screen I
think we're about to get into some of
the matchups that might feature those
teams for example like how the heck are
the St Louis archbishops down there this
is a team that has you know story
success in the Pro chess League Robert
so I have my eyes on that team in
particular to uh let's say not find
itself at the bottom of the table for
too long
I'm with you so why don't we jump right
into today's matchups we start with the
Shanghai Tigers taking on the blitz and
then we get the St Louis Archbishop
taking on mg D1 two surprise teams that
have not won their first week match at
St Louis and mgd1 but let's put all of
our attention to Shanghai and the blitz
so we have one name team the blitz led
by Alexander grishook and Maxine Brush
Your legrov Captain by Kevin boardy and
the Shanghai Tigers I feel like every
year we used to have the shangdu pandas
among the teams from China super strong
super strong it also helps that there
are you know multiple uh Chinese women
who are so strong that they help that
average rating you got Julian Jin who's
you know worth the you know 200 points
above what she's coming in at 23.50 for
the the roster purposes I mean such
value there ho yifon has played in the
past as well so I feel like you're right
they always have those really really
strong lineups and I think it's because
of the women that they're able to play
on their teams who are so strong they
often find themselves forward one and
board two
mentioning The rosters the lineups let's
talk about Shanghai first Jew and Jun
she is the women's world champion at 25
55. she only comes against the cap at
23.50 so that's a big win for the
Shanghai Tigers speaking of big wins
that four out of four performance a
month he's proving to be a Powerhouse
absolutely
um I'm really excited to see if he can
keep that up this week
um you know our very own Magnus Carlson
wasn't able to keep that perfect
unbeaten streak alive uh so will we see
Wei keep that up obviously if you have
players on your roster Robert going four
out of four I mean you only need four
and a half points from the rest of the
team right so you're really setting
yourself up for success
good math by the chess boxer Iman
Hamilton there and I think while you
scored four to four in week one doing
that again against this blitz roster
good luck to you because we see
Alexander grishook on the screen in
front of us but they also have another
Super GM and another former World Blitz
champion in Maxine Russia lagrav that's
right I mean this is the pedigree it's
just so extensive here
um free shook you know obviously a
player that has played through the chess
bras in the past I think he's a very
very strong player tremendous in this
format he'll get in that time pressure
he'll give you a heart attack but at the
end of the day you know he he tends to
get the job done but imagine that your
board one is Grisha and your board two
is mvl talk about a one-two punch Robert
I mean that's just you know Unstoppable
it's freaky strong and what at the chest
bras you guys have a you know they're
like family but there's literal family
members on the blitz we see Alexander
grishook and his wife Katerina Lucknow
we see Matthew Cornett and his wife
Demonte darlita cornette and then
there's Etienne buckrow and his son
Alexander buckrow what do you make of
this family a friendly lineup I'm
getting like LeBron James and his son in
the NBA Vibes you know that's that's got
to be all getting a side of pretty
special moment to play on the same team
as your son I mean uh Alexander Vox
should be playing uh today as well so
excited to see him in action at 2400 but
I definitely think that you know the
blitz team has one of the strongest uh
you know camaraderies chemistries of of
probably any team out there and you know
we've seen teams in the chess Olympiad
like team Armenia just that you know
tight-knit
um Community between the team members I
think that helps a lot so
um I'm excited to see this blitz team in
action Robert
super strong great people to choose from
but the teams they have to make certain
selections because this league has some
rules for the lineups and it's not just
choose all your top players you have to
play with a 2550 average team rating you
have to have at least one woman on your
roster and players over 2700 they count
as 2700 and players under 2200 out of
2200 that is actually an important one
that we don't talk about very much the
reason that is there is so you don't
have Magnus Carlson Anish Geary and
another Super GM and then pick any
player that is super low rated because
that is too stacked and so it forces you
to actually balance your lineup of
course women over 23.50 count is 23.50
so Amon you're with the chess bras you
had to use these rules to make your
lineups what do you make them
well I think there's a couple different
strategies and and you'll see uh teams
going for a kind of medium lineup let's
say you could have you know all 25 50s
right there's there's lineups like that
but then there's also lineups where hey
let me get
couple 2800s maybe 2600 and then check
the 2200 in there basically sending them
to the Wolves honestly if they score
half a point or a point you're over the
moon but ultimately you might put a
board four in there that you kind of
expect to score zero points Robert
hoping that your Powerhouse of a lineup
might be able to to pull it through so
we see all different takes on how to
maximize this and that's why the PCL is
so fun it's not just one correct answer
and every team does it differently
every team certainly does and these team
captains and managers they have a tough
a choice to make and let's see who the
managers have trotted out today in their
lineups we see or the Shanghai Tigers no
surprises with the top two boards Wei Yi
and Juan Jun but we also see a balanced
sport three and four Shu Yi and luya
ping but for the blitz Alexander
grishook Max Team versus these are the
super GMS that will try to stop Wei's on
beaten streak then we have Grandmaster
Katarina Lucknow and Alexander buckrow
on the fourth board so Amon first glance
at these lineups who do you see is the
favorite and why
well the interesting thing that I've
noticed over the first couple weeks of
uh the pro chess League you know
learning from our lineups and how
they've performed as well as watching
some of the other teams I think lineups
that look like the blitz right now
should actually get out to you know
earlier leads whereas lineups that look
like the Shanghai tigers are probably
going to score better in the later
rounds when the ratings actually match
up even more so when you have these
Powerhouse reshook mvl they're gonna
start with some easier games against
board four board three that's when you
need to score your points as the blitz
so if I see the Shanghai Tigers getting
out to an early lead I actually think
they might run away with this match
whereas if the blitz get out to an early
lead who knows we could see some late
comebacks
these two very balanced rosters and I
just want to point out the blitz their
average team rating is above 2600 it's
actually 26 12. because the league rules
where uh catering Lucknow only counts as
23.50 Sasha gristook and Maxine
vasilograph only and I'm putting that in
air quotes counting as 2700 it means
they can boast this crazy strong roster
so let's Dive Right In the first round
of pairings because I'm on you were just
saying that for the Shanghai Tigers if
they can score some points in the early
rounds they might be the favorite later
on so let's start with wagyu with black
Alexander grishook and then Jew and June
black against Katarina luck no we have
two of the best women playing against
each other in the first round
that's right now that'll be
um probably the uh the biggest match-up
of this very first round I'm super
excited for that one
um Alexander back Crow on board four a
2400 Robert make no mistake he's not a
21 2200 that's expected to lose all his
games 2400 these days should be giving
everyone on this roster a tough game is
not walking in here and expecting to get
a easy Victory to start things off but
you're on the blitz side you are
definitely expecting mvl and Grisha try
to put up some points against these uh
these opponents from Shanghai but with
such a balanced roster I don't think any
points are just gimmies here sometimes
you see board one against board four on
both sides and you're thinking okay you
know we'll win for either side but here
I think anything can happen
I'm with you no obvious free points not
available to the Players let's remind
everybody especially if you're new here
of what the format is why we're talking
board one versus Board four why don't
they just play each other all boards
play the other teams or boards the time
Patrol is a rapid one 10 minutes let's
see it's like an increment up to four
rounds why up two because some teams
demolish their opposition and get to
eight and a half points within three
rounds but if when all of a sudden done
we have a tie eight to eight we will go
to tie breaks where the round four
pairings is Chord one versus Board one
four two two three three four four they
will replay with colors reversed so I'm
on we've already seen some tyrex
including the blitz last week uh Kevin
boardy their team captain called them
lucky to have won that week and it was
barely getting through in the tie breaks
truly that was one of the most
entertaining and there's been so many
entertaining matches but that's been one
of the memorable ones for me I remember
watching that live uh commentary was uh
unreal I mean it just must have been
crazy to be there to watch that
obviously I mean I'm a fan as well I
want to see some exciting chess Roberts
so I'm not gonna complain if we get some
tie breaks today but uh we'll we'll have
to wait and see lots of Chess to happen
before that
for sure and they say better lucky than
good I say best lucky and great and that
is what the blitz were last week where
they needed some results to go their way
they did go their way so they thrived
and shown when they needed their players
to do just that and we see two players
on our screen Alexander buckrow is that
a boat test live I can't quite see
what's on the hoodie but it looks kind
of like one of those boats as uh hoodies
but wait in the darkness and he is
saying I'll take these black pieces and
I think he needs to win for the Tigers
of course it's not must win it's the
first game of the entire match I'm on
but it sets the tone for the rest of the
match
absolutely I mean there's there's
nothing better than seeing your board
four Come Away with a victory against
the board one like it doesn't matter
even if that matchup is actually kind of
a close one and you know it's not an
insane upset that just instills
confidence in the rest of the team
Robert
oh we have a closed Sicilian I grew up
playing the closest selling them on we
might not see a D4 or maybe a delayed D4
after Knight F3 but what do you make of
this opening choice is only 2 moves
played by white does this to in your
mind show a little bit of I'm gonna play
a solid game or do you think that
Alexander about Crow just he's doing his
own thing he doesn't care who his
opponent
I think uh you know when you're playing
someone as strong as Wei there is a
little bit gamesmanship that goes into
it you might think to yourself
yeah oh no like my open Sicilian is not
going to stand up to this 2700 level
preparation especially in a 10 minute
game so he might be maybe going back to
something that he's more comfortable
with players do have rapid uh
repertoires uh you know really is a
thing they have certain openings that
they're only willing to try and wrap it
and you know they're just not ready for
classical but you know it's also just
keeping the the game uh going you know
it's gonna be a longer game this way
it's closed and hey the longer the game
is maybe the more chances
and we have seen board fours take down
their enemy teams board one we saw
Alexandra costenok and Below really do
just that yesterday and sometimes when
you put the onus on your opponent and
say wait if you want to win this game
you're gonna have to do something
Dynamic maybe something drastic and we
see a very solid start I mean look at
this no tension between the pawns black
saying yuffin let me do the same and
will white eventually play for D4 on
that's the big question that I have in
this kind of opening or you play a comet
E3 and F4 the night out Castle just try
to use your pawns to your advantage up
advance
well I've seen some some systems which
are kind of nice you know knight ge2 uh
D4 Knight takes and then you just bring
your knight from D4 back to E2 and just
you just kind of sit there and play it
slowly but uh I think he's gone and just
answered the question for us we see the
move D3 that tells me already we're not
seeing D4 because if you wanted D4 you
would have just gone and done it right
away now it would be a waste of time to
go D3 I'm gonna D4 a couple moves later
yeah I just feel like this plays into
Wei's hands as a stronger player he's
got a close setups he's likely to be
able to outmaneuver pretty much anybody
on the planet but especially someone he
outrags by 300 points so while Wei
assistant thinks he is going to
determine his next plan whether it's
going to be popping at night in D4 or
stopping D4 altogether we see that two
other games have begun so I'm on in the
top right uh there's a knight on B3 I
thought that was on C3 between Arena
lock no and June June so that's already
an odd position and then in the bottom
left we are seeing shuyi against Maxine
vashilograph a Four Knights Scotch with
Bishop C5 so which game would you prefer
to dive into well I'm let's come jump
into a Jew and jins game because I
actually thought that the thing on D6
was a pawn turns out it's a bishop so we
don't even know where the pieces are in
that game so let's head over there and
figure that out yeah it looks like
Fisher retina will rewind and this is a
matchup between this could be a women's
world championship matchup right
Katarina Lucknow and you won June two
super strong Grand Masters and how did
this Knight get to B3 well Bishop C5 and
then Knight to D2 okay that's why and
just to show everybody quickly that
trying to steal a pawn in the center it
often backfires when a queen slides up
to D4 and there's a checkmating attack
and his Knight is threatened so don't
just steal pawns because they look free
you have to be very careful and instead
the Knight that shot to B3 so come on as
we get to the live position that Bishop
on D6 looking like a tall Pawn here but
in the closed position we typically do
prefer the knights so you think white
has an edge
yeah maybe a maybe a very uh tiny Edge I
think these types of positions are super
standard for the opening that we've got
so I think neither player is going to be
dissatisfied being here you know the
bishop on H4 with a nice pin against the
Knight and it's difficult to break that
pin as well because Bishop E7 just
doesn't really fit in with black setup
here the bishop on D6 supporting E5 you
know it's entrenched in there Knight C4
by white coming so the bishop kind of
needs to remain on that square so maybe
G5 by black is going to be a move that
needs to be seen because I'm not sure if
you can live with that PIN forever
yeah that's such an annoying pin on the
diagonal but she was Queen to E7 and
Knight C4 hopping right in and
unfortunately for black it's hard to
kick this Knight out of here Bishop E6
drops the pawn E5 right away G5 breaks
the pin but it allows the bishop to join
the action against this E5 pawn and of
course anytime you play G5 you have to
look out for sacrifices I'll hit you in
June she cleverly slides her Queen up to
the E6 square and says I'm out of the
pit now what are you gonna do E5 is
defended what next yeah that's really
slick and you know taking advantage of
the fact that there's no light Square
Bishop in White's position so the E6
Square surprisingly super safe they
don't F3 doesn't have any squares to
attack it G5 D4 covered so in the end
the Knight just Retreats but this is
definitely a little bit of an
achievement here for black getting out
of that pin so early you might see the
knight move so that finally black can
re-coordinate and as for white would you
say maybe an idea is like to to try to
play F4 but it's gonna need some prep
yeah F4 and then a timely E5 there could
be tactics in this position and June
June developing her Bishop the other way
potentially A6 or C5 is thematic here
shut down any possibility of white plane
D4 so this is a slower approach this is
a game where they're both trying to find
the best squares for the pieces and just
one tactic to point out that Knight
takes E4 might be available if this
Knight were to move so if we uh play
Knight B3 that could in fact be a
blunder because Knight takes E4 removes
the guard of this Knight on C4 you take
what seems like a free Knight down goes
your night on C4 and if you take on D6
this Knight and hop back successfully
and recapture the Knight on D6 yeah
that's a sweet tactic and definitely
easy to miss if you're just not thinking
about it you know Knight D2 you just
kind of play in stride but
um I'm wondering if the knights are even
gonna recycle further like Knight C4 to
E3 maybe looking at the F5 square and
then the Knight on D2 popping into C4 as
a result
that's actually a really good plan
especially if this bishop were to leave
the diagonal then I would immediately
hop back and now Bishop takes F6 is a
sort of threat doesn't win material but
it does compromise Black's Pawn
structure so these two players I mean
they're doing a good job no side has an
avenge we see the bar in the middle we
will come back to this game but every
single game in the protest league is of
equal importance it does not matter your
rating you contribute to the team's
ultimate success so in the top left
Alexander buckrow Wei it's just a close
to Selena a single piece has been traded
on the top right we're just looking at
that one uh why don't we head to the
bottom left game between Shu Yi and
Maxine versus legrall because that one
is looking quite spicy
agreed yeah we gotta take a look mvl
um for the blitz is is in a position
here with the black pieces which you
know it's ready to get really spicy I
see that pawn on D5 when it when you see
this tension D5 and E4 and you see
neither player you know willing to bite
it usually means that neither player
wants to like it it's probably an
advantage for the opponent if they were
to take it there's so many tactics to be
careful of that Bishop on E3 and The
Rook on E8 staring down at it you might
see some Rook takes E3 lines in the
future
yeah because I think the natural
questions
answered by can I just take this Pawn
right where is the full competition for
the pawn and if you play Rook takes E3 I
just don't think it works out yet but
Amman has a good idea that just doesn't
quite work in this line because after
Queen takes uh oh actually Queen takes
wasn't even right maybe just take this
Knight on C6 is that simple exactly and
you take my Bishop I take your knight
and your Rook is hanging your neck yeah
this would be painful and you know you
kind of I think when you're playing
strong players you shouldn't be afraid
to just ask these questions sometimes
like they just leave a pawn loose for a
couple moves and it's like at some point
I'm gonna call the bluff right and trust
your own calculation he plays he takes
D5 can't blame him I think at this point
if you're looking at lines like Knight
takes on D4 I mean moving the knight
from C6 then we could see Mass trades
that not necessarily sure are beneficial
for mvl
yeah maybe he gets away with it and he's
thinking so you know this wasn't
completely planned but uh if you trade
on D4 the bishop will take back the D5
Pawn survives but I knew this is going
to happen it'll take on B5 first and
then D5 will be picked off it would
appear the ship takes F6 not available
just want to show a line very quickly
because the bishop takes F6 it looks
like okay I'm removing that attacker but
once we take back take this bishop this
queen this King on the same diagonal in
comes this bishop to E3 protected by The
Rook thank you very much for the queen
in the game that's right yeah and I
think that's why we saw
um I mean take Bishop takes B5 and queen
takes on D5 but I mean is this just
gonna Peter out to an immediate draw and
looking at Bishop takes B6 and then I
was wondering about Queen takes A2 some
kind of uh tricky move in between there
and that's why Knight C3 is actually
very good move uh by by white here
because it's easy to think oh yeah
average trading mvl's giving me a draw
and then missing a killer in between
but this is trading and making a draw
because it's likely it's like let's just
get all these pieces off the board and
the Queens come off is completely level
uh two rook and Knight position with six
pawns per side so I think this one is as
even as it gets although Maxime he
brought his Queen F5 so he's clearly
playing not for a win necessarily but he
wants to keep peace on the board to give
himself chances down the line so I like
his play but the position is very even I
agree yeah not much to see here Robert
Queen F5 he wants to keep playing but
he's the higher rated player I think
he's he's kind of got that expectation
right yeah he does indeed well another
player who is higher rated in their
matchup as we look back at our four
board view is Alexander grishook and
then look in the bottom right Lou yaping
strong International Master for the
Shanghai Tigers he is trying to dive
into those dark squares on the king side
and if you look at the top left and the
bottom right they kind of have some
similarities but it feels like in the
bottom right Louis ping just making more
inroads into the position so let's go to
that game as Alexander Grisha a glutton
for time trouble he is already down two
plus minutes and there's a bishop that
has landed on H6 so I'm on take it from
here buddy what is happening
yeah the thing is we've seen Bishop H6
in this game before black has castled
which is always an interesting decision
so if black voluntarily castled after
Bishop H6 white would say thanks very
much and maybe like h4h5 launch an
attack I mean that's kind of what white
wants but grishook has said okay I
haven't committed to kingside castling
yet I'm gonna take on H6 draw your queen
way over there and say well now I'm
going to open the center and that's kind
of what we're taught uh you know the
school of Chess right you want to react
to play on the side of the board with
play right down the middle of the board
so I think rishik has reacted really
well here but keep in mind that black
king on E8 does not really have a safe
place to go now that I'm looking at it
Robert white king only one also can't
Castle King's side either
yeah another king particularly safe and
they're also strategic elements here I
think White's next move might be A5 to
disconnect these pawns from one another
so you would say all right I don't want
to see A5 so let me play it myself but
it up goes this bishop to B5 potentially
so you control one square you give up
the other so A5 does keep the B4 Pawn
defended but it does give up maybe it's
important D5 Square so I feel like
you're right I'm on the white King has
nowhere to go the black king cannot
legally Castle kingside because I guess
it's their check I don't think you
really want to go Queen side either
because that side of the board is open
so maybe the Kings will stay in the
center for the time being and grishook
now down three minutes a month we know
that he is capable of playing with just
seconds on his clock but this is a big
time lead for white and no clear plan
for either side
it's true yeah
um and it also looks like the queen
might be kind of invading but I mean
let's say if we want to just put A5 on
the board for example
um you know white might decide to slide
in there with mean G7 and I was just
thinking one of the weird lines is like
being G7 Rook G8 Queen to H6 and black
can almost even try in that position
something like G5 maybe and really go
after this queen Rook G6 H3 is the only
available Square well there's a bishop
on C8 ready for a discovery so when
white looks like they're penetrating
into the position of Queen G7 it
actually backfire completely and maybe
even trap the queen
it's a really really good point that a
lot of us would just bring our Queen to
G7 to attack a rook and say you have to
move your rookie can't Castle but
Black's right happily will step in front
of the king uh Queen excuse me kick it
away so uh still spending time and while
he does we're gonna zoom out just for a
moment we will keep an eye on all four
games but if we look in the various
positions here Amman in the top right
still very close between Academy and
Lucknow and ju and June things locked up
there
um in the top left me Wei Yi and
Alexander buckrow finally pieces are
trading but white looks kind of cramped
there and then the bottom left chuyi and
Maxima Sheila Grove it seems like it's a
pretty even position so what do you say
we go to Wei's game back to where we
started exactly there's been the most
developments there and obviously this is
a crucial match for for both sides I
mean obviously the Tigers gonna want
their board one to start with a win but
uh back row could really Inspire some
confidence here I'm looking at the
current position I'm saying okay Bishop
pair for way obviously that exchange
looked like it just happened on D4
um and the position looks really
comfortable for black in terms of you
know E5 Could Happen below the position
wide open uh should usually benefit the
Bishops but very solid position for
Alexander back row if you look at you
know where the weaknesses are for white
abc2 that's that's about it honestly
yeah that's actually really the only one
I mean it takes eight takes that would
actually be good news for white so you
could get the open file the bishop on G7
kind of like in some Kings Indian
positions it stares into its own Pawn so
it's not as strong as it could be and if
you think about it black has this double
pawns and maybe some pawns that need
pieces to defend them so he takes a five
plate the queen jumps in and now what
that's the big question can we take on
A4 I that would look like an
impossibility but the B4 Pawn is loose
over here yeah that's that's uh I feel
like that's the kind of move that you
almost reject immediately is a human
player meanwhile the engine's screaming
for it like Hey we're up a pawn no
worries uh but I I would be a little
frightened to do that as white I kind of
like what he's done with Bishop H3 I was
also you know thinking of Knight G3 but
we would drop our F4 Pawn which is a
little unfortunate so Bishop H3 kind of
accomplishes the same thing but I think
white has that eventual goal to play you
know H5 or F5 and hang on a sec is this
forced he's got to go to Epic seven
surely yeah only two squares available
D5 and F7 and if you want a draw you go
to D5 saying I may be down a minute but
I'm up 300 rating points the bishop
side's back to G2 that's he seemed a
little odd to me do you think the queen
was going back to D5 that's what it
looks like to me because I mean the
Queen's not poorly placed on H3 if
anything I thought it was kind of decent
there and it looks like white has not
basically Lost Time by this little
triangulation so yeah that was a weird
move Robert it looked like he expected
Queen D5
yeah and now all of a sudden way Yi he
could try to trade those light Square
Bishops to go after this King over here
uh the Knight on E2 stuck defending the
pawn F4 as you were mentioning so I feel
like a white is a little bit tied down
and black has more space thanks to these
Advanced pawns and weighed down to a
minute and 30 seconds I am keeping an
eye on all four boards this does appear
to be the most interesting game for the
moment but the way he has to find a move
he is really using so much of his clock
yeah and he goes for the exchange of
Bishops here it's just certainly going
to make White's King weaker the other
interesting thing is the Knight on
YouTube and Queen on D2 are pretty tied
down like can't move at all especially
the Knight so for white you're looking
at that Knight on F2 as you know the
next most eligible uh candidate right to
to make the next move
I'm looking at that I don't have two and
wondering where I can put it that does
any good night surprisingly to H1 to G3
like I'm trying to get a knight to G3
Roberts I want to push F5
wow yeah maybe there is a knight reroute
necessary uh but something that was
missed in another game as we zoom out of
this one for a second was the game
between Maxim Russia lagrove and Shu Yi
where it looks like black is on the
attack but he might have missed uh
something a little bit more
but let's see where this happened the
king went to H7 the queen came to C5 and
I mean already this position is starting
to look good for black it means yeah 55
Queen F4 and rookie E1 check that
apparently was a mistake so what was
better than that
I mean oh not rookie one I mean are we
looking at Queen G1 surprisingly or
Knight H5 oh brilliant I'm on Knight H5
it just Forks the queen in the pawn and
then Queen G1 picks it up wow that okay
that's kind of difficult to see I don't
really blame him because F7 would have
been hanging and things of that nature
but Knight H5 apparently is the best
move if Queen takes F7 oh it's Queen is
actually almost trapped after rookie
seven so the queen has to drop all the
way back to B3 and then use upon
grabbing on the king side these split
pawns will not see uh the future it
seems like that will just be a good
transition yeah Queen f8 is a funny like
Queen loss instead of Queen B3 it's like
you know you're all the way to your
opponent's side of the board and then
Rook down to E1 you lose your queen down
there that's a crazy variation very
tough to spot and it looks like mvl is
gone for you know kind of a more uh more
anticipated approach here yeah no this
is still looking like anyone's game and
MBL is up on time he's a former World
Blitz Champion so I feel like he is
doing quite decently but it should be a
draw with best play pieces are getting
traded strong player in his own right he
has no fear of Maxine vashila grab so I
think we could trust these players for
now uh we'll hop back to it if it gets
interesting but look at the top left of
your screen things have gone from bad to
worse for Alexander buckrow as Black's
Queen has invaded there's a good attack
going for wayis let's go there right now
and weigh you down under a minute on the
clock but I'm on he's breaking up in
this position now along the f file I
think the problem with uh back Row's
position is he appears to have listened
to me and played Knight each one to G3
and now now he has a terrible uh
position as a result the engine does not
like this obviously time taking down
here but should be more than enough time
look at that Rook on B7 ready to swing
over Robert the pieces are just placed
so perfectly for this attack and I feel
like white is just handicapped from the
queen on D2 and Knight on E2 being
essentially unable to move the entire
game
yeah they still have not moved and
already there's a big threat of Rook
takes Rook Rook has to take back and you
swap everything off that drags this King
away but guess what the king is needed
to protect the Knight on G3 not to
mention that if this Rook ever leaves H4
we'll fall so oh goodness there must be
some kind of knockout blow here Queen F3
check is tempting him on yeah what else
yeah Knight E6 like to just bring an
extra piece Into The Fray also looks
tempting
some sort of mix of both of those moves
looks tempting
oh yeah oh he's just barreling down at
this G3 Knight
and look at him go now he's threading
Bishop takes G3 winning a night look at
all these pins this is insane
and you know what his next move is I was
like what happens there's a queen F2
threatening mate he said he said oh
Brooke takes E2 yeah
oh
yeah that's a nasty move and then every
single Pawn that you know and love Falls
after that
this is sick way he went four to four
last week and he's showing that
definitely was not a fluke he was the
youngest player to ever reach 2700 and
now he is just bullying his opponent
taking this Knight then the next night
then this pawn and that pawn is winning
the house he is yeah this this looks
like it's gonna be a win for Wei Yi
um with a great uh great conversion
we'll just basically see the conclusion
of it here and they're going for that
line Robert uh way he's played Rook
takes E2 temporary very temporary
sacrifice because look at what he's
getting back
yeah
he's giving all these checks was he
gaining a little bit oh Queen E3 I was
wondering why the queen went to H6 you
want to trade Queens on E3 get himself a
pass pawn and Bishop C3 oh my gosh a
perfect game maybe by way either that's
insane yeah that's dominant dominant and
we don't expect anything else from Wei
he's still what is he five for five now
in the Pro chassis League Robert
five for five keeping his perfect streak
alive and there were two draws uh the
games between uh June and Katarina luck
know that was all locked up in the top
right I mean look at that it's like
Checkers over there on two different
boards White playing on the lights
squares black playing the dark squares
and then we had a draw between Alexander
grishok and Louisa Pig so that's a good
result or the Shanghai Tigers which
leaves us with one game remaining and if
Maxine versus
uh not winning this game and he
certainly is not winning this position
at the moment that's amazing for the
Tigers yeah yeah definitely it looks
like Knight D4 Shack it's kind of the
you know the the next move right F3
Falls C6 Falls and then maybe you could
go from there but he's going F6 so a
little bit of life in the position
obviously mistakes can still happen uh
Robert but I I would say this looks like
we could be getting a another draw here
and then the the Tigers would eek things
out early
it's what you were saying so maybe
you're the prophet after all I'm on if
the Tigers can hold on those lower
boards against the 2700 plus players in
the blitz then they should have the
upper hand in later rounds and way he
gets the job done but these super jams
for the blitz whether it be Maxine
Russell grub or Alexander Grisha not
getting the wins in game one but maybe
let's not count Maxim out he's up nearly
a minute in the clock under 20 seconds
for white and there is this G4 Pawn that
has to be dealt with like let's say Rook
F4 here are you dealing with these dual
threats yeah that's a great Point Rook
Rook F4 it looks like you know you might
consider just moving the Knight right
giving the g-pawn and saying okay I'm
about to take on C6 as well I was
looking at you know Rook F4 Knight D6
Rook G4 Rook C6 and you know there's not
much going on
um in opposite it looks like you know
the best you might be able to do Robert
is somehow get White's Knight for your F
Pawn but even then it's still a draw
yeah even F5 Knight takes F5 that's
right known theoretical draw nothing to
worry about so I was looking at the
clock maybe that was um motivating what
I was thinking but we see that this is
just completely low just take it you can
take it you don't need to but there's no
way you're gonna lose rook and Knight
versus an easy theoretical draw but I
just don't like that shui is getting so
low on the clock that's what it's
worrying me
it's funny it was F5 played and Knight
E4 it's like it's almost like a move you
play just to show and prove that you can
play
and if the Knight comes back to D6 well
the king will pop up to E6 here and then
you're gonna run out of these sort of
checks so the game continues I'm a bit
surprised by that because shuyi is down
so much time and Maxine vashilagrove he
didn't win the world Blitz that wasn't
by accident that was clearly his
strength and so maybe he could play for
tricks here and get his opponent in the
time travel right yeah I think I think
that's uh obviously worth exploring here
um white really doesn't want to sack the
Knight for the pawn like it's just it's
almost embarrassing because you're
you're showing that you just can't
defend the position but
um you know he's lost his Pawn there but
I I feel like white getting that Knight
to F3 has got to be uh
gotta be a good sign yeah I mean you're
nice getting active here so black is up
a pawn if anyone can win this game of
course it's black this Rook needs to
move it's under attack and there would
be a fork even if it didn't move so
watch out for like an F4 rookie three at
the right moment there's still there's
some chances here for Maxine
the night is really really uh strong
where it is right now covering F4 but
you know white needs to make moves and
there there's King F1 not the easiest
move to make
no and the rook and the Knight just
detective I was gonna say the king went
to D7 you bring your knight to E5 but
he's not even allowing that he's trying
to create some kind of Fortress but the
king runs away up to E2 so this should
be a hold we're not denying that but
it's just feeling like a position with
five seconds three seconds for white
things could go wrong watch out for
Forks he went this way because otherwise
Knight D2 tech support exactly wait wait
Knight F2 wins the night on E5 but you
do get this Pawn in F4
and I mean is he gonna take that
he is I mean look you can't get much
more than what Maxine got here right
you're kind of doing as well as you can
and it's kind of funny because this
position it says the bar is completely
uh level uh
it's yeah of course it should be a drug
but mistakes happen especially without
time and it gets a night it's a tricky
pieces
and hey I've seen and competed in my
fair share of title Tuesdays Robert so I
feel like I am a world-renowned expert
at watching Rook at night
yeah
um yeah it's one of these things where
where's the fork gonna happen you want
to keep your rook in line with the
Knight so the king can't cross the last
thing you want is to allow this King
hopping over to D6 right pushing your
king to the side of the board Here Comes
maximum
yep and usually you know you want to
create some position where you know your
Rook goes to h8 and just stays on like
H5 H4 H6 for white and even though the
white king is getting pushed towards the
queen side to the a file uh with that
Rook way over on the king side on the H
file white you're usually able to uh
create create some boundaries
the King goes back to C2 so making small
little progress Knight comes up to E5
but the issue is whenever the King goes
to D4 you give a check on d8 Knights are
not good like Bishops are at blocking
checks uh Bishops movies one square on
the diagonal and then a block a check
and I have to go so far away to do that
and you know it has to be said that uh
Maxime is trying to win he's not there's
no correct formula that you know there's
no way to do it so he's just trying his
best uh he's certainly making some
progress here funny enough Rook to C4
King A5 Knight C6 doesn't exist because
it's been but he is kicking the king to
the last uh file over here so the a file
oh he doesn't give the check over here I
guess the king could have split the C5
but now the king is just gonna slink up
what do you think it's a move 94 how
many moves is this game going to last
I'm curious what the chat is going to
say
yeah this is I mean he's trying to make
it work but ultimately I don't think uh
I don't think
two years uh is going to allow it
there's some nasty Forks now though
um
this Rook can in the night but then the
king will get closer so he's doing a
great job of keeping the king out of
play oh he is trying to slide his King
it yeah usually in these situations you
want to play like Rook B3 so that you
can kind of block the check with your
knight on C3 and then bring the king to
C6
yeah you could tell that Maxim's trying
to find the trickiest variation and he
wanted his Knight to C5 when the King
was an A5 because it was set of a mating
net that's why the King goes to A3
rather than up to A5 where he probably
would have been checkmated yep I wonder
if White's gonna defend with Rook before
here always a tricky well but let's
bring up an analysis board Rook B4 was a
blunder sorry Iman gotta do this to you
Rook A7 check the King has to go to B2
and then Knight D3 would oh yeah it
would have one blocked the game oh it's
forced as well yeah that would be nasty
like I said I'm a professional uh
professional Observer not not actually
playing the position that's how I feel
often about rook and Bishop versus Rook
okay when I'm not playing when there's
no stress on me I know exactly how to
hold yeah
this is this is a really good defense
though by chuyi here although yeah I
think this is the last move of the game
because I see
that it's pure zeros makes the 50
movable yeah this was close like Knight
C4 now and your king is about to deliver
a Checkmate so uh that was close but it
didn't quite make it did Maxine versus a
great hold for shuyen the Tigers they
get this draw it'll be two and a half
one half the Tigers hold a one point
lead them on that's right and uh hey
great uh great defense even though we
like to talk about rook and Knight like
it's you know super easy
um and it should be a draw you still
have to make that draw and against a
player's strongest vaccine time picking
down that's no easy task your team needs
you to perform and you absolutely did uh
Hey the two superstars there grishook
and mvl with draws on their boards this
is what I was calling for before the
match I think the blitz needed to get
out to a bigger start than they have
Shanghai up two and a half to one and a
half Robert I think they're very happy
with that first round result for sure
because
they actually had very solid games even
though they were out rated on each and
every board and then it was way Yi who
delivered for the Shanghai tiger so they
are now leading two and a half to one
now so Amanda and I will take a very
quick break the games will commence in
the second round in just a few minutes
this is the protesting matchup in the
Shanghai tigers and the blitz you will
not want to miss the rest
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also uh change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of
you know anyone trying to develop their
chess game
um if you do find you know style of play
that you enjoy that's good but you could
also try to sharpen it by implementing
you know on another form of uh into your
bag as we would call it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
he may be hiding in the shadows but his
play on the board lights up the score
for the Shanghai tigers that is super
Grand Master wagy the top board for
Shanghai Amman he is a monster he's an
absolute tactical Beast he is now five
out of five in the Pro chess League can
anybody stop this man
I mean Robert we're still looking for
the answer to that question Wei has been
playing lights out so far five out of
five in the protest League I mean look
at pedigree right here he's world number
29 Robert and it feels like nobody's
seen him play it's like where where does
he play because he's such a strong
player over 2700 he's the youngest
player to reach 2700 speaking of that
when he was 15 years old we've all seen
wayi's Talent over the years but you
know it's nice and refreshing to see him
competing in the PCL here Robert because
I feel like I just don't get enough of
his classical games he's just really not
playing over the board much it's a shame
because of how strong is he's only 23
years old it feels like he's been around
forever but that's because he became a
superstar at the age of 15 and during
the break there uh you know the players
in the for the Chinese team the Shanghai
Tigers they were laughing they were
having a good time so you see the
camaraderie and he really leads the
charge for them he is is a perfect five
out of 5 thus far in the Pro chest thing
and coming up next the matches do not
get easier for him he took down the
board four for the Blitz and now that
means he gets a tougher matchup but he
does lead the way he was the only person
to score a full point for the Tigers
yeah and I've actually like kind of been
thinking about that which way do you
prefer the games to go because quite
literally every game for way Yi gets
tougher from now on whereas you know
technically for the board fours every
game gets easier so which which way do
you would you rather have it Robert if
you were playing I think starting with
black against Sport 4 is a good thing
and Wei he took care of business with
the black pieces so I feel like it can
build his confidence when you're having
a good day you want to start uh piling
up those victories but when you're
having a bad day potentially and you'd
lose that first game you're like oh why
couldn't I have just lost to Alexander
grishook so coming up next for Wei as
you said the matchups do get tougher for
the board ones and that is clearly true
with round two on Deck Amman he gets the
white pieces but he's playing Katarina
luck no so as we look across these four
matchups wow what lineups these two
teams have yeah so we'll see the colors
flip now and uh the two top two Heavy
Hitters for the blitz you're seeing
there are gonna have the white pieces
against shuyi and Louis ping so look at
those boards right there on the the
bottom half of the uh the lineups Robert
because I think the blitz like this
round is really important for the blitz
to win I think that we shook an mvl with
the white pieces uh you know hey put you
guys up there you're gonna need some
wins on the board here
um Juan Jun and Alexander back row is
another big matchup but you pointed it
out I think board one is gonna be uh one
of the most exciting ones of the round
Robert
he needs to strike again for the Tigers
because as you're saying for Alexander
Grisha Maxine vashilograph it's a super
GM Mantra you hold with black they just
did that now you win with white that is
what they have to prove but we are going
to start with Wei Yi as he takes on uh
Katarina Lucknow I believe that will be
our first matchup of the round and Wei
really Unstoppable to this point he is
five out of five and it feels like he's
barely been in trouble throughout those
games
yeah that's a great Point like
um you know when you're when you're
looking at these PCL games you have to
keep in mind uh some players you know
the professionals they're okay with the
draw like they want to push their
chances to the Limit they are obviously
looking for a win but ultimately we saw
in the previous round you know Greece
shook didn't go crazy trying to win his
game he's okay with a draw
um mvl the same you know he didn't he
didn't go nuts you know he tried a rook
in Knight end game so uh yeah I think
that that's absolutely a strategy here
and Robert what the heck is going on
here we already got H4 on the board I
think the chat's gonna love this one I
mean I'm using the double x Glam I can
do that because I control the board you
see double xlam H4 Peter Spindler one of
the world's leading experts in the
grunfeld he has said that this is a
tough line to deal with Sam Shanklin
plays it and we know how well prepared
he is H4 and no response yet from
Katerina Lucknow yeah I mean I'm just
first of all I'm enjoying this little uh
double X clamp you can throw on the
moves now I've never seen this before
this is awesome I like that uh C6 played
in response and I think the move H4 it
kind of stops you in your tracks a
little bit you know you're in the rhythm
you're ready to play Bishop G7 Castle
maybe D5 you know typical grenfeld and
then you see H4 and you're like
maybe I don't even want to put my Bishop
on G7 all of a sudden so like no
rethinking things but for C6 and this
might get back into like slav territory
yeah because H4 is definitely scary if
you Castle as you were saying but if you
play in the center was this really a
useful move it does give the G4 Square
two blacks pieces potentially this
bishop coming out to G4 that could be a
bit annoying so H4 I like it it's
showing his intentions he wants to play
uh ambitiously and creatively but it's
not a good sign when you play H4 your
opponent plays a pretty calm move and
then you're the one thinking
that's right yeah because C6 is okay not
not the strangest move uh ever but it's
really thrown Wei into a
Think Tank here I mean H5 has a
follow-up
it can be played but you know I'm not
sure he wants to just uh go for it
straight away this isn't bullet chess
you know after Knight takes H5 I'm not
sure you're prepared to sack The Rook
the way you might be in some other less
important games and then now we get like
an exchanged slav with H4 and G6 thrown
in this is exactly what an exchange love
looks like but with these two moves and
I feel like the moves don't necessarily
help white for the time being but you
can tell that Katarina she wants to
finish her development she wants the
castle but also this is Bishop so if you
think about this from the London
perspective with your Pawn H4 your
Bishop is never in danger of being one
because your Bishop can slide back to H2
and you're on an unopposed diagonal so
maybe small advantages for way you hear
yeah I would probably say so you know if
you take the move H4 and G6 back black
would almost always develop the Bishop
from E7 on the division from f8 on the
f8 to A3 diagonal kind of rare in an
exchange slav like this to all of a
sudden Kettle the bishop uh and as you
said the H Pawn kind of acts as if white
has played H3 of course there are some
differences at G4 square but I think it
benefits white Robert and we see the
move Queen B6 played there are maybe
some ways to already give up some uh
give up some pawns here for white like
either B2 or D4 depending yeah E3 Queen
takes B2 Knight B5 that looks like fun
these kind of ideas oh I'm apparently
blundered uh something here uh but maybe
there is using this B5 Square could be
to White's Advantage but I guess Knight
B5 allows Knight E4 and your might just
get checkmated uh one way or another
here so you have to be very very careful
but I could see a pawn sacrifice
happening in this game
yep either E3 to defend that or you know
another way to do things is sometimes on
the C file with that loose Bishop on C8
um you know Rook C1 or queen C2
something like that
um eyeballing the bishop so yeah I
wonder how uh way he's gonna proceed
look Queen D2 if you want to just keep
everything under control is another uh
natural move so we might see just Queen
D2 E3 and and stuff like that yeah well
this game uh for now remains relatively
peaceful we'll see if it gets uh spicier
as the game continues but let's look at
the top right of our screen this is
theoretical Territory between Jew and
June and Alexander buckrow but it's a
wild Affair up there and pretty much all
the games are pretty exciting and full
of life in the bottom left Alexander
grishook against shuyi white has double
pawns that he just pushed forward but
the eval bar hovering a little bit in
Black's favor potentially with the queen
trade on the horizon so let's uh maybe
in the bottom right is of Berlin so
we're not going to talk about that one
but let's go to the game between you and
June June June and Alexander bakrow it's
a very important game because if Jew and
June can take down buckrow who lost in
the first match that would be great for
the Tigers so Iman do you have any
experience in this opening we can go
back and see how we got here but do you
have you ever played these lines
I've definitely played them only a few
times and uh never In classical so I've
been haven't gotten these crazy and I
mean I mean crazy these can go almost
the entire game Robert with uh without
ever you having to think you're just
recalling what you've prepped and
studied because these lines have been so
explored over the years you see crazy
move like G5 it looks nuts right but if
the bishop moves away the Knight on C4
will be hanging and this is just uh you
know a long long time uh of analysis uh
in the books here
I love you don't even move the bishop
you move the Knight back to attack right
this bishop so the bishop moves you lose
the pawn in G5 so you take and then
black just castles please take my Pawn
over here you see that I have an attack
going against your queen I will scoop
this Pawn back up in the future so we
see Queen C2 Knight C5 please still take
my Pawn no okay fine and after Pawn
takes politics we have this position
where I've always felt like it at least
by appearances black should be able to
strike quickly but this knife on F5 is
so powerful here because it covers the
H4 square and white can strike at any
moment on the queen side so at first
glance I've always liked black but then
the more I've seen these games go I feel
like white does have some great play for
herself
yeah no this is a position where the
Knight is also uh guarded by the queen
on C2 so it's really entrenched in there
neither Knight for black can challenge
the F5 Square very easily at all I was
about to say B4 and B5 already is such a
strong idea A5 makes a ton of sense to
take that under control we might even
see Knight A6 to B4 you get that Knight
even further entrenched and there's dark
squares and when I talk about dark
squares we've talked about the night on
F5 it really is a color complex kind of
battle here Robert because of the
presence of the dark square and light
Square Bishops on the board opposite
Bishops both sides are fighting for
those different color complexes yeah the
995 dominating this bishop on f8 for now
but as you said if this Knight were to
move out the way from C5 even the bishop
or that Knight could go to the B4 square
but for now with the Rook stare down
you'd be very very careful because you
don't want to allow White
to quickly attack trade Rooks bring the
next Rook over then bring a bishop maybe
to H3 to force the king to the side
there could be a devastating attack on
the horizon with ideas like you know a
night sacrifice on B5 as well you just
keep all of these options in your mind
if your Alexander buckrow and I'm on
he's down over three minutes on the
clock not good news for the blitz if you
ask me
yeah it was all I was also just noticing
he was doing uh you know one of those
things where you put both your hands on
your head I've always been I've always
wondered when you play online chess like
obviously when you play OTB that's very
normal but when I think about Moves In
online chess I don't think I ever do
that but I see both players doing it in
this match like I never take my hand off
the mouse yeah well Jew and Junior must
have heard you saying that and she
immediately puts her hands on her head
but that's how concentrated they are we
get the five head cam uh from them but
let's leave Alexander Buckroe too and he
decides to take on deep one giving up
the D file a bit of a surprise in the
top right but we have some interesting
games all around bottom right is that
Berlin top left by the way you called it
Amman there was a pawn sack on that
board I think we should go back there
just for a moment we will look at the
other games but I'm loving the pawn sack
that you suggested because this is not
how it typically goes you play E3 you
give up the pawn on B2 I suggested a
losing move I get it my bad but Queen
see what you give up material and then
you trade Queens after pushing your H
Pawn and not developing it feels like
wayi is playing against the rules of
Chess and yet the Eva bar saying nah
White's doing pretty nicely exactly yeah
way to go
um because if you don't trade Queens
here you Retreat the queen to you know
B6 for example I mean we can already
think about winning the pawn back with
move like Knight takes D5
um because the bishop on C8 is loose and
the whole idea is that while the Bishop
C8 is attacked like my play Knight C6
here right totally natural move covers
the C file but then the move that you've
been harping on the entire time kind of
comes into play here and that Knight B5
is C7 it just can't be stopped so really
uncomfortable position for lacno to be
in especially because Wei is not playing
this Robert because he just spotted it
over the board he's seen this before
yeah and if you try to take away the B5
score with A6 is it man has been
highlighting this bishop is loose so
Knight takes D5 for example would be
available with this bishop hanging back
here and then the Knight it's not just
the bishop it's the Knight on B8 so I
take your Bishop with check your king
goes you say oh you're Rook your Bishop
uh sorry thank you for your free piece
that's the game so I feel like already
it's a critical moment for Katarina luck
no she can think about bring her Bishop
to D7 but Knight B5 is still tempting
you don't really want to give up your
Bishop for this Knight over here with
the Rook gonna slam down on C7 I would
say clear Advantage for white this is
just one Pawn it's not really coming
into play just yet no and it's really uh
do slow down trying to develop the rest
of your pieces because you know Bishop
G7 the knights lost to get out white has
easy moves B5 Square for night the
bishop might take back with check if it
gets captured Knight F3 to E5 and white
doesn't even need to Castle you could
just play King E2 and enjoy all that
open space and open files you've got on
the queen side love way Yi's position uh
think he's off to a great start one last
thing before we got here you said 95 you
I started thinking of the E5 Square
Bishop E5 might already win back the D5
Pawn because this the pin here I'll take
your knight and grab this Pawn the
center with a fork on C7 threatened to
boot so Wow way is spoiled for Choice he
is down on the clock he'll need to make
his next decisions relatively quickly
but let's zoom out of here because I am
actually seeing some interesting stuff
happening on that Berlin board I
discounted it it was a Berlin in the
bottom right but where did all that
Berlin structure go we're in an opposite
color Bishop position where Maxine
vashir lagrav has the healthier Pawn
structure as you approach the end game
and look at this move okay how clever is
Maxime did he just blunder upon Maxine
does not just hang a pawn like this in
one move I'm gonna show this bring up a
nail sport Bishop takes F3 looks good
there's a pin down the G file but after
The Rook slides to E1 with check and the
King goes to F7 uh this bishop can just
slide back and Rook F2 we might get like
a ladder type of Checkmate against this
King it's wide open here yeah this is a
I mean I almost can't believe this was a
Berlin at one point but you're right the
the king is just so exposed here white
is almost going to be like force mating
that King where's the mate let's see the
king okay the King goes here Rook F7 is
obvious if the King goes up where's the
Checkmate that's the question do we just
force it you gotta find it there Bishop
D2 looks like a great start and the King
has to run this way and here where's the
mate because if I go here I lose my rope
what the heck
I don't see the Checkmate but you could
probably just move your Rook away
somewhere and deliver a Checkmate next
right like there's also yeah yeah
exactly all right well we're getting a
little ahead of ourselves here we see F3
the King goes to F7 smart Play Bishop
back to E5 hitting the pawn here
defensive moves from black and just King
up and white is clearly much better here
you're gonna play G4 you're gonna get
passers on this side of the board over
here and they're double pawns for black
and the bishop covers h8 which you know
doesn't look too relevant right now but
it really helps those pawns move up the
board it means that black can't go Rook
h8 to ever challenge the H Pawn so
you're gonna see like takes I'm thinking
F takes King G3 and then Sia h4h5 H6 H7
yeah I'm just gonna quickly run that
pump the board and this bishop is so
strong because it helps your promotion
square and stops the opponent from
pushing the pawns up the board so that
Bishop on E5 it is a stellar piece and I
feel like well this king is wide open
for black here maybe this king is gonna
become dead at some point right like
they're gonna be a bunch of checks
available especially if you take on G4
this Pawn will take back and The Rook F2
checks rookie one to follow so I'm not
liking this position uh forever are you
on chest two right now but I've never
seen it you got a skull over the King
right there if you are you on the new
update what is this I do what I want you
know I just hide it until the moment's
right and I just feel like this King on
F7 it's In Harm's Way so I had to put
the skeleton out there I love it I love
it yeah we see King G3 it really is
gonna go south I think mvl this is like
textbook does anyone know the Berlin
better than a guy like mdl I seem to
recall some of his games where he's
played like 50 moves and draw you know
just just a demonstration of knowledge
oh wow and by the way this evil bar went
Sky High right there so B5 somehow a
mistake and I'm guessing it's because
the C yeah he's saying Take Me I'll Go
Rook C1 I'll win this Pawn I'll win that
pawn so now white has two unopposed
passers and black has none
yeah the pawns are just not mobile for
uh Lu yipping here so I think mvl is
looking really comfortable here with the
white pieces uh Robert but you know
looking at all the boards I'm actually
curious if uh
if you think that game up in the top
left is as decisive as it looks because
Wei ye again with those white pieces is
looking like it could be a convincing
Advantage here Wei is a beast five out
of five in the protesting I mean look at
this last move too uh his last bunch of
moves he played Queen C1 if we go back
in time he's down to pawn let's just
trade a queens that Queen's not going
back it's a problem so we see a trade
then the night goes to B5 black plays
Knight A6 he just develops he continues
your plan you called for it and it
happened black is moving the same pieces
and the king is still in the center and
look at this F6 give me that King takes
Knight C so that's an unexpected move
your knight was supposed to cover but as
she captures in comes the rook and the
King on E6 speaking of kings that are a
problematic piece I'm gonna have to do
this again I'm sorry this King it's
really in trouble here on E6 there we go
the Chad's gonna love that one perfectly
uh perfectly used as well because yeah I
mean white down upon but it doesn't even
matter you can take it back if you want
the Seven's hanging but it might not be
about that anymore I think you could
even just develop yeah and I uh see that
Rook takes B7 was in fact played I was
putting too many of those emojis on the
board thank you for the pawn this bishop
may help in the attack as well Rook C8
the one idea let's give this check down
here you just don't allow it I I oh my
goodness oh kidding me
Bishop to C7
oh that's unreal
what like I was thinking what do I do I
can't move my king here because this
Pawn maybe I play F3 to try to boot this
Knight out of here he says not a single
ounce of counter play for you if you
bring your king back I'll give you a
check so your king is gonna have to run
away no matter what this is sick stuff
geez well I mean it's looking great for
way Yi
um not only are the moves coming in you
know one after the other but he just
seems to be in a flow Robert he is
looking so smooth so far in this PCL uh
mvl is looking fantastic thus far I mean
I guess we we haven't taken a look at
that uh Chris shook game right that's
the last the last game for us to check
in on because that that's really going
to dictate how this round goes yeah
because in the top bottom right we see
Maxine versus Sheila Grove he's well on
his way to victory in the top left Wei
similarly in charge and then that leaves
us with a top right game and the bottom
left both of them have about level
positions let's go to that Alexander
Grisha game that you are calling for
because Amman this is an absolute mess I
see that black and white both have Five
Pawns but excuse me what in the world
this is bowling I see just a split
everywhere
yeah this just looks like
um you know some of the worst pawns that
you could imagine versus some of the
worst development you can imagine so
that's why I think this is one of the
most misleading 0.00
valuations ever because I can't believe
it's sitting there like nothing's
happening you know minding its own
business the eval bar doesn't seem to
care meanwhile I'm looking at this I'm
seeing you know long castle for example
The Bishop's under attack Bishop E6
looks likely you know Pawn to F4 to kick
the Knight be careful don't want to
allow Knight to F3 well he does a
temporary exchange like maybe this is
what it was all zeros because we have an
opposite color Bishop position but I'm
on let's let's hold back for a second
where's this King going if you go to C7
up Goes The Rook to D7 with check and
the bishop is tied down to this Pawn if
the King goes here well you're just in
your Bishop's path so I feel like you're
right that all zeros is extremely
misleading unless there's some obvious
draw that I'm missing I feel like why
did you not I was looking at Bishop D6 I
was actually analyzing Bishop T6 here
you're a Madman you're okay let's bring
up analysis board Amman madman Hamilton
uh gives up a bishop for free it seems
but after King E7 with the fork a month
that's six stuff I've I've just saying
if you tell me it's 0.00 I'm gonna find
out why
it's a lot easier when I start by
knowing the evaluation but even this
doesn't look that clear right like a
rook D7 check King takes which Pawn do I
take all of them
like I mean I guess for black it's kind
of obvious you're gonna play Rook Cafe
and then just start vacuuming on the f
file
um and just see what's left over at the
end because you've gonna you're gonna
have a past E Pawn or maybe past the H
Pawn right and white will get a past a
pawn very lucky Bishop D6 suggested by
you spotted by shuyi you two are on the
same page it's a different Universe this
is great play by the Chinese Grandmaster
this is why I think rating gaps can be
misleading by the way Maxine versus
Schiller did officially just win his
game uh not surprised by that result but
um yeah this is just great stuff from
shui and I was gonna say that 2500
versus 2750 of course in a match
Advantage 2750 but in a single game
there's no reason why shui cannot handle
the super Grand Master for the blitz so
let's get on out of here as Alexander
Grisha Ponders his decision because Wei
in immense time travel against Katarina
lock no he is better and he needs to win
because Maxine Shirley grav took down
Louis ping on uh the bottom right there
so let's go back to the top left because
in time travel mistakes happen but white
is clearly better
that's right yeah and you know we've
been seeing so many good things about
Wei because there are so many good
things to say but katarini Lucknow has
managed to not only stay reasonably
level in this position but find a way to
nearly trap that Bishop on C7 and get
way low on the clock so that his
decisions are trickier to make
and look at this opposite color Bishops
and even material but not even placement
of Bishops look at this Rook it's going
to come over here and go after this pawn
bishop takes G6 will be a tactical
threat after Rook h8 but E5 Kettering
like no strikes in the center she wants
E4 to shut down this bishop
yeah and she's defending H7 with the
Rook from A7 really nice
activating along this but if Rook D7
then there's Rook A8 so look at where
you go he's trying to cause problems for
the black king and she goes King E6 15
seconds for way he's got a move what's
he gonna do Mom
well at this point I think he probably
knows most of the advantage has been
lost
um E4 is a little a bit annoying maybe I
was gonna say Bishop on B3 would be
great so maybe bishop A4 to B3
um that's actually really nasty so eight
oh I don't love that because you're
putting your Pawn on a light square but
maybe there's no stopping A3 next
mm-hmm that's right I'm looking at G4 I
feel like I like G4 G5 that looks really
appealing and Rook A5 she's barely
holding everything and your move comes
into play this bishop I get trapped him
on yeah strangely enough like you could
definitely see that dark Square Bishop
going down here Rook h8's also an idea
again oh and then G5 because the Rook
has to go to A7 defend you play G5 only
safe squares G7 but that Rook will be
cut off from the H7 Pawn Wei and amont
Hamilton they're playing great moves
here but six seconds for the Chinese
super Grand Master and nearly 30 for
black oh he's barely getting his moves
off
yeah that was a good move Bishop G7
first in order to prevent Rook h8 so
lachno is up to task here a quick
analysis board please because after King
F7 Rook A8 is possible with Bishop takes
D5 check I'm not sure if that was good
but if Rook takes a bishop D5 was check
first and then you take the Rook but
only one extra Pawn probably not good
enough so instead we see the Rook slide
of B8 and then up to B7 he's just
keeping the bishop on the board and uh
oh that's bad news for the black king
and Bishop oh the bishop is in such a
bad spot here G5 and Rook F7 is
essentially gonna win the piece and
there might even be mate here remember
oh my goodness so G8 is mate it's
Checkmate she walked right into it
and she now sees it and she is going to
throw on the towel look at where you go
Katrina lock no super strong player but
way Yi is Unstoppable in the Pro chess
League he is you know when you're
feeling it you're feeling it and we see
uh a win there by way Yi I mean how many
times have we said that in the protest
League uh six exactly
we have said it six times but Juan June
right now uh she is in time trouble
against Alexander buckrow Mutual time
trouble so let's go into that one
because we have a material imbalance
where black has a rook that's in the top
right black has a rook against a knight
and two pawns who's King is safer and
why I'm not sure I'm on
I I love White's positioning you know B3
um you know just stay on the the light
squares here I feel like in the long
term this should be a great position for
white but black could sort things out
tactically if uh if we see some blenders
but long term this should be definitely
winning for what yeah you see the queen
of Bishop lined up but the open H file
with Rook D1 check to follow I mean this
king is forced back the bishop will be
forced back to F1 and neither side has
much time 10 seconds for black right now
he doesn't know what to do Bishop F1 is
easy and there's no Queen H3 because
your Bishop is hanging with check I
imagine and the black king gets mated
so maybe King A8 set that up let's just
get out of the track I don't know F4 was
kind of a threat so The Rook comes back
to the last Rank and now White's King is
feeling safe and sound that's right yeah
um we might even see G4 get played but
remember as soon as you start moving
these pawns exactly switch to the H file
and try to get something going there
there must be a way to get the queen to
B6 that's what I'm looking for dream
square is Queen to B6 and queen A7
Checkmate so how do you get this queen
on over there
yep no this is whoa he goes for the
sacrifice here but uh that's a little a
little premature Queen takes C5 even
could be played
but simple chess can you no no Knight C7
the king would go up to A7 and then you
could have taken everything but this is
desperate for buck Corona is giving away
all his pieces and this Knight can even
drop back before
uh where is the easiest knockout you
could even take care at some point yeah
exactly like you don't want to do it
when The Rook song f8 which is funny but
yeah she's done a good job here and now
yeah I think the uh the game is in hand
and that's it you take this Knight check
and you get a queen it's going to be a
win for the Women's World Champion Jun I
think you can resign safely after this
you only have a few checks but Queen D5
eliminates any more checks and we
actually are being informed that earlier
in this game Alexander buckrow missed
something huge so he had a big chance
that was overlooked and we'll just let
this game conclude and while it does I
move 24 we're told uh you know she's
just checkmated but I'll move 24 there
was a missed opportunity for buckrow he
went Bishop to E7 but Amman C5
um there's just a pin down the D file
and he overlooked that you only have
five seconds I guess yeah the time
playing a big factor in this game as
well but hey that is uh that's just a
pin plain and simple Robert yeah no
that's something you would expect him to
see and unfortunately in his time
trouble it looks like he'd actually had
a minute and 20 seconds so he had plenty
of time to spot that but unfortunately
he missed it and now all four games are
done and it's good news once again for
the Shanghai Tigers Alexander grishook
held to a draw after that lovely Bishop
D6 move that you found for shuyi so that
means as we see here board one way or
two Jew and June they took down their
opponents in time trouble and then
Maxine Russia legrall the only player
for the blitz to strike so Aman as we
look at those four matchups I mean what
do you make of it another win for the
Tigers
yeah I think the Tigers are in I mean it
seems obvious to say they're ahead in
the match so obviously they're in a
great position but I just think that uh
grishook and then VL when you think
about the progression their opponents
are only gonna get tougher and tougher
so if you look at their results thus far
they've had a few draws uh in the first
round Richard with another draw here
those are all points left on the table
against weaker opponents things should
only get tougher for them and an even
lineup like the one that the Shanghai
tigers have with you know kind of
similarly rated players on most boards I
think that lineup gets better and better
as things go on but you see this round
right here leading by example Jew engine
wins on the top boards uh not a bad
round for white pieces would you would
you say Robert a great round three and a
half out of four and well way Yi gets it
done June June gets it done so for the
Shanghai Tigers we see they are leading
the way two out of two for Wei one half
out of two for Jew and June she Drew
Kettering no and beat the board for
Alexander bakrow and on the other Squad
The Blitz only one out of two for
grishook not terrible right that happens
but you need more from your top board
definitely yeah you you want uh grishook
and mvl be performing a little bit
better uh back row uh probably quite
expected unfortunately to have zero
points out of two he played the top two
players for the Shanghai Tigers so his
games are actually going to get easier
be exciting to watch him in the next
couple rounds he's going to be playing
against the boards three and four and
the same with like no so uh you know as
the the rounds go on Robert the matchups
are going to get even closer and
obviously there's a lot on the line as
we need a comeback from the blitz here
if they're gonna have any chance yeah
right now we're talking about the Tigers
and the blitz but I want to make mention
of a bullet event that is coming your
way the February bullet brawl arena is
almost here if you missed last month's
bullet action don't miss the event on
Saturday February 25th your favorite
title streamers will be back with two
hours of action-packed bullet chess with
2 500 on the line that's this Saturday
February 25th at 10 A.M Pacific Standard
Time use the command brawl in chat for
all the details I'm on you gonna play
oh don't mind me just gonna be uh
marking that one down on my calendar
right here uh Robert last Saturday of
each month I played in the last one it
was a lot of fun I mean I really like
these these formats
um the arena format so like Arena Kings
but hey now we've got one for bullet I I
think the shorter the time control these
days the better for me Robert okay well
the short of time showed the worst for
me I'm an old man I got shaky wrists so
I'm gonna have to shake off this old
body take a little bit of a break and
win return we'll be back for the pro
chess League match-up between the
Shanghai tigers and the blitz round
three commences in just a few minutes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chess the weight of a win draw or loss
is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
that's a win for ABI Mani Mishra and you
see that he is pumped up
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh my gosh it Rooks the
game first no it's mate and look at the
smile on Alexi Serrano's face
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
let's go let's go
and we return to this Pro chess League
matchup between the Shanghai tigers and
the Blitz captained by blitzstream Kevin
boardy this matchup is very important
for the overall standings because in
this league you need three wins as a
team to make the playoffs and we have
some important dates ahead of us we are
just getting set in the regular season
only this is our second week the 24th we
have our All-Star Game the arena Royale
and then March 30th the 31st eight teams
make their way to the playoffs but for
ultimately four teams go to the
protesting finals in May so mon you
built a roster you have a team the
candid chess bras did you build them for
the long haul you think they can last
the full season
yeah I uh I mean obviously the playoffs
is exciting right getting to three wins
and uh I mean we have the arena Royale I
think the chess bras of course are going
to be there Robert so you can count on
that but uh PCL finals that's what it's
all about and I think this season as fun
as it is it kind of ends before you know
it so enjoy it while it's here because I
can't wait for the playoffs playoffs
we're talking about the playoffs I'm
excited for them and I think the
Shanghai Tigers they're looking ready
for the playoffs because in this matchup
after eight total games have been played
two rounds of action Wei two out of two
Juan June one now for the two and the
rest of the Shanghai Tigers chipping in
so Amon as we head towards the third
round here what the blitz needed
differently
yeah I mean I think the blitz uh right
now are looking at uh absolute necessity
for their top words to lead by example I
I think we shook in mvl need to be
leaned on here but look for back row to
start stealing some points right he's
down there with no point so far but he's
had the toughest games Robert so I think
that uh look for back road to try to
score one out of two in these next games
that would be big for the team the mvl
and grishook uh you know they need to
put some points on the board and we're
about to get some super Grand Master
clashes because we keep talking about
Wei Yi and his perfect score
um excuse me black against Maxine vashir
lagrav uh that is not exactly an easy
pairing but way he did take down Leonard
Dominguez a week ago with the black
pieces
that's right no you I mean obviously the
colors are are relevant here you have
the the white pieces uh usually an
advantage no matter what or for any
player in the professional chess sense
but when it comes to a 10 minute plus
two second increment game Robert you're
able to create chances for both sides uh
kind of regardless that's true and
Alexander Grisha gets the white pieces
he'll need uh to make magic happen for
the Bliss but we are gonna start I was
gonna say with our all board one matchup
because I keep forgetting that Maxine
versus bore two for the blitz that's
what happens when you have a one-two
punch at the super GM level with grishuk
and maximum Maxim's actually the higher
rated player in classical chess his
classical rating has dipped to 27.36 I'm
not used to seeing that Amana he wears
to seeing him being a 2770.
that's right no it's uh extremely
unusual but uh mvl of course donning
that Blitz Jersey there which looks
pretty slick by the way shout out to
Kevin bordee for those
um he's he's up basically with the white
pieces this is probably you know one of
his biggest games of the round because
he's facing someone who's never lost in
the protest league so far Robert and way
he's played some tough opposition as
well it's not like he's collecting
points out here he's he's earning some
tough wins he really is and he's
avoiding the Berlin so we just saw
Maxine Russia legra play a great game in
the Berlin and now we see him play a
kind of more open Spanish with his Pawn
on e4 is not captured early the Queens
are still on the board and there's a lot
of tension here in the position from E5
to D4 the E4 Pawn all that stuff so I'm
on way playing instantly he has more
time than he started with we're used to
seeing that from mvl he is one of those
lightning quick players but it seems
like way well with thinnest preparation
absolutely yeah I think both of these
guys especially were dealing with e45
you know re Lopez stuff both of these
guys are well aware of uh what's going
on here so definitely not surprised to
see uh Wei with some good preparation
because it's almost like the onus is on
uh the player with the white pieces
Robert to sort of make something of the
position if it just you know you're both
showing your theory and ends up as a
draw you're not totally satisfied keep
in mind that the the situation and the
match right now also dictates a little
bit what needs to happen mvl probably
needs a full point more than way Yi does
for his team so that might force him to
choose some more risky lines that keep
things going keep some play on the board
and you don't want to go all in if
you're the blitz or you just need a one
point win in this round two and a half
one F that would be good because that
gives you an entire fourth round to
strike you just don't want to lose this
game if you're Maxim and I think we're
going to see it I was about to say G5
and night sacrifice here this is wild
stuff the black king is open but the D4
Pawn is loose and whose theoretical
knowledge is better that's the essential
question because I'm on we had
experiences like this when you make one
inaccuracy you just lose the game
because black is up a piece but then
Black's King is also in danger
exactly it's like you make one wrong
move and all of a sudden white goes Rook
A3 Rook G3 and you know you're like
getting mated by force or something so
you really do have to be careful uh in
these lines but the the eval bar you can
see creeping a little bit north of uh
equal there in White's favor
um Bishop D5 played and I'm curious what
we're gonna see here because mvl is
playing this for a reason he knows it in
and out but let's be real way Yi is not
playing G5 Robert walking in without any
clue what he's doing and then Bishop D5
happens there's a stared on a pieces I'm
looking what happens if I take can I
afford it he plays C6 instantly this guy
has prepared the line and what about
Rook A3 like that is a rook lift that
looks very appealing to my eyes uh is
there anything wrong with bringing this
Rook up to A3 that looks dangerous for
the black king
hey that's that's all I got Robert I'm a
rook A3 Rook G3 kind of guy
um dangerous oh look at that
hey you know believable yeah I like the
move uh I love Rook A3 it just feels uh
like a strong move without much
calculation just into intuitively uh it
makes a good impression
yeah if you take this bishop 1 D5 Rook
G3 all of a sudden this king is just
being hunted down the Knight can't move
your queen is behind it uh the bishop
takes Knight is Discovery and if you go
to the H file I can just take your
knight and then bring my queen in this
is a typical ladder Checkmate along the
g h files
that's right I mean this game could be
over before it starts what do you play
after A3 because it makes the move
C6 looks strange if C6 has the intention
to take the bishop after Rook A3 if
you're not able to take the bishop he's
probably a bad sign already
I guess this King will have to Escape
right somehow the king will have to run
this way is that so he played Rook E3 so
The Rook lift is still happening
but there's the clearly the wrong choice
because it went from plus a little bit
or whatever to now minus a lot
right and I guess if I'm just thinking
intuitively like you know my Rook on
anyone's doing nothing and Brooklyn E1
clearly is so I'd rather if I'm going to
G3 anyway or H3 I'd rather use my Rook
that's just not participating so not
sure if there's a specific reason that
he chose uh the e-brook instead because
if you had that choice in front of him I
mean you'd always pick the a rook so he
must have something in mind or he's
recalling some variation where it was
definitely the e-rook being used because
otherwise Robert MPL would choose the a
rook I mean any day of the week yeah
just to quickly show something that if
the black king is going to escape this
way you want your rook in the E file so
let's say Rook A3 Rook E8 Rook G3 okay
I'm running with my king and maybe this
is still you know clearly okay for white
uh but you want the Rook on E1 so that
if this capture ever happens you take
back and open the e-file to Checkmate
the king so that's another reason why
bring your undeveloped Rook into the
game would have been better but we will
leave Wei Yi to his task it's better
with the eval bar he may be out of his
preparation he may not be sure so let's
look at the other boards because every
single game in this league is of equal
importance every team member contributes
the overall result in the top right I
see a hideous Pawn structure for Zhu and
June but white is missing that fee and
keto Bishop the light Square Bishop took
a knight on C6 in the bottom left what's
the material count even but with
opposite colored Bishops and queen cell
on the board anybody's game there and I
like by the way the Alexander buckrow in
the bottom left his last move A5 we may
see another Rook lift in that game
yeah that would be really fun as well I
think the you know the top right uh
their Jew engine against Alexander
grishook is such an epic matchup there
um and it's so imbalanced as well
because you mentioned you have to give
up that light Square Bishop in order to
the pawn structure like that so
one of the biggest imbalances even
though that eval bar is right around
zero yeah what a what an interesting
position uh they have between Alexander
grishock and Juan Jun uh because it
looks like white has done nothing none
of the pieces except for the queen have
been developed uh but it's clear that
rashook is playing for the long term
Pawn structure uh June has these double
isolated C pawns and that's not good
news for her right like that's just a
structural permanent weakness it's not
going anywhere and by the way in the top
left Wei Yi just moved his King to G7 so
uh why don't we go back there because
that game is fascinating and that's
where they actually probably Remain the
most interesting one for the time being
King G7 he's walking into the fire what
about Rook G3
I mean
I'm gonna need an explanation it looks
like he wants to move the Rook
and then prepare King
like almost Rook G8 I'm looking at and
you know if you go Bishop F6 or Bishop
H6 you just calmly take with the king is
that is that what's going on here
wow that is actually wildly brilliant
stuff and your point is a good one if
this Rook I'm actually not sure which
Square to go to h8 maybe G8 just because
that way at some point you might be able
to bring your Rook up or sacrifice it
for this bishop but Rook G8 and a bishop
takes F6 double check you would love to
take with your queen but you have to
take with your king and despite being
out in the open the Knight covers F3
checks and that means there's no good
check to make because you probably are
giving up too much material after takes
takes your king steps back to G7 because
you go to E7 that's mate in one don't do
that that's right not be advisable but
your king goes here and after Queen F7
there's King I think HC H6 unreal and
queen F4 Queen G5
if only if only I know so if Rook could
get to H3 and get after this King but
Rook A3 there's uh this move Queen H4 if
you play Rook H3 thank you for your
queen
ah the darnchest.com bugs you can't take
it because oh just the PIN
he played for G8
what a brilliancy
I like that and I think it's in moments
like this they really start to
appreciate you know if you could grab
that Rook on A1 and throw it on E1 we
would have the exact same position right
if the Rook had lifted from A3 to G3 and
it's so important because Knight E2
check is a square that that queen always
has to guard so just you know down a few
lines if that Queen ever gets
sidetracked chasing a king giving checks
you just always have to worry about
Knight E2 so there are these small
subtleties that you're not thinking
about but the engine is saying that's
exactly why we don't love these modes
but look how important this is in this
variation if you're Queen F4 piling
maximum pressure against this Knight
exactly what Amman is talking about so
what Amman is saying is actually of
critical importance not just uh
something where uh blindly saying it is
actually really really important because
Queen F4 would be a huge attack
potentially against this King the Knight
is pinned in multiple directions and
it's not possible because of a night
Fork oh that's actually a ridiculous
four like give me all of the pieces here
with that fork that's nasty yeah that's
uh they call that a royal Fork
I don't know but I call that a a fork
for sure family Fork I think I think
it's family just give me that night oh I
like that too man Robert's just emoting
on the whole screen right now yeah you
know people think I'm this serious guy
all the time but I can throw in an emote
every now and then
Rook G8 played such a nasty move to face
I mean mvl he's got that Rook on G3 but
that's it you know you look at his
position he's running out of pieces to
actually participate let's not forget
Robert there's a whole hanging Bishop on
D5 like like down a line somewhere
Black's gonna finally have a moment and
be like oh yeah I can just take that oh
speaking of just taking that can you
just take this Rook we were looking at
this variation the queen takes takes up
seven the king just runs to H6 and it is
actually safe over here this is one of
those games where you know you look at
it like wow what brilliant sacrifices by
Maxime he's going after the king and
then when the king reaches H6 you're
like
um yeah so about those sacrifices uh
maybe maybe too much material has been
given to Black exactly you need to have
you know some amount of material that's
still on the chess board for you to mate
with and he's running out of available
uh suitors maybe this would have worked
in a Blitz game rather than a rapid game
because there's just too much time for
Wei to sit here and calculate and he
will take this Knight he will bring his
King around to H6 and I think he will
win this game but we will come back here
we should give other games some love
some attention uh this one has been
fascinating from the start and we'll
keep an eye out on this one between Wei
and Maxine versus but in the top right
we wanted to go to that game before but
we got distracted by the position in
this one Alexander Griff shook me he is
definitely in charge in this game in the
top right look at this Pawn structure we
said this a while back it doesn't matter
that white hasn't developed them on you
can't move those double isolated Pawns
yeah and it actually is so impressive to
me players that are able to take these
positions with the black pieces and play
them uh play them well because the
engine you see it's like not that
concerned you know small advantaged
white and when I look at this position I
think you know significant advantage to
White just so easy to play Bishop A3
Rook C1 like how are you even defending
that c Pawn if not full passivity with
Knight D7 but somehow you know the
engine and active players take these
positions and just you know thrust
forward like F4 coming soon and even
though you're giving up so many squares
you're just tossing pawns and pieces
forward I mean that's just how you play
with the black pieces here so uh I if we
see that kind of gameplay by wenjin
loose radio sack pawns open the position
up that could be the remedy here uh to
compensate for that awful Pawn structure
yeah Bishop A3 looks obvious but you
might be right among just throw your
pawns forward I'm not sure which one and
when to do it but push them forward and
go for the attack and while Alexander
grishook is thinking here we like his
Pawn structure let's take a look at how
his wife is doing Katarina Lucknow and
her husband Alexander grishook are
teammates they're both Grand Masters
they're both superstars in the Chess
World and I see in the bottom right she
is holding nothing back against Liu
yaping and a week ago when the Shanghai
Tigers took on the archbishops I was
saying Louis pink he loves these calm
solid positions this is anything but
that with the H file being pried open
for this Rook it's developed on its
initial square and is this queen going
to be able to join the party for
potentially for a checkmating attack
that's right and I think the arrows that
you just indicated were scary enough
that even though it's a slow plan I
think that Queen on H7 and mate on H1
was enough for f takes G3 to be the
preference I mean I would almost never
want to play F takes G3 here look at the
bishop on A7 lined up directly against
the king that looks scary but I think it
was born out of necessity now for white
however if you can somehow manage to get
like 93 Rook F1 there are some weak
squares D5 F5 and of course Rook F1
hitting F7 there's there's some
possibilities for white but just not
that easy to to manage that and I guess
it wasn't that easy for way Yi we're
gonna zoom out of here we want to focus
more on this one but look at the top
left of your screen there's a king on E5
this is not King of the Hill that King
is gonna die on that Hill what is it
doing out there as Maxine versus simply
going to Checkmate Wei Yi whose King is
here and there's still The Rook
surviving
what the heck is going on I mean you
have to praise the uh The Confidence
from mvl here this is insane actually
after like Queen to G5 which looks like
a move white has a lot of very decent
options I was looking at Rook E7 of
course there's also F4 just picking up
the queen but what the heck did he do he
didn't take the Rook right he went King
to E5 and then after Rook takes F7 the
queen joined the party over here uh
that's
I'm surprised I mean there's just no way
where King E5 that just can't feel like
a good move to play I don't think he
played it out of any sort of wishfulness
I think he was upset to have to play it
but I'm wondering and I you know would
love to hear eventually what he missed
in this variation because this looks all
pretty forced the queen should take this
Pawn here after King H6 there's not a
single other check this one gets blocked
here this one gets blocked with the
queen
right and you know King h8 worst case is
a draw right like it's nothing nothing
like crazy crazy I think you can still
play your queen H4 stuff right yeah I
guess here The Rook does finally lift
off and maybe the king is in grave
danger oh check on H5 first yeah that's
a good point you know what it is
possible from far away that he missed in
this position that Rook A3 that there is
a move like Queen H4 but I'm sure maybe
there's something else but it's easy to
miss from far away much easier when we
have the eval bar we know that but in
the live position I mean this King on
what just happened here Rook G5 was
played to block the check because the
king went back to E6 uh then you just
take this bishop and you threaten this
pawn and this Checkmate and ah yeah
that's no good
but you gotta admire the you know
bravado from mvl just plays such
enterprising chess like he risked a lot
by doing this and it's paying off for
him here in the blitz we're gonna be
happy if he can pull out a victory uh
literally from the jaws of defeat there
and hand way his first defeat in the
protest
R.I.P to the Perfect Score R.I.P to this
King that is sitting on E6 I mean that
King is just an unhappy piece over here
look at it it's just out in the open sad
news for the Shanghai Tigers you really
wanted this King to survive but it is
not going to it's just out in the open
yeah looking at that Bishop on B6 and
it's like you can move the Knight
literally anywhere nice discovered check
but you can't attack anything it's just
so sad
and well if that goes the blitz's way
they will cut into their deficit
Alexander grishook slight Advantage but
things have turned around in board four
suddenly Lou ya Pig we left that game
and we have to go right back there
because he has a huge Advantage it would
appear against Catherine luck no so her
attack has been pushed back and
White's not even up a single piece but
it says like plus three here
and the weird thing about this position
is like the Knight on H5 is a really bad
piece like it can't I mean unless you're
sacking can't go to G3 F4 Knight F6 back
I mean you're just not doing anything
Knight on F1 covers H2 that's the only
weakness in White's position at all so
this is kind of what I was hinting at
when we were here last is that I could
see this somehow turning around for
white because fundamentally the position
is solid but black was you know
threatening some Checkmate ideas now
that the Checkmate ideas are essentially
non-existent I see this as you know just
a great position for white and I'm
already thinking about sacking this
Knight Robert what do you think where
are you gonna suck it how are you gonna
get rid of it
I'm gonna do nothing Rook D3 maybe oh
you
you're a sick man you're just going for
checkmate one I'm A sly dog what can I
say
well yeah one for the uh going for The
Rook d8 instead and it looks like Knight
D3 Robert was played in the game and and
that is a bit of a concession
and well A5 play quickly by luck knows
she wants her Bishop out to Asics but
look at I told you he's a very solid
player like he can handle tactics when
they arise but he's saying sorry you
wanted your Bishop to go where exactly
go to A6 I'll grab your G4 Pawn try to
trade those Queens off if you castle
kingside that's where your attack was
and now your king is actually open
Louisa ping up a minute Plus on the
clock and according to the engines about
plus two in the position I don't think
it's that simple I really think there's
a lot left in this game but he can bring
his Rook to D3 in the future and then
just barrel down the D file
that's right that's right and we have
some results as well uh Robert in some
of the other games I see a draw there on
back rows board against chuyi and uh way
Yi speaking of that game he he has
actually lost in fact against uh mvl so
just a a very very slick game that was
uh super impressive for him to get that
win out of that
yeah fortunate but it doesn't matter for
the team they don't care how it gets
done as long as it gets done that's a
win for Maxine vashilagrobe and a good
draw with black for Alexander buckrow
against Shu Yi so the blitz have a
chance right now can I really like no in
some trouble but I was in a grishook I
mean look at that ending that he has he
is trying to slow play this he's trying
to outplay his opponent the Women's
World Champion June June and I think she
knows she's in trouble here because
these pawns remain E5 is loose Rook to
A1 let's swap off at least one pair of
Rooks and then your resulting end game
is terrible for black
yeah and I mean basically grishook has
done the absolute best thing possible
which is trade queens that is White's
goal this entire game
um so even though the material looks to
still be level big Advantage for a
grishook in a practical sense because
Rook A1 can happen looking to trade all
the Rooks and even that end game is no
easy task for black to defend yeah black
can't attack anything and why you just
go out for those pawns don't be
surprised this Knight goes to A5
eventually the King goes up to C4 but F4
you sense a bit of desperation but I
like it just trying to get some activity
here and well is fgfg then The Rook
slamming down on F2 is that a threat
that's the big question
yeah and I think overall it kind of is a
threat
um like it's it's annoying enough for
sure if you play King B1 I think the
Rooks double
um but it is an idea to play King B1
Force the Rooks to double which takes it
away from the file so now that we've
seen F4 you kind of drag that Rook off
the f file because previously I think
King B1 was the intention to grab that
E5 Pawn unpin yourself then the E5 Pawn
would be hanging and if Black's Rook
just goes back like you know Jew engine
Place broke A2 to A7 you kind of have
some ideas of maybe taking on E5 there
so
um maybe King B1 is an option here
definitely isn't now shut down to 40
seconds and we are keeping an eye out
for the board 4 game but right now this
is where our attention should remain 30
seconds now for Grisha he's not sure
does he trade a pair of Rooks does he
play the king to B1 it's not an easy
choice to make but I'm worried about his
clock he's a great bullet player of mine
we know that but he is spending so much
time right now
yeah it's like uh you know he has a
special talent and ability to play
positions with no time on the clock but
as his friends and teammates you never
want to actually see him need to
demonstrate it
no and he plays Rook F1 he kind of is
make keeping the status quo please take
me on G3 I take back we'll trade of
Rooks in a different file E5 remains
weak these remain double nicely The Rook
on A2 it looks impressive imposing it's
not doing all that much but I love
Bishop F6 watch out for an E4 push at
some point so The Rook now goes to A1 a
little tricky play from both sides
that's right yeah I I like it uh now
that there's no Rook F2 coming F takes
G3 is not really as big of a threat
um but the one thing is if things get
traded and black moves the bishop again
now there's probably no Rook F1 to stop
The Rook F2 invasion
and she brings her Rook back to eight
kind of keeping the tension alive and if
there are some trades maybe black can
play G5 of course not with the Rooks
thing on H1 but at some moment you
consider in King F7 King E6 and bring
this King up and if you take maybe it's
the black king that enters the position
and causes white some problems over here
that's right I was thinking that white
might look to reroute the Knight on C4
to the E4 Square hovers G3 hovers F2
that looks like the ideal Square for the
Knight also hitting C5 so I think net on
C4 it looks amazing blockading the pawn
I think it's time to move that
and a big problem for black is King
should belong on E6 can't go to F7 you
walk into a pin so G6 played instead and
it's not easy to make progress here for
white but he does bring the Knight into
E4 your idea maybe bishop E7 she does
that trading the Rooks by force I'm on
is there enough material remaining to
pick off these weak Pawns
it's tough to say it's a clear Advantage
um it's one of those positions where the
engine is just gonna scream raw for the
rest of the game but uh grishook is
going to be trying to win here
um he can try to be tricky but honestly
speaking I think that that do engine
should be expected to make a draw here
and I think we'll go back and forth for
a while as the players play in time
travel let's quickly Zoom to board four
we just saw a bishop takes F7 check by
Lou yaping the King goes to d8 for
Kettering lock no in the bottom right so
it is extra material now for the
Shanghai Tigers board forward you see in
the top right the players their kings
are in opposition great play thus far by
Jew and June in Alexander grishek's time
trouble but he's pushing forward and
trying to win so let's go back into that
game just because they do not have much
time and shook's King has won King of
the Hill
yeah I I still think that uh
when Jin has has done a fantastic job
here like
it looks really bad but I think it's
mostly like just a visual disadvantage
yeah she just plays these moves back and
forth there's no stopping that the
Knight covers the other Pawn what
somehow grocery needs is to get a knight
towards the king or these pawns and
that's why he's rerouting it but there's
nowhere good to go
that's right
um just thinking for a moment there that
Bishop if white could get Bishop C7 and
I thought that might be an achievement
um so there's a moment where she played
Bishop E7
still the position is getting better and
better and I I think that right now
wenjin is in that mode where she's
shuffling so as grishook you can try to
create a position where you get your
opponent to just get rhythmic about
their moves and all of a sudden hit them
with something what was E4 that was
shocking to my eyes because I thought
really well he was gonna bring his King
there and they bring the bishop around
at some point but he plays E4 that makes
the E5 Pawn feel safer but I guess this
is what he's aiming for is Ken is King
run up the entire Queen side into B7
yeah I mean that's the only plan left
because he needed to play E4 before
doing that otherwise black would play
King F5 King G4 and call it a day
and here comes that King first keeping
the Knight stuck here
if the king where's the Knight going A4
but the bishop can always slide back to
D6 so maybe there is no progress to make
but with Druid down to three seconds two
seconds she's barely uh you know keeping
alive on the clock right now it's scary
territory yeah and you can see the king
wants to get to C4 with Knight A4 that's
what I thought we were gonna see
I thought so as well and well they
continue to go back and forth maybe now
the king is coming it is
that's right
and Bishop E3 waiting for the right
moment
and I wonder if like
that usually what you'll see is if
grishook is sort of set on that plan he
might be making some quick moves now
because he's not sure about it he
doesn't want to commit to a plan that
might liquefy into a draw immediately so
instead he's like moving pieces randomly
and he's using that extra time to keep
thinking about that main idea right and
his pawns on e4 so the king couldn't get
out but you would love to be able to
push D4 at some opportune moment
especially with the bishop getting on
this diagonal uh so he removed that as
an option he's going back and forth back
and forth but Juan Jun she's too strong
to experience to freak out and make a
mistake she knows that all she needs to
do is Shuffle and Shuffle she will do by
the way Katarina lock no did lose that
game will show the final position as
soon as this one ends because it was a
nasty final position
and I mean at some point I feel like
you've got to try King A4 and something
to A5
the only other plan is Knight to A4 and
King C4 which hasn't well and tried yet
oh wait a second your idea Bishop d8
King A5 why is it going that way
he's going the wrong way but also Bishop
B6 there why not King A4 Bishop B6 yeah
the king could have come up the board
let's just quickly go back in the
position bring up the analysis board
there uh that was surprising he brought
his King the exact right way and then
after this he could play Bishop d8 King
A5 King bring your king forward yeah it
did it looked like that was risk-free
basically
yeah and if we go to the game like the
Kings Island C4 but there's nowhere for
the king to go for a knight B6 check get
the king out of there go right back
right he had it he had the exact
position he wanted
and you have to be careful with
three-time repetition now
um it's not something you can actively
try to prevent but you might not saying
that I feel like we've been here almost
before yes but Jew and June she's still
holding the balance but it gets scary
with the King going to A4 and Bishop A5
but he's he's spending too much time
there might be a 50 move rule before he
could take a pawn because we see he has
a winning Advantage but maybe if he
makes one more mistake and he plays
Bishop d8 here comes the game he needs
to grab a pawn or move a pawn of his own
the bishop is in the worst spot ever on
B8 it's walking into a king on B7
oh
why is he not bringing the king up
A5 finally there we go and the advantage
is Sky High he finally figured out that
his King could walk in the position and
he needs to grab a pawn if he does not
take a piece by 15 moves when was the
last pawn move it was
ah so long ago I can't even scroll up in
time but there a piece has been captured
and now he's gonna win yeah that Bishop
is the worst the only trick this bishop
takes G5
otherwise this is a walk in the park
wait a second
oh oh the Knight can't get in
and now the king can go back and forth
nice incredible cannot lose Tempe and
that is the inherent limitation that we
don't go King D7 because look at her
distant opposition a brilliant save if
she can continue holding this for June
June she was lost at that moment and now
you have to take that's four so the good
news is her moves are a bit forced here
right
King D6 and just amazingly you can't
get that pawn like King A5 King A6 try
to lose time oh distant opposition
go King I guess no King D7 because King
B6 King D6 you want to keep that
opposition
yeah this is the most uh you know
studious right King E7 still the distant
opposition there
amazing oh look at that because this is
exactly why you want opposition is now
you're creating the opposition King B7
King D7 this King cannot inch anywhere
you would love your Pawn back on B2 to
waste the turn you have no Tempo to
spare a draw by repetition and Alexander
grishek is super unhappy I mean he is
just beside himself because he knows he
had what should have been a winning
position that was so impressive by Juan
Jun because rishook I I was I'm trying
to hand credit to everyone here because
that was just an unreal game Robert
first it looked like grishook deserved
all the credit what progress that he
finally made he got to a winning
position and where was his big mistake
right here he needs to be able to take
Knight D6 and then bring his King here
so if the king A6 if the King goes in C7
that looks like the problem the Knight
takes the bishop the king takes back and
then King B6 white creates the
opposition if your king goes back thank
you very much for the pawn I win the end
game and you have no other moves you can
jettison the pawn here but that's still
will not help the cause so Iman he
needed to waste a move with King to
Asics very difficult to play when King
B7 feels obvious because after King A6
Bishop C7 uh the big difference here is
now King B7 and where does your Bishop
go if you go to D6 I still take you if
you go to d8 I take E5 if your king
moves I take C6 every move has a
drawback and it should be pointed out
something that we didn't really touch on
is like the reason that Grisha was so
upset with this position is because you
actually can't move the Knight as soon
as you move the Knight Bishop A5 Bishop
E1 Bishop takes H4 and guess what you're
gonna lose that position for sure so yes
it means that the Knight can't move
anywhere but B6 which he tried but it
just wasn't good enough wow what an
ending that was and now we know that
this round was tied two to two between
the Shanghai tigers and the Blitz and
that is not good news as Maxine
vashilograph somehow gets that win this
match could have gone entirely the
Shanghai Tigers way if we could have
scored that Victory uh butts right Lu ya
ping scores for the Tigers Maxine Russia
lagrav scores for the Blitz the other
two games were drawn but that was not
for lack of trying so as we head into
the fourth and final round we know that
the top scorers for each Squad include
Wei Yi and Zhu on June for the Tigers
and for the Blitz
he seems to be leading the charge for
the French team
definitely and you know you look at the
the Shanghai Tigers and their scores
thus far is just so balanced reflective
of the lineup that they've selected
right all four boards are scoring points
whereas you know just as the the lineup
is designed on the blitz side it's very
top heavy so going into this last round
Robert with a score of seven to five the
Shanghai Tigers only need one and a half
points that means the blitz need three
to one if they're gonna win this thing
so that's only for tie breaks uh three
and a half if they want to win this
thing outright obviously a gargantuan
task ahead of them for sure and for
those of us who missed it you could
check out that game between Lou yaping
and Kettering luck no he checkmated her
King on C5 so that was a brilliant
finish for the Shanghai Tigers board
four but the fourth and Final Round will
be here shortly so we're gonna step
aside for a moment the players will have
to shake off whatever unhappy memories
they just had and play a whole new game
we'll be right back for the fourth and
final round of this matchup between the
Shanghai tigers and the blitz here in
the protest League
where does that come from that kind of
even Keel like kind of level-headedness
I mean a lot of people get really big
headed and very very confident when they
like get on a roll and you're just like
I didn't play well
gotta be better next time
I mean you can never relax I mean I do
that so I don't relax I keep the same
amount of energy and concentration
during the tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the former World Blitz Champion
Alexander grishook he is playing the top
board for the blitz which is captained
by Kevin boardy he might be analyzing
that game still looking at ways he could
have won but that game is a thing of the
past Amman he has drawn all three of his
games in this match usually that's not
enough for a team to win your top Board
needs to score what does Alexander
grishook and The Blitz what do they need
to change to score an impressive 3-1
victory in this final round how can they
get it done
well first of all if they want to win
you know let's call it in regulation
here they're going to need a monstrous
three and a half points across these
four boards definitely I'm looking at
that uh final board because Louisa ping
should be the stronger player compared
to compared to Alexander by Crow so he
needs a big game back row on board four
definitely needs a big game and also
like no it feels like it just hasn't
been her match thus far but to end off
with a big win here turns everything
around
um but Zu Yi and uh Louis ping have been
so solid so the thing is I think they
need to be scoring at least one and a
half points on those those final two
boards mvl probably with the biggest
rating mismatch in this final round so
you know lot is on his shoulders here
and we haven't seen a win from Alexander
grishook which sounds insane to say so
the blitz need an all-around performance
because hey they need like three plus
points so it's not just one player that
needs to get it done it has to be a team
effort it will certainly need to be a
team effort for the blitz as we look at
the round four matchups because now it's
board one versus Board one all the way
through to four versus four so weigi and
Jew and June get the white pieces
against their super Grand Master
opponents Alexander Grisha and Maxine
Russia lagrav and then Kettering luck no
and Alexander buckrow they have not
scored too much one point between the
two of them but they get white against
shui and Luke and Louis Pig so I'm on
question for you if you're the blitz are
you happy to have black on the top two
and white in the bottom two or would you
prefer a little bit of a switcheroo
um I would say maybe at this point yes
um just because I think we shook in MBL
are strong enough players that they can
create winning Chances with the black
pieces whereas you know if you have your
board four with the black pieces a
stronger player might be able to just
kind of force them into drawish
territory too easily so
um I think this is the ideal setup for
the Blitz in terms of the color matchups
you know it's as much as you can hope
for
for sure well uh we know that for um I
was in a Grisha it was frustration
around the go now he takes on way and
Wei himself must be pretty upset because
he knew his opening preparation he must
have known he had an advantage and then
immediately after the preparation ended
he took a wrong turn and he lost that
game so with the white pieces do you
expect him to kind of try to force a
draw against Alexander grishek or do you
think grishook himself will play a
modern or something offbeat to avoid any
sort of forcing lines
I I was gonna say you know modern
Sicilian something like that
um might be the case from Grisha we have
an interesting matchup between two
players that didn't really have a good
time last round uh we see even at the
board yeah he used to actually be there
he left as soon as his match uh was
starting and now he plays the French
defense so two bad things from Alexander
grishook he he lost some time and then
he played the French
and I think that one might be a product
of the other you know going into tilt
but uh hey he's playing the French he's
representing the French uh lineup here
so hopefully some good vibes uh for his
team I mean last game almost feels like
such an anomaly when it comes to his
performance because he even had that
game uh in the bag it looked like just
second guessed himself and as you
mentioned may have misremembered some
prep
and if I'm the blitz I don't mind
Alexander grishek holding a draw here
because uh Maxine vashilagrove much
higher rated than June even though she's
having a good performance today and is a
super strong player you might have to
rely on Maxine to win with black and
then your bottom two boards both of them
have white so you need to cut this
two-point Gap immediately I think you
trust your players with the white pieces
and Trust Maxine with black do not take
the risk against Wei I think that's why
the French was chosen and right now a
solid start for Alexander grishook with
the black pieces he's also up on time
which is a rarity
that's right and I think if you're
looking at the overall board situation
it's tough to get three and a half
points I mean basically at that point
everybody just has to have an amazing
game amazing round but when you get into
3-1 territory all of a sudden you look
at the games you might be like okay mvl
gets a win uh maybe Lucknow gets a win
and draws on the other two boards and
that gets it done so you bring up a good
point that grishook in this game doesn't
need to go all out and do anything crazy
you're up against one of the highest
performing players in the PCL right now
you know might not be the best time to
pick a fight with the black pieces well
speaking of people trying not to pick
too big of a fight if we go to our
bird's eye view as this game just is
exiting the opening stage we see some
openings that look a bit more peaceful
than others in the bottom left shuyi
playing Grand Master Kennedy Lucknow
chose a Petrov and we know how solid
that opening is many of the Chinese
players the essay that opening because
it's look at it the symmetrical Pawn
structure in the bottom left it's com
territory but Katarina luck know she's
gonna try to get some wiggle room make
some small improvements but that's going
to be a long battle and in the top right
Amman I have to say even though Jew and
June you know has a slight pull in the
after the opening uh for now I think
it's a good choice by Maxine vasilograph
keep the tension alive don't let any
sort of liquidation happen play for the
long game
that's right yeah he's definitely I mean
someone on the blitz is gonna have to
take risks here you can't just play
Perfect chess and you know make a draw
you might have to take some some chances
offer some chances to your opponent if
they don't spot them don't capitalize or
play accurately then you get more
chances yourself so I think when your
team is down 7-5 everyone in the team
has to know that hey things might get a
little loose we might have to take some
risks here risk a loss in order to get
away and Katarina luck no using the
linear Dominguez method in the bottom
left H4 he played this exact opening
against Shanghai a week ago and the
bottom right the game is Alexander
buckrow and Lou yaping that has started
and I just want to give another shout
out to Lou ya ping who beat Kennedy luck
no with a nasty Checkmate we're gonna
send that to you in the chat right now
you can click on it and see the final
position for yourself it was a king out
in the open so Amon I think we should go
to Maxine versus game just because I see
pawns pushing D5 and F5 and it's an
awkward pawn shop structure but you it's
clear he's playing for a decisive game
he is he's trying to make something
happen there's uh no doubt in my mind
that
um has a great position here but you see
that pawn push to F5
the first thing I think of is you know
oh danger to the white king maybe some
uh aggressive play against the king but
then you start to look at the pieces and
there's no Rook on f8 to play Rook F6
there's no Bishop on D6 to you know hit
H2 it's actually kind of an empty attack
to me so when I see F5 no attack white
still possesses a dark Square Bishop all
of this leads me Robert to really enjoy
uh Jew and Jen's position so I think she
started out fantastically the next idea
other than just bringing the Rooks into
play would be to maybe move that Knight
on F3 actually try F3 yourself pick that
Knight on e4 out
and she plays B4 I mean I I really
believe that the blitz team strategy is
to win on this board and the pick up a
game with one of your two players with
the white pieces so I like Jew and
June's position I think Maxime is just
trying to pick an opening that makes us
a fight but the worst part for him is
June June seems unfazed she's actually
up over a minute on the clock she's
playing all the excellent moves you can
ask of her and she has a pair of Bishops
and if you ever take that gets rid of
Black's best piece this Knight is
clogging the center and you do not want
to take this bishop which isn't doing
all that much
yeah and you know there's an option here
to play moves like B5 C5 just get so
much space the Knight is going to drop
to d8 probably make its way to F7 where
it takes control the E5 square and maybe
mvl is gonna start getting freaky with
G5 G4 Robert because hey what else do
you have to do
I like the language that you're speaking
I'm gonna pardon your French with those
nasty lines you're showing that Knight
coming around to F7 looks like a bit of
an issue for white to deal with but I do
like the look of B5 and then you can
even plant your knight on an E5 and then
play F3 so I do feel like white can gain
some space but be careful not to
overextend the last thing you want to do
is play B5 then move your Rook
carelessly and drop this Pawn over on A3
so you have to look at the base of your
structure and already you see MBL
challenging Jew and June's position so
Knight date automatic Knight F7 looks
very likely next and yeah I do like
White's position but I feel like they're
still winning chances for blockers all
you could hope for against such a strong
player like June June yep love the
position for white here I'm even now
seeing that she's kept Bishop which
means Pawn takes D5 Knight E5 and even
if that gets traded by a knight from F7
got the bishop supporting that E5 Pawn
from B2 I I think Jun has a significant
Advantage here I'm with you so let's
leave her to it as her lead on the clock
remains and her positional Edge is also
there and in the bottom left I mean with
the black pieces holding his own against
Katarina lock no that H Pawn is going up
the board and then she goes first on the
flank then towards the center and shuyi
cannot be bothered he brings his Bishop
in contact with hers the one on H2
offering a trade here
Iman I'm just not seeing that much life
in this position white is doing just
fine but you need to win this game
that's right and you know you kind of uh
start the pregame strategy with
expectations like oh maybe a win on this
board with the white pieces you know
lacno is a stronger player than back row
on board four and maybe a win with mvl
you know he has the biggest rating
but then you get into the matches and
you might have to find your wins Robert
on completely different boards than you
intended because those two boards that
we just talked about it'll look that
good for wins anymore
no I mean sure you very strong GM in his
own right has played a good day of Chess
announcing let's liquid date trade
everything off I feel like you need to
trade on your own terms you don't mind a
capture on H2 because it brings your
knight from F1 out and maybe up to G4
but where are you going to create
threats the problem is you want to take
on D5 okay great we just get a simple
swap on the D5 Square where is the
action going to take place well she does
initiate the trade I just don't know the
Second Step here
that's right takes you know pun takes
back the knight in F1 he's actually
maybe waiting for Bishop takes H2 to be
played so he could take on H2 maybe
bring the Knight to G4 Pawn to H6 the
pawn on D5 is you know maybe a little
bit of a Target Knight E3 Queen B3 but
Pawn on D4 is also easy for black to
gang up on so I I'm with you I don't see
any real winning chances uh but you know
it's a long game ahead and there's still
still some targets to attack with Queen
B3 decent attempt to start yeah just
make sure that everyone knows D5 is not
hanging this is a common tactical trick
let's say black plays a quiet move like
Pawn to B6 if you take this Pawn on D5
you'll simply lose your queen there is a
stare down there's only one piece in the
way let's get rid of that piece with
check to the enemy King and pick up the
queen so that's not going to happen of
course B6 actually as we saw after Queen
B3 would not be the best move and I
think it's because D5 remains a weakness
there's some light Square issues over
here on the queen side so this would be
a good transition for white
indeed yeah this looks uh looks pretty
straightforward
um I don't think has been under too much
pressure uh thus far it doesn't look
like it yet but remember there are many
games developing at the exact same time
Robert so what looks like nothing here
either one of these players might need a
specific result based on what happens in
the rest of the match wow and a lot
happening in the top left Alexander
grishok with a rook lift but it's more
of a defensive Rook lift and the bottom
right we haven't looked at that game
because not a single piece has been
traded we will of course dive into that
one when the action heats up but the top
right that game between Jew and June and
Maxine versus LeBron that match uh that
game could either end the match for the
Shanghai tigers in their favor if she
can score Victory or get the blitz right
back in it because I'm on the idea is
we're talking about the Knight going to
F7 they're having to trade of Pawns on
the D file but the C Pawn is gone but
it's kind of on D5 so how did it get
there it looks like C6 was Maxim's
Choice and then we saw a swap and the
queen landed on C7
yeah I mean first thing I'm double
checking is of course Queen takes B7 uh
you know may as well calculate the the
hanging Pawns in the position but it
does look like the queen gets trapped we
should show that so bring an announce
where Queen takes B7 I'm on Highway
trapping that Queen
I mean it it looks nice to start with
Knight D6 to like take away the c or B8
to G3 or H2 rather diagonal and then to
bring the rook in next so that's
probably what I would do yeah
and the queen gets the B6 but I guess
can we how do we trap this thing because
isn't this Pawn
like yeah what the heck I'm almost
looking at night
E8 after uh Queens on B6 so like
previous move like 98 and Rook B8 that's
hilarious that way the queen has no
Escape squares I actually think that
it's you know not even trapping the
queen it's just the queen is so
misplaced that you get to a position
like this it's not about the material
where white is up a pawn but if you swap
Bishops then you're gonna lose your
second one on B2 so clever clever find
by unite to D6 and just going out for
the queen and instead in June June she
knows better she also trusts her
opponent she was rookie F to see one her
vintage it's uh not as big as it once
was but I also like what she's doing
because she's minimizing her own risk
definitely
um but this just looks really convincing
um I know that eval might have gone down
a little bit I'm looking at Knight E5 as
a follow-up for white as well even just
treating those pieces intakes for
example like I mean 95 is that'd be
automatic here 95 looks great the bishop
is under attack and uh is Bishop takes
B5 available though I think that's why
the Knight came to D6 so 95 oh that's a
good point
yeah um and and that's why a four was
played and the queen does it just sit on
B6 like it's trapped but it's also
unable to be attacked
wow good recognition from Jew and June
Bishop A3 next is a nasty permanent pin
and then Bishop takes E4 to follow
yeah Knight C4 is nearly forced because
I think white was about to play Bishop
A3 and pretty much win the game so can't
allow that pin Knight C4 are there any
other moves to consider here
yeah I don't think Queen B7 would have
worked out so she takes and now 95 looks
very good C3 is always met but Bishop A3
this Pawn is hanging as well yeah black
has a pass Pawn but it can only go so
far and the rest of Black's position is
just hanging
Yep this is a very big Advantage for Jew
engine and mvl is kind of going for it
as you need to do in the final round of
course we're not going to rule this this
game completely winning for white just
yet but for player of Jew engine's
caliber a position like this Robert uh
you would say she wins this the majority
heavy majority of the time
yeah I'm just looking at the clock
Maxim's up a couple minutes the two
second increment will always help but
she has a dominant position she knows
she's in charge right now and she can
end this match pretty much for the
Shanghai Tigers because if we just zoom
out for a second as she has a huge
advantage on this game uh the opposite
colored Bishops not of that much
importance at the moment we see that in
the top left Wei slightly better with a
pair of Bishops against Alexander
grishook in the bottom left that game is
getting spicier with knights in the
center and upon an H6 in the bottom
right we haven't tuned in there but Lu
you ping he beat Kettering lock no
around a go and now he has sacrificed a
pawn if I'm counting correctly but he
has the advantage in the bottom right
wow some interesting games no matter
where you turn
yeah and this is always going to be the
case in the final round of pro chess
League matchup especially when there's a
score imbalance like we see here seven
to five in favor of the Tigers they only
need to scrounge together a point and a
half somehow on every board Robert
yeah let's look at the one between
Louisa ping and Alexander buckrow it has
not been the younger Buck Rose day his
father Etienne bakro former 2760 top 10
player in the world in a former second
for Maxine Russia lagrav and right now
buckroe's up a pawn so I'm on actually
just a quick question for you not
necessarily about this position in
particular but do you enjoy being down
upon with the activity or up the pawn
and saying prove that you can make it
work I think uh that question is always
the case that it really depends on the
clock situation because that's also part
of the compensation if if you've had
that extra Pawn but so difficult to
manage
um then you know I don't really enjoy
that it's it's really tough to face
someone's compensation and face the
pressure on the clock as well so uh what
I see right here is Knight E4 an
unbelievable square that piece and a
knight on A4 that just strictly he's not
part of the action so I think if that
happened I would much rather play the
Black side of things from Knight E4 here
yeah I think this position Robert you've
got me sold on playing with the black
pieces yeah I know I was kind of trying
to talk myself into believing in White's
position because you are up a pawn and
sometimes it's a bit murky you can't
find a way back to material equality
that can scare a player but not Lu you
ping I keep saying he loves solid games
but he is not afraid to get into
tactical territory and that's where
we're at now so with the last move 94
maybe E5 next maybe this Rook sliding
over this King on G2 lacking important
Defenders so I feel like with E5 if we
get these trades in Comes This Rook up
to E5 over to H5 and right maybe I'll go
over Checkmate yep love that Queen and
C8 so well placed I think it might be
time for that E5 move as you said but I
think Louis Bing has a great position
and you've said that about a number of
players on the Shanghai Tigers uh Robert
because it feels like are they not doing
well on every single board right now
uh let's see top left slight Edge Tigers
uh top right maybe crushing position
this is just what the doctor ordered for
this Shanghai let's go to that game
because the advantage is growing and
growing and now I think Zhu and June is
winning a piece that's our last queen
takes B7 that's a rook under attack
that's a knight on e4 that is threatened
as well and F takes E3 I think the
attack is Just an Illusion I believe she
could safely take this Rook on C8 Pawn
takes F2 the king slides that one oh
that's actually yeah even f3s it's just
clinical
oh she says you're not touching this and
she just attacks the Knight saves the
pawn and The Rook is still hanging no
Knight D6 because Bishop takes Knight
just winning yeah this looks like a
stone cold win if if wenjin doesn't win
this that's a huge disappointment for
for her and the team but it looks in all
likelihood like she will then you know
what that presents Robert the need for
basically Rio from the rest of the squad
for the Shanghai Tigers they kind of use
this balanced lineup on boards two
through four and then have Wei Yi as a
monster at the top and it's working to
Perfection for the team from Shanghai
this one's completely over I mean Maxim
knows that you see it on his face he is
simply going to lose a piece if he
protects his Rook the Knight is going to
be captured uh if you move the Knight
well The Rook is under attack so you
can't do anything there is no attack for
black this one is as good as done you
see if Maxim he's just gesticulating he
knows it's over yeah there's there's no
tricks to be had here
um I mentioned this before the match
Robert but it's kind of coming to
fruition those even balanced lineups
usually have a strong round four that's
what those lineups are made for because
when it comes down to it you know you're
they're gonna give good games to board
one and two and they're probably gonna
have rating advantages on boards three
and four so they're made for this they
were out to the early lead and it looks
like as you're highlighting I mean
hickey up that piece is pretty much it
you have a pass Pawn if you need it
you're up a piece your king can't even
be attacked where's this queen going how
is it going to get to F2 it's not that's
the answer so I feel like we can trust
June who played a nice strategic game
Saw the tactics when she needed to
brought her Queen up to C7 and back to
B6 a nice performance from the bore two
for Shanghai so let's leave these two to
it because with this presumed victory
that means that you need wins on all
three other boards for the Blitz and
it's just not happening I mean you look
at the top left Alexander grishook I
think I'm calculating right he's down a
pawn against Wei so he might even be in
trouble there
yep no this this looks like a tiger's
Victory imminent as we're seeing every
single uh every single board looks like
it's almost in their uh in their favor
here minus lagnose position which is
kind of turning around
but anyway let's go to that Grisha game
because he only has seconds on his clock
yeah in the driver's seat against
Alexander grishock and look at what he
just did in the top left brought his
Bishop back to C1 I'm gonna do an
instant replay in a moment there just
because it was so impressive in this
position it looks like your Rook can't
move so Bishop takes C3 is about to be a
threat The Rook is hanging but rookie
wants please go ahead and take my Pawn
here Bishop H6 would lead to this
Checkmate on the back rank there's
nothing you can do about it you're just
going to go down Rook f8 apparently is
the best move but I just take your rook
and win the game so instead we so the
bishop be able to slide back to C1 and
now Wei gifts left for his King his Rook
at any moment can slide to A4 he is up a
healthy past Pawn here and it actually
is a passer that can push at some point
and he's never losing this so you know
that that already is probably enough the
team based on how a Goodwin June's
position is so should be should be
enough for eight and a half points there
but I don't think he is thinking drop
he's thinking win here
why not I mean if the team is going to
they actually don't know what their
teammates are doing uh but you can't
just if he can force a draw he doesn't
know that his teammates are winning so
why not just play you're up a clear pawn
and grishook down to five seconds on his
clock give me the open file for my Rooks
trying desperately to push this Pawn
forward and then get the C3 Pawn uh I
think it's good to stop that move
because the Rook on the fourth rank is a
monster protecting this Pawn H4 as well
yeah
that's right
yeah grishokin big trouble oh my gosh
this looks like a game we can leave in
favor of uh something more beautiful uh
Robert uh the top right is that more
beautiful look at Jewel and June's
finals
no that looks pretty sick a Jew in June
we're gonna bring up the board just for
a second here uh Maxime had to give up
his Bishop on E8 he's already down a
piece goes Queen Detroit this actually
looks quite threatening with the queen
infiltrating but after Queen takes
Bishop Queen h8 check sacrificing the
queen to win the opponent Queen with
this Knight Fork uh that seems worthy of
just you know kind of a brilliancy just
the game from start to finish we love
these types of games a great performance
from Jew and June and well that's a
night Fork yeah that's amazing that is a
uh really good finish to a really good
game and uh that win along with you know
way
grinding down that position against
grishook there uh should be you'd think
uh enough for the team there Robert and
I'm looking at the other boards and I'm
saying wait a minute those Shanghai
Tigers they actually needed those
results because the other boards don't
look too promising no not at all while
we can look at uh Wei trying to win this
game Let's actually oh my gosh Kettering
Lucknow made a mistake let's zoom out
because I saw the evaluation bar was Sky
High for her and I just assumed it was
over but in the last couple moves her
Advantage has gone away and she's going
for the attack it's not easy for black
to do it but look at this position after
King G8 white on the attack and is not
down in immaterial but she goes Rook
takes H7 that actually was not the
correct move instead she could have
played 97 and then Rook H7 it's mate
it's forced very sweet tactic there King
G7 Rook H7 missed by like no which you
know it might not matter in the end
based on the other results but that is a
big Miss in terms of this game
yes she's actually still on the attack
against this King she can go Queen G7
pick up this Knight over here but the
King has escaped four now and Black's
still in trouble uh with 30 seconds on
the clock I mean this still feels like
white is totally winning but oh we're
both looking forward look look at that
move if rookie won you give a counter
check to the white King on G1 and you
win the game that is sick recognition
from shui I feel like he's done a great
job defending all day and if Knight
takes Queen takes we'll immediately see
a draw by repetition Rook F2 Queen D1
back and forth that's right
okay I mean you can maybe play on but
I'm not sure you you want to at this
point
and look in the look at the top left
Rook A5 by way Yi trading off the Rooks
no trade for you but down goes A4 two
extra pawns for the Chinese Superstar we
see a draw in the bottom left that
secures match victory for the Shanghai
tigers and they're gonna have room to
spare because Wei Yi is dominating
grishook up a couple pods he is yeah and
this this should be uh pretty easy win
for him there in the top left of your
screen we're now in the game and I mean
yeah he's just he's just taking care of
business at this point
two extra pawns you just need to be able
to move them so bring your king over
then push the C Pawn all the way up to
the other side
yeah you can give up the g-pawn here if
need be
way you just needs to bring his King
over I'm wondering what he's thinking
about brings his Bishop up to C5 I mean
the match Victory is already secured for
the Tigers but it feels like he's just
kind of moving back and forth English
time travel
yeah that's right I I'm not sure if he's
trying to
okay he's bringing the king over now and
he's actually come up with a very
interesting way to do it he trapped The
Rook
oh my gosh
Rook I was not expecting that I thought
I was gonna push the beep on and bring
the king to D3 instead he simply traps
The Rook on C2 and grashook is just like
what can I do to get a victory in this
match the answer is nothing all four
games are done for Sasha and Uncle Sasha
well he goes only one half out of four
while Wei jumps to three out of four
and then just look at the performance
from the top two boards you engine both
winning with the white pieces and it
looks like uh chuyi and Louis ping are
both going to get their jobs done with
the black pieces and draw at minimum uh
for Liu ping it looks like that's the
the last game
and we see a position up in exchange and
completely winning it turns out for
black because the A3 Pawn if these pawns
didn't exist if you could take the a
pawns off the board white should
probably hold this game but because the
eight pawns are there and now the Rooks
trade is offered once you swap you're
gonna lose this a pawn and black is
gonna promote
yep
unfortunately you want to keep the Rook
on the board but you're going to be
dropping the a pawn rookie one trades
The Rook I think that's probably the
cleanest
yeah Louis oh my gosh he just stops this
Pawn from pushing he's gonna bring a
second Rook uh to the second Rank and
then just go after this King
easy win yeah foreign
one of those players you don't really
hear about him ever but he comes into
the pro chess league and two weeks in a
row he's a force for the Tigers yep
yep absolutely not to be underestimated
very very good player to have on your
board four
yeah 24.90 feet a classical rating uh I
am but GM strength and just mowing down
the pawns now is Lou yaping and if the
Rook trade is going to happen we talked
about this take this Pawn take the Rook
bring the Rook back over mop up
everything easy win you can even grab H3
on your way
and now over to A3 and just pick
everything up
and buckrow pre-moved a bit but I think
he's about to resign he has resigned and
Lou yipping I mean he had a plus day on
board four for the Shanghai tiger so we
knew that the blitz needed a 3-1 score
in the final round just to tie in a
month it was three and a half in favor
of the Shanghai Tigers he yeah it was
the target score but for the wrong team
so unfortunately you know I will say
probably the blitz took some more risks
compared to what they might normally do
they needed uh more results but I gotta
give credit to the Shanghai Tigers I
don't think a lot of these results were
born out of desperation you know turned
into uh oh you know I've risked the loss
in order to get a win I think a lot of
these were just Stone Cold outplays doom
and Jones game was clinical way Yi's
game was clinical I mean we saw a lot of
results here everybody on the Shanghai
Tigers Robert pulled their weight
they certainly did they bared their
teeth they clawed at the Blitz and they
win this rapid match and you see from
top to bottom the Shanghai Tigers they
all played an important role a balanced
top three points each against a
two-headed super GM lineup that's insane
from Jew and June in particular and luya
ping two and a half out of four when
you're Port four as a positive score
that's just terrible news for the
opposition
yeah I think when your board four has as
many points as the highest scorer on
your team like the opponents board four
compared to your team that's that's
enough of a statistic right there you're
not winning the match period
no you're not they have officially lost
the match and that means that the
Shanghai Tigers join two other teams
with a perfect match record reminder to
everybody three wins and you're into the
playoffs we see Shanghai 2-0 just like
the Indian yogis and the levitov chess
wizard so Ahmad based on what you just
saw here do you feel like Shanghai can
compete with the levitov chess Wizards
as maybe the top team in the league
absolutely and I I think uh we're
starting to see that a really really
strong lineup involves just one of the
top women players in the world right
Juan Jin we saw Alexander kostenic on
the levitov chess Wizards those lineups
are so valuable you're getting you're
getting players that are 200 plus points
more valuable than what they're counting
as for your roster uh average rating
calculation
and the Indian yogis also at a perfect
2-0 record they have some superstars on
their roster they were led by vidit
Gujarati who took down unfortunately for
you Iman came to chess Bros board one
Magnus Carlsen to flip the script there
and win that matchup on the other side
of things we do have teams that have
suffered some bad Fates we have some 0-2
teams and we have some teams without
match victories so coming up next we
will have team mgd1 and the St Louis
archbishops both of those teams
surprising losers in week one but I'm on
that Clash coming ahead of us in week
two I mean we have some big names in
those lineups we do and you know it's
always a reminder to people if you've
seen the teams in previous weeks believe
me you have not even seen the extent of
the roster possibilities there are so
many people that compete for these
different teams in the Pro chess league
and you can only field four of them each
week so we might see some new looks for
these teams uh going into today's match
we will and some teams definitely need
new looks the Charlotte cobras the
Spanish Maniac shrimps with two losses
to their team name but they will have a
chance in the next week but coming up
next we have a heavyweight battle the St
Louis archbishops led by super Grand
Master Fabiano caruana take on team mgd1
you may be familiar with the name origin
aragaisi he leads that Squad so in just
a few minutes after this short break we
will come back and cover the matchup
between the archbishops and mgd1 that's
all for now from the matchup between the
Shanghai tigers and the blitz I would
say the French Blitz but they only have
one name it's a mononym they're Blitz
and unfortunately for Kevin board in his
Squad they suffered at the hands of the
Tigers but that's in the past next up St
Louis archbishops mgd1 we'll be right
back to cover that action
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Hamilton we just saw the Shanghai Tigers
clash with the blitz now we have another
matchup in store for you will be the St
Louis archbishops taking on team
mgd1 Amman hey man did you even get any
rest whatsoever
hey Robert uh yeah long time no see it's
uh it's good to be back what can I say
I'm now I now consider myself a veteran
of PCL commentary so this show should be
a breeze it certainly certainly will be
a lot of fun no breezes for any team in
this league we look at the standings
that have happened thus far because
several teams have a perfect score of
most of the wrestling do not Shanghai
Tigers they joined the Indian yogis and
the Levittown chess was the perfect to
us for the blitz dropped to one and one
but toward the bottom of the standings
which is where we are going to focus our
attention for now St Louis archbishops
team mgd1 we started discussing it on
the last show but a month I mean these
are surprising teams to see with losses
to their name absolutely and you know
what's even more surprising is that one
of these two teams is gonna have two
losses to their name Amy believe I'm
saying that
um we're gonna see a lot of the depth of
these rosters today in action some
change UPS on both sides so very excited
to see what these new look lineups have
to offer for both teams because look
they saw that what happened with the
last week's uh lineup they need to get a
win here you don't want to find yourself
Robert too close to the bottom of the
standings table
yeah and speaking of new looks we saw
five in a carwana sport a new a haircut
at Tata steel and he returns in the Pro
chess League he makes a seasoned debut
for the St Louis archbishops they have
such a strong lineup from top to bottom
a mon fan favorite was Alice Lee last
week she's a teenager she is a nearly
2300 and she's only on the rise that's
right and I feel like you know in in the
U.S there's so many of those talented
Juniors you know boys and girls and the
St Louis archbishops lineup has got a uh
a lot of them uh on this list here of uh
you can see the roster in front of you
so look it's not just Alice Lee you've
got Rochelle Wu as well
um you know a lot of talented Juniors
and those uh those are the future for a
reason Robert
yes for sure and well of course they
will rely on Fabiano caruana as he makes
his debut for this season but somebody
making his debut for an entire team or
team mgd1 is Amin tabatabai the Iranian
Superstar is nearly 2700 himself he is
gaining rating and look at that photo he
scares me I do not want to play him I
know and he's you know on a team team
MGD one pretty much a full Indian lineup
he's the the only player who's not from
Indian that they even have on their
roster but I mean I think with uh with
his skill level he's gonna fit in just
fine uh Robert I think that this team is
just insane to imagine that it's not
going to be a close match because look
at those even ratings across the board I
mean every match is is going to be tough
there's just no gimmies
yeah in the meantime to buy he's not
from India but we have seen Brazil
bringing artemiev a lot of teams
bringing in these free agents and let's
look at the actual matchups for today uh
because we're talking about fabina
carwana we're talking about a meantime
of Dubai as we look at the respective
boards for each team come on I mean
these are super strong lineups but the
biggest differential board for Rochelle
Wu she's very strong but a digimatello
outrage her by nearly 200 points
yeah no this this lineup that uh we see
here obviously you're looking at the the
mismatches right uh Rochelle Wu is
definitely gonna have her work cut out
for because you see that that's the St
Louis lineup is going for that typical
thing that we've seen uh from some other
teams where you're kind of stacking the
lineups on the top obviously Fabio on
board one is super strong they've also
got the three GM lineup we see that's
kind of matched on both sides team mgg
one a little bit more balanced I would
say and certainly expects to have the
upper hand in the board four matchup
that's right because the St Louis
archbishops they have a 2300 on board
for compared to nearly 2500 for team
mgd1 but how does this work if you are
new here what were you doing earlier
today because we just had a great match
between Shanghai and the blitz uh but
just remind everybody it is an all play
all format so if you're bored four for
one team you still play all the way
through to board one for the other the
time Patrol 10 minutes plus two second
increment rapid chess we have up to four
rounds why up to the first team to eight
and a half points wins the match that
can happen in three rounds that has
happened earlier this week with the
Brazil Cappy bar has taken down the
Charlotte cobras in just three and if
it's tied eight eight we will replay it
round four action that is far away away
we'll start with these round one
pairings where top board is the bottom
board for the other team you'll get to
Fabiano caruana in a second but Amman as
you look at these matchups with garudia
nicobian Michelle Wu gained the white
pieces against Amin tabatabai and Arjun
Eragon I see what do you make of those
matchups yeah I mean I I think it goes
back to what I was mentioning in our
first matchup here where you have very
different team uh Dynamics right
Rochelle Wu clearly the lower rated
player and she's gonna have her work cut
out for especially in round one you know
you send your your board four in there
she is making this lineup happen Robert
right if if you want to have all those
strong players on your team you need
someone at her rating in order to make
the averages work but that means that
your Port board 4 is kind of getting
sent to the shopping block early so any
result that she's able to score in these
first couple rounds would be absolutely
massive for the team morale
and there is no more difficult opponent
in the world than the likes of a Fabiano
caruana or a our generic icy but we are
going to start with Fabiano caruana's
match up here in the first round he gets
Aditya metal that is not going to be an
easy pairing because a digimatal birth
year I believe 2006. so a youngster
someone who's on the rise and doesn't
have the G next to his m in his title
but that will be there very soon yeah
you you have to feel that you know for
most of these talented uh youngsters
especially from India that it's just a
matter of time before they get that
title confirmed but I don't think the
title whether it's an i or a G Robert is
gonna play any role in this game right
here he is uh super strong in his own
right and hey he's he's going right for
it Fabby deciding to imbalance things uh
and going for a king's Indian we know
the engine doesn't love the king's
Indian Robert but still offers some
fantastic practical chances
yeah no this king's Indian can be very
sharp and it's not really like Fabiano
to play this opening it's clear to me
Amman he is playing for a win as early
as move one he knows the top Board needs
to score in order for the team to have a
good shot so right now white is thinking
you can take on E5 trade Queen some
people do that when they feel like a
draw is a good enough result uh but it's
not that simple and instead he says
let's just play normal chess I'll push
my Pawn forward and D5 keep it closed
that's right but we do see the bishop
out on G4 early so I mean I'm wondering
could you already go for something like
Knight E1 like he's trading those those
Bishops valuable because I think that
for black you you almost don't want to
and well so much so he doesn't even
trade Bishop for Knight but I was gonna
save 91 might bring your Bishop back
anyway what the heck do we see here
immediately H3 and C5 Robert he's kind
of like pretending to sack a pawn here
yeah you take on C5 the Knight will take
on E5 so instead we see a swap of Pawns
on the D6 square and that gives black
maybe some of these dark squares on the
queen side but white has control over
the B5 Square it does feel like there is
going to be a strategic battle on that
flank now the king's Indian we know it
very well black attacks on the king side
white attacks air quotes on the queen
side but there is no attack for black
and whoa I mean I say that and he plays
B5 I think I think he heard you and he
was seriously offended uh Robert he said
no attack you got to be kidding me B5
immediately played I mean the B2 Pawn
getting hit by the X-ray on the B file
but it's more about that pawn in the
center Robert E4 is just going to be
hanging if the Knight vacates to C3
square there's no way to win B5 without
doing that I mean what about I'm looking
at B4 here but starting to realize the
Knight on A6 lined up with The Rook on
A1 Bishop on E2 could be some issues
there
that's right B4 Pawn push has to be
timed correctly the Knight on A6 is a
bit loose so if you ever played B4 and
you try to swap pawns the Knight hangs
there it still might be possible Amman
because the E4 Pawn will drop at the end
of the line uh but I said Bobby first
brings his Queen to B8 he's Ultra well
prepared and now it's a ditching metal
on the clock faced with a B4 maybe a
rook C8 and a rook sacrifice for this
Knight over here giving up the exchange
for the center and Aditya plays Queen D3
so far they're jockeying for a position
but all four games are underway so why
don't we hop away from this one for now
and just look at their teammates action
because it's not just about a single
board just because Fabian was played for
a world championship does not mean it's
all about him and man which of these
boards is catching your eye right now
well I'm I'm looking at the way the
games are developing here and I'm
definitely drawn a little bit to that
top right there we've got Nicholas
theodoro and uh Grandmaster harika drona
Valley as well so I'm looking at at that
game especially because the last movie
Bishop E6 looks kind of interesting so
should we hop there
okay why don't we go on over to the game
between harika and Nicholas theodoro
Theodore from Greece Eureka you know
she's a main State for the Indian team
and she actually recently had a baby at
the Olympiad in Chennai she was pregnant
at the time and still playing for the
Indian woman Squad and now with the
white pieces we see some tension in the
center right now of course you can't
take this Pawn without losing your queen
so what do you think of mom what does
white do here as black has not developed
at all yeah and it's such a weird like
the last movie was Bishop E6 Bishop
takes E6 Queen takes E6 and it's it's
always so unusual to put a bishop on
that square or any piece really when
you've got the bishop on f8 that still
needs developing so a little unorthodox
but obviously the next couple of moves
should be E6 Bishop V7 and Castle or
Nicholas and it's really about what can
White drum up in the meantime because
that's two three moves before Black's
really comfortable and we do anything in
in the meantime before uh before that
happens otherwise I think black is
totally fine
and well the good news for white is in
the event of a pond capture you don't
necessarily have to take with your pawn
and have an isolated Queen Pawn after
Pawn takes you would take with your
knight start training some of the pieces
and if you could land a bishop on D4
when all is said and done that's a very
active piece looks good for white so I
do think harika can continue her
development with Knight B to D2 We are
at early stages of this game uh but
black will eventually Castle King's side
that's right yeah now maybe you could
make the case that takes on C5 is
possible so you know Bishop B7 you could
grab that pawn black could also take on
D4 and then
and then go Bishop E7 as well both are
okay
yeah for sure so this one early stages
will of course come back to all of our
games as we see the action unfold let's
go back to our bird's eye view because I
think Arjun aragaisy fabrina carwana
they have the same exact ideas in mind
look at the bottom right Arjun aragaisy
playing a king's Indian defense against
Rochelle Wu super Grand Masters taking
on their very strong but not Grand
Master opponents they want a fight from
as early as the opening yeah it makes
total sense
um we have uh Rochelle the board four up
against Arjun and yeah going for uh a
really similar position to what we saw
in the top left there from from Fabi but
uh Bishop E2 I mean usually when F5
happens you go for this uh this capture
and maybe try to take over the E4 Square
because Bishop B2 lined up against that
Knight on H5 if you go and you take back
G takes F5
to be a little careful about the Knight
yes and if you do nothing black is about
ready to strike with F4 in some
positions but this white Bishop can't
take this Knight on C5 so I'm already
thinking do I want to part with the
bishop here I don't really want to if
I'm being honest but it does hurt
Black's Pawn structure and as you're
indicating the E4 Square Ultra well
defended by White's pieces and you want
to clog that square because the king's
Indian this bishop is behind its own
Pawn you do not want to see this Pawn go
off the board because as soon as that
pawn is gone the bishop becomes super
strong
you've been commentating with Daniel too
much the whoops are coming out
hey you know whoops there it is and yeah
you would love to get this bishop active
and well speaking of Dania he would love
to have this position from the black
side
yeah yeah no love this uh love this move
F5 from Arjun if I recall the last match
I mean RJ was just playing like an
absolute Beast so really excited to see
him back in Action here in this match
and yeah even though the Evolve bar is
not saying anything too special thus far
I feel like this is the normal
evaluation for King's Indian Roberts so
let's just call it equal
yeah it's equal but the clock is not
right now Arjun well ahead on time and
so that leads me to believe that
Rochelle not feeling super comfortable
it's not fun when you're the low rated
player to face such a strong like our
generic geisu who has beaten the likes
of Magnus Carlsen and we see Rochelle
Castle Queen side getting her King to
the other side of the board it's what we
typically see you go after this King on
G8 but big questions for black right now
F4 would be a huge strategic blunder
right not play that move I'm gonna show
it very quickly Bishop takes Knight Pawn
takes here you see that now the position
is locked up and the eval bar goes Sky
High because white plays G4 and kicks
the Knight back and not only is E5
hanging but you probably don't want to
take you just want to make sure that the
position is closed and then you can
operate on the king side yeah that's
right I think there's a stigma probably
for good reason that you don't want to
give away your dark Square Bishop as
white and the King's Indian but there
are some instances where Bishop takes C5
is actually a really good move that's a
good example right now however I think
the threat is kind of being renewed if
we saw like you know the exact same line
that you just proposed you wouldn't need
to be D take C5 now B takes C5 is
possible maybe that that position is a
little better for black to play than
previous makes all the difference
opening up the B file The Rook can join
the attack so F4 is not going to be
played Without serious calculation
because I think it would have been a
huge strategic mistake a possibly losing
Choice already for black you know not to
push that pawn you need to keep the
tension same deal for white I wouldn't
go about and take this Pawn at least not
yet the bishop can hop out with Tempo
against this queen the Knight is
perfectly placed so it's going to be a
battle on opposite sides of the board
I'm on I think that team mgd1 has to be
kind of happy oh as soon as I say that
the Knight came out to H4
hey you said they should be kind of
happy maybe happier after Knight to H4
immediately you know I'm definitely
thinking about F4 just because it looks
the most forcing hitting the bishop and
if you take on F4 of course your knight
on H4 is losing its support so that's
the first move I'm thinking of after uh
the night move there Robert
yeah I'm looking like at that as well I
think it looks very promising because
Bishop takes you may even throw in Pawn
takes G3 because the Knight loses its
Defender but whoa Knight F4 played in a
perfect time to bring in the team
captain for the St Louis archbishops hey
Nemo how you doing
hello Robert I'm doing well how are you
guys
uh we're doing pretty well but but you
know we're not the team captain we're
not nervous about the results come on
how are you really feeling watching your
team play
honestly I was feeling really good about
the archbishops coming into this you
know into this entire tournament into
this entire event we have some really
strong players like Fabiano Carana
nicolesiodoro but it turns out every
other team also has extremely strong
players on their teams I mean you know
the previous team we play fielded Jew
and Jung as their like female player who
is just 25.50 in a world-class
Grandmaster so there's lots of tough
competition out there
yeah I mean obviously you're totally
right that's why the PCL is so stacked
Nemo can you tell us about the lineup
this week it looks a little different
from the week one St Louis lineup we
remember
right so uh Fabi is coming off of travel
or you know he has he has time now to
play this match uh we've got theodoro
playing he's a very I would say he's
quite an underrated player so we do want
to field him quite frequently a Cobian
is stepping in
um as replacement for Alejandro and ooh
Rochelle is is now playing as our female
player for this week I mean we've got a
couple of strong female players we had
Alice Lee last week who's 13 and already
23 300 or something so we have a lot of
stacked female players as well
yeah the team lineup from top to bottom
is very very strong and while Nemo I
mean are you involved with that decision
making because you're talking about the
lineup it sounds like you're very
invested into your squad there so uh you
know what's that process like first of
uh you know bringing the players to the
team it shouldn't be too difficult St
Louis they have all the players but
choosing the lineup each and every week
our players saying like come on Coach
put me in
I do not choose the lineup I feel like
that would be way too much pressure uh
on me so that is all up to the team
manager Mike but I am happy to be
cheering on the team but doing content
with them and you know just giving them
support from over here
yeah I think that's the that's a good
way to do it Robert Nemo understands if
you can offload the responsibility it's
a lot easier that's why I've gone into
commentary you know I'm not responsible
for these calculations we put on the
board
well we all must calculate that's you
know our role in Nemo being a huge
streamer if you don't already follow
Nemo's Channel I don't know what's wrong
with you but go follow right now we'll
put her stream in the chat but let's go
to our four board view just because
every single game this is what I love
about the protesting I keep saying it
over and over again I'm a broken record
every game is of equal importance so
Nemo as you look uh from the top left
all the way down through the bottom
right and what's catching your eye as a
team captain but also just as a chess
player
kind of
um
glad the games are all equal this so far
nothing crazy has happened but I would
say
um that Nicholas's game against harika
is the one I currently have pulled up
and that one was just kind of
interesting because I thought something
might exciting might happen but it looks
like it's going to a fairly equal end
game now
like nothing ever happened you think
there's an advantage and you know Queen
E2 gets played and wow this is this is
really liquidated since we lost this is
yeah
um but I did hear you guys were talking
about Rochelle's game against aragassi
and I did want to point out she's
playing against somebody who is
you know 500 points higher rated I think
that game is also super interesting it's
still currently sort of equal but it's a
nice kind of
um I would call it like dynamic
well I think we normally those kings
Indians right it's you're always gonna
get these wild wild positions no matter
what
yeah
are spinning a little bit out of control
for her but as you said this is what
tends to happen in the protesting in the
bottom right we see that Origins pieces
are infiltrating there's a pin towards
that rook in the corner so it does look
like our generic IC is taking charge but
he's beating Magnus Carlsen before he
just beat him in the air things master
so uh you know it's hard to ask Rochelle
in the first game to take down Arjun but
on the flip side of things your board
one five minute carwana you know we
don't want to put pressure on him to win
every single game he plays but if we
tune in there for a second yeah it looks
like like it's going to be a
straightforward draw at this point with
uh the Queen's trade being offered
yeah I'm not sure if he can uh make
something of this uh you know Nemo do
you think Fabi is gonna like really work
for a result here or he's not gonna go
all out and he's kind of okay making a
draw even though it's a board one versus
Board format
I think since this is his first game in
the Pro chest League he didn't play last
week uh I would say a draw is probably
okay but as we can tell maybe Fabi is
playing for that win with Bishop to B3
he does not want to swap off the Queens
he might decide that he has a little
more to play for
so you know there's a lot of possibility
over here
um but at the end of the day it is and
completely symmetrical Pawn structure
you both have pair of Bishops it's
probably going to be very difficult to
squeeze an edge out of this end game
yeah yeah probably agree Robert that's
the thing I mean this board four for
mgd1 it's an international Master it's
no no pushover pairings in the PCL
no not at all I mean this is a very even
game it's against a strong player so we
can't rely on Fabiano to win every
single game he plays but your team at
some point might need him to strike so
Nemo I know you're streaming on your
channel so we want to let you get back
to your audience we say hi to them uh
you know of course we show our support
always but I will talk to you later I'm
sure and good luck to the squad
yeah thank you so much Robert and I'm on
take care guys have fun
bye for now
wow okay well five and a carwana this is
just looking even so let's zoom out of
here let's go to our four board scene
because unfortunately
for the archbishops Rochelle Wu they're
bored for she's in grave danger you see
the bishop on F3 in the bottom right
hitting both Rooks Black's not even down
any material has an attack against the
white king uh so unfortunately for
Rochelle it's uh already in the bag in
fact the game is over she's resigned our
generic geiste has won so I'm on the
other three games all looking pretty
level which is great news for team mgd1
yeah I again I think um in this round
right here Fabi not getting the win
that's definitely a a great result for
MGD one an easy win on board one for
them and yeah I think because they have
that more compact lineup I think an even
start uh is fantastic for them
yeah so it looks like with these games
let's go to the game in the top right
Nicholas theodoro playing this end game
against harika dronavali not all end
games are drawn don't listen to what
they say all the time this position
white has the outermost passer uh but
black has the more active King here and
well I guess this game is a draw as soon
as we come in nothing really to do you
know Black's not in time to push the
pawns or anything so drug read yeah and
you know I think it's it's also about
the night end games night end games are
so tricky it's like hard to come up with
concrete rules to follow we have
opposite Bishops same color Bishops Rook
end games we all know a few themes and
and tricks there but night end games are
just all over the place because the
knights can find their way to any Square
on the board and we see here there's
just no way for that c Pawn to get going
and actually be a pass Pawn you throw
that pawn over to A3 Robert and all of a
sudden with an outside a pawns much more
winning chances for white
agree completely but not in this game
this was a stable draw for the two
players so let's go back to the only
game we have still going and it's not
going to be going for that much longer I
don't think it's White's turn between
varujan okobian and Amin Tabitha by VAR
is a staple of American chess face
played in so many U.S championships he's
a played on the U.S national team he's
coached the team he's been around all
these great players but look at this
this is just completely even two Rooks
and three pawns per side this is what
happens it went to about evenly rated
Grandmasters face off
yeah I mean Rook F1 and you can
basically fall asleep as white and make
a draw
um F3 looks slightly unnecessary to me
but
um it's hard to really criticize what's
going on here this is a draw no matter
which way you cut it yeah and I get why
you're saying this because it just
creates some openings for black if this
Rook could get to D2 or this King could
somehow slide all the way up to G3 but
unfortunately this Rook comes back to C2
before you know it and we can just shake
hands in this one that's a funny way to
Trader Rooks
ha
yeah
throwing one in for the fans there
and the fans do appreciate it and well
Amin Tabitha Bai he might not know
what's happening in the other boards uh
and well if he did he would be perfectly
happy with making a draw against Vara
copen the team is up by a point
yep Yep this looks uh this looks like
it's gonna be a dead draw and we've been
saying that a lot over uh all of these
games honestly this one looks completely
dead the game of Fabiano caruana looks
like at least there's still some life in
the position I mean this is three on
three with Rooks so I'm not
I'm not seeing anything I think that
Fabius is also a draw but
um he's got the he's got the Bishops as
well to work with yeah this game
officially addressed let's get out of
here there was no surprises there I
actually didn't realize five on his game
was still going that has Scene It seems
so equal forever now that I didn't
actually know that the game was
continuing so what can Fabi do if his
Bishop gets around to F1
and maybe there's an opportunity the
king slides back and this is the problem
for black is great your king is so
active the white king is not but now
what do you do right you can't make any
more progress white will just go back
and forth for the bishop you can't inch
any further yeah it's almost just
tantalizing that you've got all those
pawns on dark squares you've got the
light Square Bishop like it's so good
but
you just can't make any progress
and I guess the only chance for Fabi is
if there's a mistake in the king and
pawning game but even taking and just
bringing your king to E2 you have
diagonal opposition and that would allow
you to make a draw but I could see an
argument for just keeping the Bishops if
you don't feel like calculating this was
the only move that Drew by the way all
of the moves would have lost so just to
show quickly the king to E3 looks good
but King C3 uh you can force the king
back and then the king will slink around
this way I'm honestly surprised I'm not
gonna lie I'm surprised that he traded
Bishops like it just seems like more
work calculation wise
um because you keep the bishop on you
can just close your eyes and Shuffle
okay he's up to task and uh well
demonstrated there uh Aditya Mattel
really good hold and MGD one Robert
gotta be super satisfied with how that
first round went you see Fabiano caruana
there okay he's he's just getting into
the PCL Robert he's just warming up but
it's also one of those situations for
Fabi he's thinking I couldn't do
anything I had the black pieces my
opponent played a super solid game so
what more can you ask of somebody you
can't force to draw to thin air so for
the St Louis archbishops that draw five
five on a carwana not really the desired
result because as we see a ditching
Mattel five minutes yeah that was a
pretty dull draw it looked like Rico
Jordan Valley Nicholas Theodore also
looked like a pretty stable game version
of Kobe with white against the meantime
to buy Amman we saw that Rook end game
completely level and then the only
decisive game was our generic I see with
black that was the biggest rating
differential yeah you know I feel bad we
we said hello to Nemo checked in she
showed up watched the only loss of the
Round And Then There Were draws all
around so it feels bad we didn't get
more action while Nemo was with us here
but you're right it was just a super
even match up you know all across this
round and of course where the reading
disparity was the biggest uh our generic
icy pulled away with a victory and gives
his team mgd1 lead
MGD one with a one-point Edge so far
after the first round of games but the
St Louis archbishops may need to take
some more risk if they hope to strike
back and get even on the scoreboard
we'll find out if they're capable of
doing that we'll be right back this is
protest League match up between team MGD
one and the St Louis
foreign
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck okay kind of
square to place the dog
[Music]
oh he put them back to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
you can permanently stop the London
capture the pawns Keen to win oh wow oh
there's no stalemates but still wait
there is still me but the still made the
player wins ooh if only that was real
chess I think I'm getting the hang of
this game I think I think I actually am
getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chess That's so exciting
[Music]
no no no mouse slip no no no no no no I
won
duck chess champion give me those points
baby
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis archbishops Trail by a
point against team mgd1 but the
archbishops they have a history of
success in this league among they are
three-time protest League champions but
we know they have the pedigree to do
what it takes and now mount a comeback
in this match
yeah you said it best Robert the St
Louis archbishops have been around since
the you know Inception of the protest
League
um and I say that with certainty because
I've been around since the beginning as
well and the chess bras have taken their
fair share of losses to the archbishops
in Championship uh playoff and you know
you name it matches over the the many
years so such a Powerhouse team and
absolutely a two and a half one and a
half first round Robert is not going to
scare anyone no Powerhouse team for sure
and familiar name fabina caruana has
been on the St Louis archbishops in two
of their League titles and he is playing
in this week's matchup he will be facing
off against a new opponent in the second
round here so as we look at the lineups
today in our second round of action uh
we first note that the only win was for
Arch and aragaisy and that means heading
into the second round the Saint Louis
archbishops have ground to make up so
with half point in the top three boards
and a loss for Rochelle Wu you'll have
to have a better round this time and I'm
in a carwana Nicholas Theodore get white
I'm on with white on the top two black
on the bottom two for the archbishops do
you think this is their rounder strike
or should they wait for later
well I don't think you uh want to wait
for anyone in this PCL format remember
eight and a half points is the target
score uh you can get there in three
rounds so no you absolutely want to
strike quickly I think that uh this
round is actually important now you have
Fabi with the white pieces right he's
got you know uh tough games ahead as we
mentioned for board ones the games get
tougher and tougher so hey he's got the
black pieces his opponent played well in
the first round but I think Fabi and
Nicholas Theodore with the white pieces
and playing the boards three and four uh
you have to step up and and bring some
wins home for the archbishops because
Rochelle Wu still gonna have her work
cut out for her there uh as the board
four for St Louis so uh in these lineups
where you put a board four who's
significantly lower rated than the rest
of the squad you do need to perform on
the top boards
being the top board for the St Louis
archbishops he gets the white pieces in
the second round he is going to face off
against harika dronavali that's a big
rating gap between the two but harika is
such an experienced Grandmaster she is
not going to be afraid of playing
against uh Fabi and he gets the white
pieces he's going to need to come up
with some kind of opening that causes
her problems
that's right
Abby with the white pieces is gone for
just Knight F3 very modest you know not
looking to shake things up with uh
anything crazy but he he also plays the
move Knight F3 to just see what you're
gonna play against it and then react
accordingly um and we see G6 played by
harika and uh I think that that means
okay I'll take the center you're not
gonna see too many Grand Masters Robert
shy away from that no white has these
two imposing Pawns in the center black
trying to use the pieces this is exactly
what Dania did against Jose Martinez and
in that game the white Palm went up to
D5 but here you see fobby saying I am
going to shut down your Bishop it kind
of resembles the king's Indian if we get
an E5 D5 situation with C4 to follow
this is exactly a king's Indian
structure
that's right and I'm trying to think
about the the Tempe but
um after D5 black moves the Knight I'm
always worried that you would be a move
down on a regular position
um so it could be a little bit weird but
I think for the most part white kind of
wants to keep that pawn on D4 if they
can H3 maybe play like Roy Lopez style
Knight F1 to G3 it also happen here and
look at harika bring her Knight to D7
please play D5 because F5 is much less
effective when white can instead of
playing D5 gets to take and take and
open up the position so she's hoping for
Fabi to press forward with D5 but he
seems like he does not want any part of
that
and I'd be very surprised if we don't
see uh some kind of A4 reaction
um Bishop G5 huh Color Me surprised
Robert I thought we were going to see A4
automatic
well with the color you surprised I have
the same color as you with my light so
I'm also quite surprised by this and
black could have played F6 but then the
bishop would have looked even worse a
queen E8 this game is kind of unexpected
for me I just feel like I don't know
what to make of the central tension I
don't know if A4 is actually a thread or
if I can make some other Move Like an H3
uh Amman is A4 and maybe A3 something
that white actually needs to look out
for
well according to me yes according to
Fabiano no you're curious what the
engine thinks as well because look A4
for white just shuts down uh any advance
on the queen side for black it means
that B3 Knight stays stationed on B3
which covers the D4 pawn and that D4
Pawn I've been mentioning earlier I
think it wants to stay on D4 because as
soon as you play D5 you open things up
for uh for black and uh well in order to
keep it there I thought A4 was necessary
Fabi says no I mean look at this Robert
that pawn made it all the way to A3
yeah and the evaluation bar is dipping
in Black's favor uh but it's a tough
position to play Knight F6 not approved
of I wonder what it is I'm just gonna
take us a step back quickly maybe it was
this F5 move which is really difficult
when there's a rook staring down on a
queen on the e-file but F5 was in the
spirit of the position F4 was threatened
to trap this bishop so I think F5 was
indeed the correct choice but I don't
blame harika or her yeah what a
ridiculous thing that was Knight G4 can
trap this bishop anyway get a trade so
why don't we leave these two to their
strategic struggle as their teammates
have all started their games a month we
see in the top right look at that's one
of the most closed positions I've ever
seen in my life between Nicholas
theodoro and Aditya matal and then the
rest of the games are just getting
underway yeah I'm wondering uh in that
game in the top right maybe we want to
head there I was curious if this was a
benko because it kind of feels like it
could have started as as a Banco Gambit
and that's you know surprising opening
to to see make an entrance
uh let's go back to the beginning and
we'll quickly play through the moves uh
this was not a Banco game but at least
not initially we saw C4 and then B4 for
white just trying to take away this
option and black says take it away I'll
go for it anyway because if you take
black will quickly be able to recapture
the pawn it's a reverse benko I was 50
right you know I I didn't give you the
credit that you deserved but come on I
mean these positions locked up no trades
just yet and as we get to the game I
actually really didn't like the move A5
closing this flank seems wrong to me you
should play for a pawn break because now
let's look what happened White Castle's
Queen side and closes everywhere the
center is closed now you know what that
means H3 G4 maybe the Knight will move
and then white will play for F4 I feel
like this was a very bad decision from a
ditchy Mattel because the side that
controls the pawn breaks is off on the
side with the advantage it's only white
who could storm pawns forward in this
position
yeah agreed this is uh probably quite
comfortable for for White and the main
reason is that normally E4 it looks like
great move but normally black would play
D takes E3 um and right now because the
king is Castle the other way it's not
possible
G5 is the move that he went for but I
think that was born out of like fear
necessity I mean call it what you want
Robert G5 surprising
I mean I I literally can't believe it
like I'm looking at this H4 tempting G4
he plays H3 first he's slow playing it I
actually like what he's doing he brings
his King all the way to the side and
then he can bring his Rook over he can
strike with H4 at the right moment and
if G4 he'll move his Knight and play
Pawn to F3 so he's going to crack open
the king side at some point and I like
what both players are doing here as he
reroutes his Bishop yeah I mean black
could not have better control over F4
honestly like that on G6 two pawns
Bishop I don't think there's any concern
about the move F4 happening so this game
is all about H4 but realistically fully
locked game with one idea to open things
up I don't think that's enough like I
think this one is actually quite level
because there's no f for coming and
things are so locked up that even if you
get one weakness on the king side often
need more than that to win the game and
often we see a Petrosian King march
where that King will go somewhere over
here rather the king well just run let's
get away from all the action because we
know it's going to open up black has no
choice because H4 let's say right now if
we can analyze for a second black will
not take it that would be a terrible
move you see the eval bar go all the way
up because after this kind of swap you
have a target white just simply pounces
on it and if you play G4 then the Knight
moves back to H2 and eventually F3 will
be played Rook F1 so the position opens
up by force there's nothing you can do
about it but it's all about timing and
well speaking of it Nicholas theodorus
is now is the time
yeah it goes H4 and it is G4 so you're
calling all these moves there's one
break in the position and is Pawn to F3
some point you feel you have to go for
it there's also kind of a funny move
like F3 Knight H5 to be wary of where
you know funny enough like you can't
defend your Jeep on
well it's really important to look out
for that I wasn't on my radar and now
that you mentioned I'm like whoa there
could be a fork of the Rooks because G3
cannot easily be defended maybe it's a
pawn you're willing to give up
oftentimes in positions where you want
an attack like throw a Pawn off the
board get an open file for a rook so yes
a messy Affair here between Theodore and
it's all
yeah this looks like exactly that King
March might be next Rook to G8
um I think if Black's King makes it to
C7 before white does anything decisive
then there's just nothing going on
agreed and I think black might throw in
B6 at some moment just to make sure uh
that this Pawn isn't hanging at an
inopportune moment but F3 now and I
think Knight H5 you called it in the
eval bar saying the advantage is heading
in Black's Direction it might be because
of Knight H5
yeah I'm looking at Knight H5 and I
don't see an answer like
to me this is like
should be kind of good for black I'm
wondering what I'm missing here because
D3 cannot be defended period so what
what is White gonna do
um
Theodore saw this he hasn't really oh he
just shook his head a little bit I was
about to say he hasn't reacted then
you've seen Knight H5 when you expect it
pawn H5 and now G3 is under attack black
is stealing one Pawn maybe two maybe
this Knight can get into F4 suddenly
adichie Mattel who drew five in a
carwana is poised for another good
result I would imagine I mean it doesn't
look worse anymore yeah net H5 Robert I
think that sets him up for Success here
and more importantly than Knight H5 you
know being a good move and in fact the
eval bar I'm just I'm in shock that it's
not liking this more
um but worse than that I think it's that
Nicholas missed the move so it's it's
uncomfortable to face a move that you
just didn't expect
although losing that g-pawn can be very
helpful there is a king on G7 and a rook
happily staring down the line through
all of the smoke so it's a big moment
for a digimatal will leave him to
thinking you see he's doing the typical
chess player pose hands on his head
let's see how the teammates are doing
because every game is ongoing here and
oh wow what is happening in the carwana
game against harika come on that looks
like it has changed quite a lot
that's wild that is a wild position uh
C6 on the board I'm trying to just
decipher how many things are hanging and
who's taking what
and who has taken what is black up a
pawn right now am i counting that
technically yes
oh that's right B5 what a positional
um move that is and Bobby I don't know
if he's wincing or smiling or what but
he's like give me the light squares I'll
take here bring my knight to C4 next and
instead it should be seven but that move
not approved by the engine
no I wonder if it's it's just like you
know if things open up here are blacks
pieces ready to to handle the the center
of the board like on takes on F5 for
example
um you know I kind of wonder if Black's
ready for the pressure on the epon
I don't think so and that's why she's
not taking she's not taking what she
does but the e-pawn might just drop as
the Knight is pinned to the queen E5 is
loose EF opens up another attacker here
yeah come on what what can black do why
is this like hovering slightly better
for white okay why is this okay yeah it
looks like terrible up to my eyes yeah
Rook V8 looks like a nice move I mean
you want to defend your Bishop which was
loose and obviously x-ray the queen so
you do have your own tactics now Bishop
C6 Bishop A6 are both uh on the cards
and it kind of forces white to
immediately react
and look at how Fabi does he takes away
both of your Bishop A6 and C6 moves
uh yeah that was not nice by Fabby I was
relying on those
and rookie doesn't work right because
Rook A8 just to show a quick line the
ship takes D7 you take my queen I take
your queen and whites up a piece at the
end of that variation yeah this is uh
this is no good and that's why uh Erica
had to play Rather strange looking
Bishop C8 never feel good playing a move
like that
oh gosh I mean her position's falling
apart you call this Amman black was not
ready for the center to open and now
it's open and it's just falling apart
yeah you almost have to go like I mean
so if you play Rook takes on F5 then
you're kind of you're covering the
e-pawn there but you're handing over the
E4 Square white already owns the C4
Square let's not forget like you know
down the line white could just win the
A3 Pawn back and black is like up a pawn
here maybe trying to claim that that's
something that's worth something but no
that pawn is dead if white ever wants it
Fabio wants more than that
he certainly does I wonder what his
response is going to be because Bishop
D3 we can go to a new diagonal and go
after this King that looks very pleasant
you mentioned Knight C4 and Knight E4 I
think for now I just am a little scared
about Rook takes F3 if this Knight were
to move but yeah he's just putting all
the pressure on and if the Rook moves
there's still Knight takes E5 because
the queen is hanging oh my goodness this
looks really bad good point yeah
you have Rook F7 for example Knight or
Rook takes E5 Rook F7 Knight E5 and
Bishop G6 is like lethal
this looks like a great position for the
archbishops and five minute card and one
more point is Rook F4 you hit the queen
but you lose a rook on the spot because
after I take and show that quickly you
have to take back with your Pawn hey you
got my queen but I get yours with
interest a little extra Rook so the
tactics are working in fabi's favor I
think harika's in big trouble but her
teammates some of them are doing very
well so let's go to our view of all the
boards uh because arika she may be uh
perhaps on her way to a loss in the top
left but look at the bottom right Amin
tabatabai in charge against Rochelle Wu
and the top right Aditya matal with the
upper hand against Nicholas theodoro
right yeah no this is uh this is what
you need from Amin he's he's coming in
he's playing against the uh board four
that's obviously a match up that you
know you want to capitalize on I think
that that game is one that we should
jump into uh Robert because we haven't
visited it yet and clear Advantage for a
man with the white pieces we tell you
that we love Bishops with an open board
and look at these two wow Bishop hits
all the way down to B7 can stop on e4 or
D5 the knights not coordinated very well
if your knight tries to come back in the
game your Rook probably just gets
trapped from the spot so uh it's White's
turn after all that is said and I feel
like you've got like D4 to open up just
not there this diagonal or your Bishop
as well unpleasant yeah there's so many
options here and uh you know Queen G4 is
has been the move tried I think there
are actually so many moves that you
could play as white and they'd all be
okay simple development D4 even just
going for the a file with Bishop E3 and
Rook A1 nice and simple Knight on d8 is
just Tethered to the defensive uh Duty
on the on a B7
yeah Black's pieces can't move the 987
want to go to F6 there's a rook in its
path Knight of Fate doesn't really help
as you said Rook A1 take over the a file
and this is really really bad for
Rochelle so she's had two very tough
pairings she played against our generic
guys see now she plays against the
nearly 2700 I mean
he's fully focused he wants to score uh
this victory for the team MGD one so
yeah I think she's gonna try her best
just to muddy the waters a little bit
but this seems very simple your mover K1
looks very powerful he wants to bring
your Rook to the other side
yep I like that it looks like it should
get the job done Rook down to A8 and
even be followed by like I'm like in a
queen C8 a lot of ways to to infiltrate
with every piece
no this looks overwhelmingly good for
white so let's uh you know leave these
two at it uh well
the meantime to buy considers his next
move it could just be Rook over to A1
we'll tune into the other teammates
because in the top left Fabiano caruana
is still in charge controlling all the
light squares but look at the top right
I don't know what has happened in that
game it's been a while since the
beginning but now it looks completely
closed I'm on are we single position
where neither side can make progress I
think we are and um I mean yeah okay the
move was Bishop H3 I think that the move
B6 uh it's just that last nail in the
coffin to really say okay no one's doing
anything here
um if you take on H3 then potentially
white could try to take with the queen
and even give up a pawn just for like
entry points into the position I'm not
sure that this is anything special but I
don't know it's something you might not
want to allow yeah this actually already
starts to look quite scary for the black
king you might survive it uh but white
will always have a bunch of checks
against that King so Bishop H3 no
response yet I don't really know how we
got here so we'll leave the analysis
board up uh we'll bring it back for you
uh just to show you how we got here
because it suddenly looked good for
black took a pawn the second Knight came
in and then this Knight traded so this
was the problem the king in line with
the Rook we see exactly why that's an
issue and wow I did too much tossing if
I'm gonna lose the pawn I'm Gonna Keep
your knight at Bay and not open the
position up more that's just brilliant
stuff
in Black it almost seems like might have
a small Edge in some of these positions
of course there they should be just
equal but
um I like the dark squares
yeah and I mean white was kind of
shuffling around and black could have
kept the bishop and then kicked it out
maybe that was the way to play for a win
is say where is your night going exactly
it's almost trapped but he forced the
Knight to take and then after Rook G5 we
saw the Swap and the King stepping
forward to G6 so Queen D7 I really like
that move not allowing this queen to
even think about getting in the game and
now after Bishop takes Rook takes there
are no open files for either side to
work with this is just a clear draw
barring some kind of crazy blunder
that's right B6 is almost a draw offer
in itself and uh we may just see the
pieces Shuffle black has like these
outside dreams of like taking the g-pawn
but guess what they're not happening
white has Rook G2 and you're Tethered to
the H5 pawn and defending it so yeah
this should be uh probably repetition of
moves where they might agree on a draw
there's no way to play for when where's
this King going right the king can go
anywhere but you're ultimately just
going to see the players repeat here
there's not even a mistake that can
possibly be made no there truly isn't
you'd have to you know react to Queen H3
with like a queen blunder that's
literally it
so this one is locked up I think the
draw will be in the bag a ditch him at
home that means he will have drawn
fabina carwana and then Nicholas
Theodore with the black piece is a great
start for the board four of team mgd1 so
let's zoom out of here we can trust the
players split this point and what else
is wait Fabiano car one let's go to our
bird's eye view following the car want
his Advantage seems to be a thing of the
past and you know what it looks to be
off the back of a move that you
highlighted which is so interesting Rook
takes on F3 has clearly happened in this
game
all right well let's dive in as the
Theodore addiction we're talking was
drawn let's go to the game between
caruana and harika dronavali uh you were
saying where it happened Rook takes
Knight that complicated matters white
still had an advantage but the king is a
bit Airy so let's see what happened we
saw a trade official comes to G7 extra
exchange for white should be winning so
where did Fabi actually blunt there he
went A3
and he missed I guess this Knight coming
to G5 and then back around to F4 things
of that nature and had to give up this
Pawn so still I guess an advantage for
white but black with some chances I mean
watch out yep I mean H3 should probably
happen but guess what The Rook on B1 so
cleverly defended by the queen on e4 so
Queen H1 just has nothing
amazing so we just bring up the analysis
board just a couple moves ago it seemed
like black was doing okay I guess for a
moment but it's the Eva bar saying
something rather being than it being
easy so where was it around uh here
right here I'm gonna cheat I'm gonna
turn on what the line is we see the Evo
okay Queen E7 somehow is the right move
it wants to go this way and this way all
right I get it but not that easy to find
no with limited time on the clock so
yeah that's uh
yeah this looks like the more natural
way because you know black wants to play
Bishop H6 the problem is there might be
a check like Rook B7 I think that's the
plan though if C7 you got F2 hanging
there's no check coming and Bishop H6 is
nearby Rook D7 just says no
great calculation by Fabi giving up F2
with check the king is running 92 is
another check but the king keeps going
to B4 and black quickly runs out of
useful checks as the king will just hide
maybe you can eventually up to the other
side of the board your problem seriously
they're full of Queen E5 you know Knight
D4 Queen E5 Knight C6 is obviously a
serious Pitfall there
don't play King B5 there's Knight C3
speaking of a pitfall wait where's this
King going if you give another oh you
can block with your queen that's super
annoying
yeah you could even just keep trucking
up the board there King D6 but yeah
Bishop is pinned that's what's key
Bishop f8 would change everything
would like win for black yeah
unfortunately pins or queen G1 I think
Queen E3 is the simplest move you have
no more checks for black after Queen to
E3 the threat is C7 maybe in some
variations nope can't draw my arrows
right now but Queen takes E5 is also
hanging with this pin yeah yeah I think
Queen E5 is maybe the more dangerous
move because it threatens to just
simplify everything if not made on the
spot whereas C7 blocks the pin on The
Rook so I could just see some random
Bishop FE coming
that's actually a good point there could
be almost a mate so he takes that Bishop
takes the Palm with check then we'll
play the pawn to C7 and that is bad news
or black
yeah I mean D7 probably worth trying
this queen takes E2 Queen takes C7 you
Harbor some hopes of a draw there
yeah some that's actually pretty good
chances to draw but I think Queen d7s
went by Knight B6 hitting the queen in
line from oh look at this that's clever
too
so check just to uh
get things perfect and I think you could
probably make your queen here
and the King
where can go anywhere like is it that
easy the king just uses it might be able
to yeah
well watch out night before don't play
King here because then Knight D5 is a
fork so watch out for the fork he does
now the king attacks the Knight the
Queens are going to win the day for Fabi
yep that should do it there are too many
queens on the board for Fabiano caruana
so he gets it done in round two it means
the score temporarily tied three to
three but if we look at the bottom right
of our screen it is all Amin Tabitha to
buy we don't need to look at that game
as he just is going to go on mop up Duty
winning the black pawns and he has a
past b-pawn uh in the making so let's go
to our game maybe Arjun aragaisy and
varujan a Cobian because we haven't
looked at that at all and VAR down to
just about 11 seconds with the black
pieces and for Arjun he's up on time but
this position even though it's better
for white not that clear-cut
yeah because you have Knight F6 and
Knight takes E8 but the result of that
line is your a pawn probably drops so
while White's position looks fantastic
the pawn on A4 is loose
and it's key that the D6 Pawn is loose
as well but he's not taking it right
away because oftentimes with these
trades happening The Rook will come to
E1 C1 Kick That Knight out of there and
get whoa okay he goes for it but I
thought the Rook was gonna just go over
here and kick this Knight away
yeah I guess the thing is there was no
breaking through that position because
the Knight on C3 was just Tethered to
the a pawn the entire time so may as
well at some point start the
simplification process but Knight D5
Rook takes C4 it's not to move her
Knight A4 first
I think you could choose your own
adventure oh is
my I'm wondering like is there some kind
of like C5 push at some moment I don't
think so because the Rook can just take
but what is the winning idea for Arjun
that's starting to look like it should
be a draw yeah it does I I mean I think
he's not there yeah that's true G5 was
really rough
he's simply blundered and he gives away
the H6 pawn and now Arjun clearly has
the upper hand Knight is uh covering C4
and the Knight on A4 is just stuck
can't move right Rook takes P6
we were just asking what can white do
the answer had been nothing until the
pawn went to G5 because the Knight had a
square to jump to an F5 but Rook A6 now
that should be able to Corral this Pawn
here and white spawn doesn't look so
stoppable yeah and Knight takes C4 Rook
C6 still works
that's a nasty
pin to make you seven okay if you take
on C4 I guess there was a
oh my gosh I'm gonna I'll show it after
the game another sick tactic by Arjuna
guys he sees everything just to show
that quickly as VAR can't believe it
he's beside himself but Rook C4 there's
Rook AA check your king can't step up to
E7 has to go to D7 and Knight B6 with a
fork hydrogen Air Guys he sees all the
tactics no matter how big or small yeah
that's a super nice uh tactic there uh
B6 check closes it off but you'll notice
that with these really strong players
they'll close games with casual tactics
like moves don't even not even
everything that gets played is what's
actually being calculated so so many
things flying under the radar
yeah and that was a big result for team
mgd1 because it looked like St Louis
archbishops they would at least tie the
round that's not what just happened mgd1
once again wins by two and a half one
and F score a mean tablet to buy took
care of business against Rochelle Wu
that was expected based on the earlier
position Arjun that game was looking
like I was heading towards a draw and he
steals that Victory and helps the team
mgd1 to a 5-3 lead
yeah Robert uh the story so far for me
is Aditya mital he stole two draws from
Fabiano caruana and Nicholas theodoro
and we talk about board four their games
only get easier so Aditi Mattel is uh I
mean doing extremely well from the board
four position he's got a point he hasn't
lost yet I think he's been playing
tremendously so I think he's uh he's the
MVP of the match thus far
he's the MVP of the match for team mg D1
and well since we're on the topic of MVP
candidates we have to talk about Luca
doncence the NBA All-Star he is making
his way into the Chess World because
four time NBA All-Star Luka Dodgers has
officially launched his meta human Luke
A.I onto the chess scene for a limited
time you can challenge Lucas AI sidekick
and watch it grow stronger with
experience will it be enough for Luke AI
to secure victory in the computer Chess
Championship that much is up to you use
the command Luca in chat to play Dao and
I'm on have you played Luca I'm not
asking about basketball and have you
played the Luca bot
I mean if you're asking about basketball
you obviously wouldn't know the answer
so you know it could be yes could be no
but in terms of the chat spot I actually
have uh I have a YouTube video playing
against somewhere uh let's just say I
took the liberty of playing in while he
was only like 500 Hilo before he's
gotten stronger and stronger and I had a
little fun uh checkmating him with some
Artistry on the board
love that well you have to beat him
while they're young or before the bot
becomes a super human computer that uh
is something that everybody should take
part and you could play because AI
bought a chess.com but for now Amanda
and I are gonna scram we'll be back in a
few it is the St Louis archbishop's
trailing team mgd1 we'll see if they can
bounce back after this break
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we return to this week two pro chess
League matchup between the St Louis
archbishops and team mgd1
mgd1 is in the lead by two full points
at the moment they are led by Arjun era
geisi as their top board but they
brought in a free agent signing Amman I
mean I would say I mean Hamilton wow a
meme has been a superstar thus far hey
the first names are pretty close I uh I
missed out on uh buying the right vowel
for a better ELO reading unfortunately
but he's been a great signing I mean
what can we say started out well I'm
definitely interested to see how these
next two rounds go because you know it's
one thing to say that Eric icy tabatabai
they've started out well but they've
been playing the lower rated sports for
St Louis so now we get to see them play
against the higher rated boards I think
that is where you can really measure the
impact of these players
and they have made a huge impact thus
far a great one-two punch on the top two
boards for team mgd1 and we see we can
just compare them directly to the org
one and board two for the archbishops
half a point in favor of Team mg D1 as
Arjun is two to one Fabi Amin has one
half to get over his one and then even
on board three both players drawing one
game and losing the second but then
addiction metal he's been your MVP Iman
he has one out of two so as we head into
the third round let's talk about it your
MVP edition metal gets the black pieces
there against
but the top two boards for mgd1 they get
white against karwana
yeah I think uh it's been an amazing
start for team mgd1 not just because
they're up but because I think that the
type of roster they've gone for more
balanced I think that that roster you
know if they get ahead early I think
they should be doing better and better
as the rounds go on I said this in the
first match but I really think that's
the case St Louis has missed their
opportunities with Fabiano you know not
winning against Ward four with Nicholas
theodoru not winning against board four
uh there are points left on the table
here for St Louis so now we're going to
see adity Mattel with the black pieces
draw would be another tremendous result
he's also going to have white in the
final round against Rochelle Wu didn't
finish with something like two and a
half points which would be unbelievable
for team mgd1 it's what Lou yaping did
for the Shanghai Tigers earlier board
Forest scoring a plus score and we'll
see if that is what's going to happen
but I'm in a carwana I mean we always
want to focus on his games when he is
playing he gets the black pieces against
Amin to have it to buy and Amin means
business today he drew in round one
there was no choice for him he had black
against the strong Grand Master barujan
or kobian but then in game two he you
know made quick work it seemed of
Rochelle Wu he had the upper hand from
start to finish but now he has his most
difficult opponent of the day I'm on he
gets white but he's playing as Fabiano
if you are the team captain for mgd1 do
you say to him hey just come on man just
make a draw and you say hey go for it
you know we can end this match here in
the third round
well honestly I would probably say go
for it like uh this is round three not
round four where you know all the
information and you can sort of play for
your final result that you want uh A Min
both Amin and Eric icy those are these
guys are Fighters right they're they're
here to play and I think because we're
only in round three you don't want to
psych the players out tell them to get
in their own heads play a different
style to secure results uh I mean
absolutely stick to to what has been
working so far and Fabiano has not
looked you know he he did win his last
game Robert but I'd say he's looked a
little shaky to start things off
allowing a lot of counter play in his
previous win and that draw of course in
the first round against board four
he also looks like he's playing from the
next room like he's so far away from the
camera right now uh he's maybe a little
bit too relaxed after a victory but this
opening the four nights in the English
we see that white has this compromised
pause structure over here but white that
also has the pair of Bishops so what's
your experience like in these variations
Amman because I know I've struggled with
both colors in a position with this kind
of imbalance
yeah the the one thing for black is
there's a kind of a nice plan of trying
to play F5
um black has a couple different plans
there's F5 and some degree there's also
you know A6 and B5 but I find the A6 B5
plan to undermine that pawn works a lot
better when you know the pawn from D2 is
on E3 and that would happen if maybe you
played D takes C3 we've seen bc3 by
white in the opening so I'm looking for
black to maybe move that Knight right
for F5 if the bishop gets that five
you're certainly happy to see that
um so that's one of the main plans for
for black here the other one which is
harder to achieve based on the pieces
Robert is maybe C6 D5 but that just
looks like so many moves to achieve that
yeah too far away and for I mean is not
going to push his Pawn to D4 unless it's
the proper moment because well now the
Knight went to E7 I'm a little bit more
tempted but what I was going to say is
as soon as you push the pawn to D4 C4
becomes an easier Target but this Knight
now is in the k inside you're not so
worried the Knight would go to A5 Pawn
B6 Bishop A6 and you see that in the
nimso Indian black just piling up
pressure against that pawn but instead
Bobby going to the king side and I'm on
I mean it's hard to crack through
Black's structure right now
it absolutely is
um you know the the knights are also
sort of eyeballing a potential F4 Square
visit Knight H5 always have to be uh
cautious of Knight takes E5 tricks with
the Knight hanging but in general if you
could get that Knight into F4 uh black
wants to play Knight F4 you know Queen
F6 and really uh launch some nice play
against White's King here so I I imagine
that that's what fabby's looking to do
as for white Robert I mean these double
puns are you in a rush to get rid of
them are you looking at like C5 kind of
stuff or are you just gonna get
developed I feel like C5 is one of those
moves you make like I need to get rid of
the double pawns but if we quickly bring
up an analysis board it doesn't solve
all of your problems because if you play
C5 and I'm just gonna make a random move
like rookie 8 just to get this swap of
Pawns here now you actually have this
backwards Pawn on C3 so your Pawn
structure seemingly improved because you
no longer have double pawns but you
actually have a more approachable Pawn
to the black pieces with the bishop
moving and The Rook coming to C8 made a
queen to C7 yeah good point good point
there uh you're not really uh not really
solving any problems actually creating
some because in this position it's kind
of hard to attack the C pawns without an
open file so I mean it's hilarious you
might see the exact position
I was not expecting this to happen I was
just throwing out moves and it looks
like Fabiano caruana you know he is a
long time buddy of mine and he's just
playing like I'm speaking it so uh let's
watch your random move rookie that has
random move apparently is one of the
best you know uh co-signed by Fabiano
caruana what a chat by the way I think
this matchup might be the most vowels
against each other I didn't think about
that but Fabiano caruana gets a mean
tablet to buy they're a pick of vowel
it's it's in there uh so uh wow this
exact variation just happened we may see
some problem for white on the
see-through square but we'll come back
to this game for sure because all four
games are in progress right now and in
these matchups you need to score
somewhere if you are the archbishops
you're down by two points I'm looking at
that game in the top right a month
between Arjun aragaisy and Nicholas
theodoru and I feel like arjun's just
trying to take it to the archbishops he
already has two wins under his belt here
and he wants to take a third yeah I
agree that game looks really exciting
um to take a look at uh it seems as
though in the last couple moves uh he's
made his intentions very clear right
Queen C2 absolutely no Queen trade
um you do want to keep the Queens on the
board the G file is open the D5 square
is screaming for a night to be planted
there this looks great for white yeah
the D5 square is ultra juicy and this is
what happens when there's a bishop
against a knight you it kind of reminds
me of a night or it's not the same
structure of course not uh but in the
night or if you get these positions
sometimes where black has a dark sword
Bishop that can't do anything and white
has a knight that hops around the light
squares in particular D5 the good news
compared to a night or Japan's not on D6
it can go up to C6 get that Knight out
of there that's right and Bishop d8 was
just played it might look a little
unorthodox but I feel like if the bishop
went to D6 or you know another kind of
normal looking square and all of a
sudden comes Rook G1 and they're
actually threatening Checkmate in two
threading Knight F6 check and queen H7
mate
yes I was actually looking spicy so the
bishop covering the F6 square is
important look at this move C6 is not
good anymore the Knight hops back to an
odd Square to B4 look at this I'm just
gonna put this on the board You're Now
Pawn is under attack you play C5 you're
just strategically lost you might be
tactically lost as well but you can just
resign strategically if I put my knight
on D5 or to C6 give me all the light
squares that's right yeah that would be
just the worst possible configuration
but if we can't do that what are we is
is do we want to play almost A5 I mean
the pawn is hanging I want to play A5
and then C6 but way too slow this
threat's happening H5 Queen takes E5
Rook G1 enough time for all that
I forgot the E5 Palm was saying I wasn't
even looking at that pawn on the spot uh
rookie eight played so now maybe there's
C6 because you can bring your Rook up to
E6 afterwards but it's true is looking
just like a shaky defense for theodoro
here I really don't envy this task I
just
I love that Knight on D5 it's a stallion
it is it is I'm also thinking you know
if the move F4 happens that black might
have F5 quite possibly
wow decides to just start with that
he says give me the light squares then I
can go to C6 they're also tactics
available for white but
what do you make of the Samana I really
feel like white is better even though
the eval Bar says black is doing just
fine
exactly how I feel like vishvan d8's a
little bit strange there's no Queen E6
move uh you know funny enough The Rook
on A8 would be hanging and if you play
F5 you're always facing Queen D5 check
uh seems like a nice centralizing move
Knight on C6 looks annoying because you
can't play rookie six to challenge that
and I'm just kind of wondering what what
moves you're supposed to do so I agree
with you I like White's position but the
engine is saying there's unfazed
how why I just love the look of a night
landing on C6 but somehow the engine is
unbothered but it's just a great square
like that's your that's your dream
Square it's a Target Square truly you
just want to bring the Knight up over to
the C6 Square yummy give me that square
yeah honestly Knight C6 looks like a
good move here I'm looking at like Queen
E6 after
maybe yeah maybe right that's how we
feel we're like okay maybe the E5 Pawn
might be loose but also they're going to
be tactics with the rook in line with
the queen so I guess uh for now black is
holding on I would prefer white maybe
even just H5 at some moment uh Knight C6
first I like saving the night and trying
to push this Pawn up and uses a
battering ram so we'll see if origin
erag icy can break down the defenses of
Nicholas Theodore but for now let's look
how the teammates are doing just because
this one seems like arjun's slightly
better but what's happening in the other
Awards five minute caruana slightly
better according to the engine in the
top left in the bottom left varicobian
maybe slightly better for the Archbishop
still early stages there what's going on
the bottom right Michelle Wu is going
after harika's Pawn structure but the
eval bar is saying nah arika's doing
just fine
yeah I like to look at that game that
looks very spicy
um especially with the imbalance that's
clearly present two Bishops four black
in that position but you see this
interesting
situation where the Knight was just
making a ton of threats but once they
just got defended the knights also
trapped
whoa and F4 throwing the pawn forward
you're right the Knight was about to be
trapped but now it can hop back to F2 so
are these pawns total terrible
weaknesses oftentimes black will try to
push pawns on the queen side at some
moment E3 is not really a Target just
because e-file doesn't have a rook on it
just yet but this is hard to evaluate I
see the evaluation so I know that black
is better objectively but I'm still
trying to ignore that and use my chess
player brain and I feel like this just
is messy and both sides have their
chances
I I think you lost the chat as soon as
you said you know not look at the bar
and use your brain
um I think you lost everyone there
Robert but uh I agree it it's what it's
kind of a misleading evaluation I feel
like because look at that pawn structure
and you can definitely appreciate
Black's King is weak here and if white
moves that Knight for example like Queen
D2 or Rook F3 followed by the Knight
moving and maybe G4 F5 you could start
to really push some pieces around
yeah workout 3 is a great move that Rook
may also slide to H3 uh this Pawn on H6
is a bit of a Target so I don't really
like the look of it there yeah I um
I don't know I'm worried about that pawn
on H6 I feel like there's a rook sliding
and you can bring your knight back you
said push this g-pawn up
black is still better though I'm trying
to wrap my head around that black is
objectively better but I kind of want to
have the white pieces exactly
um it's one of those positions where you
know for sure you know B5 B4 is coming
long term or black so
this is always going to be a decent
position for a hurricane but in the
short term Rook H3 trying to launch that
attack this stuff can get really scary
um and I'm trying to look at the Times
there looks like nothing too bad for for
black because the worst thing is
defending and be down on time
that's right and the H6 Pawn now is a
clear Target with a knight on a five
kind of doing the heavy lifting for
black protecting that pawn uh maybe it's
time to try to bring a Queen on over to
the uh King side but the Knight covers
all of these squares and instead she
goes to C2 the engine not thrilled about
that choice
yeah Queen C2 and trying to think like
what was the idea with Queen C2 is it
because the Knight on F5 can't be
dislodged too easily between D2 you know
at least guards the E3 Pawn basically
what's the follow-up to Queen C2 because
I don't know how to add more pressure to
Knight on F5
yeah I mean what you know Rook F1 Rook
F3 I don't see H5 rookie this feels like
a very long way away just to make that
Journey so yeah I don't know what
White's gonna do I don't really know
what Black's gonna do either so while
these two players are working on it
let's see how their teammates are doing
just because this feels like you go
either way all three results possible
and the bottom left I see the eval bar
up or varusian okobion he needs to get
this dub it's against your hero for the
mgd1 squad adichie Mattel seems to be in
huge trouble maybe even in a losing
position against a Cobian yeah and far
as I mean this is his kind of position
it's so stable there's no threats to the
king he's just grinding down a slightly
better position and he's increasing the
advantage it seems like with every move
E5 has been played he's gonna create a
weakness on C6 E4 is also a Target A4 is
a target meanwhile white has pretty much
nothing that black can attack so I mean
VAR could not have hoped for better thus
far and uh now it's about the conversion
phase
yeah there are uh problems ever Knight
B6 trying to trade off the knights but
you're right this Pawn this Pawn this
Pawn all the Pawns in the position are
worse or black so huge Advantage for the
very experience Grandmaster Kobe so for
those of you not familiar with vars play
he loves his solid openings whether it's
the French defense or the caracon is
black he just tries to be as solid as a
rock and play for little positional
edges so uh we
see that the St Louis archbishops have
been down by two points they're fighting
back and we are going to bring back
their team captain and Nemo so she's
going to join us talk about what's
happening here so uh if we can bring her
on that's ideal and hey Nemo how are you
feeling I know your team's down two
points heading into the round but seeing
the games unfold right now you're
feeling a little bit better with Farr uh
yeah
absolutely I really like a copian's
position I actually just heard you guys
talking about it and talking about how
he likes his really positional sound
openings and it looks like he's come out
of it with a slight Edge and it looks
great I we we just need to make up the
two points you know that's all we have
to do
yeah yeah you know it's it's nice when
you say it out loud it doesn't sound as
daunting I mean two-point lead is kind
of significant but I mean with the the
lineup That St Louis has you can
definitely make that up in an entire
round and personally from the positions
that I know VAR thrives in Nemo I I
think he's gonna win this game for sure
yeah I think he's got you know a pretty
confident
game right now he's got a very solid
Advantage I don't see any way for this
to go wrong so honestly and all the
other boards are more or less equal you
know
um maybe Nicholas has to do a little
defense but other than that I think it's
it's going pretty well so I'm looking
forward to the results here
totally with you I mean this is just
clean play White spawn structure super
healthy this is a great Pawn chain
punching as strong as his base Pawn good
luck getting to F2 whereas Black's pawns
all out in the open so while uh VAR and
Aditya they don't have moves going let's
kind of zoom out for a second because uh
you mentioned how Nicholas might have a
little bit of defensive task what about
Fabiano on the top left his position
looks very healthy and he has nearly a
five minute lead on the clock
honestly I like the five minute lead I
care about the five minute lead a lot
more than I care about the you know
equal position
it is a ten plus two format so tapatabe
is going to get increment but it's Queen
and knights and there's like the staying
in end games you you like having you
know you like to pair Queens with
knights because you get more control
over different squares so I like his
chances especially with five minutes
with six minutes to one minute like
that's that's pretty solid and he's
pushing his pawns he might go for H3 or
something I really like that structure
for for Fabi he's pushing for a win for
sure
yeah this looks this actually does look
like a position structurally uh White's
Queen side pawns look a little
disconnected and with H3 coming in you
might get to a situation where like
White's King is under you know constant
threat and meanwhile the queen side
pawns are are also a problem so fabby's
like creating problems on both sides of
the board which I think is a great
strategy
absolutely rule of two weaknesses right
that's right exactly exactly that and I
was thinking you know and he drew his
first game so if you're like oh what's
Favi what's wrong with him but he was
playing a very strong player he won game
two and now he's posing all the problems
here in the third game but uh you know
the pressure is kind of on each and
every individual on St Louis they feel
like they have to win because they
entered the match uh they're around the
match here down by two points and oh
fabi's hopping his Knight around and
watch out
yeah a lot of attacks are coming
it's looking over Fabi
you'd like to see these weaknesses
suddenly the F4 Square you know maybe
even throwing the pawn to H3 I think if
the Knight moves from E3 we might even
see a sack on G4
anything app I really like the Knight
coming to F4
um white it just has to play so
carefully now and with
such little time on the clock I think
it's very very likely that fobby is able
to pull off a win in this game
you have King F2 you can play Queen D3
and try to get a queen tree because
there are Forks everywhere that's why
the king stepped here so this is the
only piece not in the game there's not
enough six like if you could bring this
Knight somewhere you would feel great
about it but all right so say I want to
give the D5 Square I forgot what the
other night well maybe maybe there's
like some night age
seven Knight G5 ideas just coming for
the F Pawn coming for the H3 Square as
well
a lot of a lot of things are definitely
happening
yeah maybe uh maybe Queen C6 Queen takes
C3 setup yes you keep those those are
the things that sometimes work when
you're low on time and you know Abby is
gonna be so good I think at using his
time advantage to create these little
problems that are tough to navigate
absolutely to be fair to avatave is
26.55 so you know I don't know if the
Cheapo might work but you can always go
first I forgot I wasn't uh back on my
stream uh doing stuff Sunday with the
chat yeah sorry I got carried away there
oh well fobby's in great shape here in
this game but let's zoom out for a
second because you know every single
point is important for the squad as well
I mean I mean is living on the increment
look at the bar it actually dipped in
that game as soon as we left it from
Fabi and we'll go right back it looks
like the king quickly went to F2 I
mentioned Queen D3 as one option I
actually don't know what white does
after Queen E3 because your thread is
simple take and then Fork on D3
yeah it looks really uncomfortable
honestly
that's a powerful Fork I mean after
Queen D3 I assume you just have to play
Queen to D2 but uh black just looks like
he has so many options in this position
I can hardly move you can post so many
threats it's the Nemo
I like it it's great choice yeah
activating you know yeah
can hardly move I mean okay you get one
Pawn push you can pin this Knight over
here maybe we'll see a queen try to go
to d8 but I don't think fobby's gonna
one of us are going to back rank
Checkmate or anything like that
yeah no backlink Checkmate but if Queen
C5 Queen D2 Knight G5 Queen d8 actually
wins that Knight might not win the game
because there might be like a knight D3
to follow but it's kind of a weird Fork
there there's that H3 though right
because you have the fork you can just
win the queen
oh that's nasty so maybe a cheapo Knight
G5 no he didn't play 95. what is this
Bobby we were just flatting out
tapatabase we mapped out the whole
blender yeah
he's too he's too strategic he's saying
you played C4 let me get my knight into
D4 come on fobby we want tactics not
strategy right now he's too strong
that's the problem right now
faster if you just cheapoed I actually
think that is true like no joke I think
he would have won like on the spot if he
had played but this is also domination
Bishop A3 okay the queen can just move
pick a square anywhere maybe C6 or C8 I
don't know pick one
yeah there's just no way for white to
really break through I mean I like Queen
C8 because maybe after Queen at B4
there's some Queen f8 idea so you're
just preemptively stopping that and then
you just go for Knight takes F3
um with no worries at all so I like that
idea a lot
mm-hmm
yeah every move looks more or less
yeah I think Bobby said well when he
listens to you exactly every move looks
more or less like your moves that's what
I was about to say this is the job of
the captain you know
I'm feeding him brain waves very nice oh
look at this move Knight B5
this is an amazing game just take let's
take this take that play H3 and go check
me this king that's so extravagant yeah
that's so
yeah that's some Favi style right there
that's great
I feel like there's got to be a mate
somewhere of the Queenie too let's go
right for this King exactly yeah we need
to King H3 and just sit there for a sec
calculating he's just thinking right now
yeah Queenie too
hey at least I got one yes
wow what a win for Fabi there gorgeous
so uh near me feeling a little bit
better now after uh that victory
absolutely I mean that game was was
beautiful there's just G5 finishing off
the game you're threatening Queen F1 the
only way white can defend is Queen C1
and then you can just take on F3 with
Checkmate I mean that's that's a really
nice tactic to spot and the whole setup
leading up to that moment was great so
you know we're now only down one point
and as far as the other games go
I'm feeling pretty good about the match
overall
um acopian still you know winning in his
Rook end game I'm sure with as much
experience as he does have he can win
this freaking game I wouldn't be so
confident you know
and myself but I think he's got he's got
this one down
I mean I'm confident in your play you
just told Fabi what to do he did
everything he won the game so uh it's a
clean extra Pawn for bar Kobe we did see
that Rochelle Wu is probably about to
lose her game to harika drone of all
that's what happens I went board four uh
for one team is lower rated than the
rest but right now we see that uh Marco
been up a minute up a pond and it's a
healthy passer and come on that was your
hero that was a ditching batal he was
the one who was uh upsetting the
archbishops but not in this round well
you know hang on I I think there's work
to be done like it's definitely about as
bad as an end game could get for black
because your king is cut off but hey the
white king doesn't have progress to make
and it's not entirely clear what White's
gonna do if black just shuffles this
Rook
right I think you have to yeah go for
the F3 Palm Bush but I don't really see
like what Robert you're you're an expert
on games what would you say White's plan
here would be
well definitely to get this King
eventually around this way but do not
take this Pawn they're losing the spot
Rook B7 Pawn a seven Rook B that's
obvious so uh for varicobian so I think
what you have to do is just move back
and forth and when this King eventually
runs away the black g-pawn will become a
passer and distract the white forces so
the Eva bar actually went down I've
sorry to say that Nemo uh
oh no this could be a spoiled
opportunity for the uh archbishops but
Nemo I know you're streaming and we do
want to let you have calmer territory
with your channel so thanks for uh
joining us here and I just have to say
our generic icy beat Nicholas Theodore
so I'm gonna send you on your way in
sorry to be the bearer of bad news but
it's always great to have you on the
show
very much for having me
see ya
bye
oh this could be really bad for the
archbishops because it looks like
Rochelle Wu lost her game to harika
dronavali
um Arjuna geisi he won against Nicholas
theodoro and in this game
oh as soon as she leaves there was a
mistake and the epon is gonna win the
day
I
don't get that because
it seems rather trivial that you just
throw the epon up the board and the King
can never leave G7 and H7 right
no the King has to stay put because as
soon as the King goes this way everybody
The Rook slides to h8 if the King goes
to F6 Rook f8 check you're about to see
this happen and then you get a promotion
I think we're gonna have to tune back to
that moment because it said the game
should have been a hold and now it's
obviously it lost a ditchy Mattel is not
happy yeah I I I know that G4 was like
obviously a clear blunder varusian and
Kobe winning that end game he is pumped
up that's great for his confidence but
what was missed here because G4
definitely doesn't make sense but let's
say black does nothing and goes like
King G7 isn't white also playing E4 and
running a pawn up the board yes and the
reason why is because what we saw in the
game the white king stepped in front of
the pawn so it appears it was much
trickier than methi Rook a one check you
keep checking this King because the King
goes too far in this direction up to C3
then when you play G4 oh right you need
the king to scramble back here and it
cannot so that would have been what
black needed wow yeah so I mean I was I
was thinking that mittal was actually
going to pull that bra out which would
have been huge for mgd1 but R is uh
playing a little bit of a hero here
especially considering the other results
uh in this round Robert it was not
looking good for St Louis
no it was not we see the results on
screen it was a win for five minutes
carwana and Arjun era guys even that one
up on the board one then board three for
each side took down board four so it was
board ones and board three the higher
rated players did win for each team and
now that this round is over Amman this
brings us to a 7-5 lead for team mg D1
we know that one and a half points for
team MGD one wins the match what's the
archbishops need to do to fight back
well Robert it's it's gonna sound dire
because it is but um honestly adity
Mattel I think has a big advantage on
board four so Rochelle needs at least a
half a point I think that's where it
starts because uh GM's on all other
boards for the archbishops any of those
results could swing either way but you
need Rochelle to get on the board here
not necessarily with a win but just a
draw because I think you know losing all
your games I mean she's been playing up
every round is so tough for her but
without every other player on her team
over performing she's gonna need to put
some points up otherwise this win is uh
is just too far out of reach so with 7-5
here Robert I think it starts at the
bottom with Rochelle she can make a draw
then moving up the the rankings
obviously everyone on the St Louis
roster can win these matchups even
though they'll be super tough games you
heard it from Amman Hamilton Started
From The Bottom then they get there it
would appear but Rochelle wuf well she
will have a tough matchup and Fabiano
caruana and arjunaire guys see they're
scoring big points for their respective
squads we're gonna step aside take a
quick break when you return it's the
fourth and final round of action here in
the Pro chess League matchup between the
St Louis archbishops and team MGD one
you'll want to miss it because we'll see
if the archbishops come out to come back
stay tuned everybody be right back
[Music]
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
thank you
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the last round is upon us which means
that the top boards will be squaring off
against one another and that means we'll
get Fabiano caruana taking on Arjun
aragaisi now five minute carwana is a
protest League MVP in previous years and
look at this Amon number eight player in
the world we used to see him at number
two he's lost some rating points
reigning U.S champion and has just
thrived in the PCL environment
absolutely I mean Fabiano caruana has
been representing St Louis archbishops
every single year I mean he's been in
the PCL since the Inception Robert you
see a two-time PCL Champion with the St
Louis team uh you know MVP as well just
a star on on the roster so it would be
you know fitting if St Louis was going
to manage a comeback in this round that
their star player and multiple time
Champion was gonna lead them uh to do it
with a win of course to inspire the team
yeah inspiring the team he'll need to do
that and win his game because Arjun
aragi has not just inspired he's been
perfect on the day so as we see the
clash between all the boards that are
next to each other board one versus one
two versus two and so on I'm in a car
one two and after three great score but
even greater Is three out of three and
that's what Arjun aragaisy brings into
the final round
yeah and you can see the the based on
the scores here the difference does come
on those lower boards Nicholas theater
not having his best day he definitely
needs to win this final uh game to turn
things around and like I said Rochelle
Wu getting on the board even with a draw
would be a great result she has been the
underdog in every game that she's played
Robert and I think when you go for this
stacked lineup plus a lower rated board
four uh you know it's tough for them to
get any points on the board plus I mean
you start your a playing against our
generic icy that doesn't necessarily
Inspire confident
now it's a day mayor it's a nightmare it
doesn't matter what time of day that's a
tough opponent but for Rochelle Wu she
has a chance here in the fourth and
final round but it's not that easy of
course not it's International Master
Aditya Mattel with the white pieces on
board four but I look at the top Fabiano
it's white against Arjun Nicholas
Theodore gets wet against Amin Tabitha
to buy and bar gets black against harika
I feel like I actually like the color
combination for the archbishops they
need to score at minimum a 3-1 win in
this final round so I think they got the
colors that you would ask for them given
the State of Affairs
yeah for sure I think that
um VAR needs to uh come up big on board
three there uh for the archbishops and
Nicholas theodoro and Rochelle Wu those
are the boards that I'm looking at
because those are the players for the
archbishops that have been struggling
thus far in the match Robert so I'm
looking there first for some early
results see how those games are gonna go
but obviously this is a team effort
you're down seven five you need three
points just to make tie breaks three and
a half to win uh you need everybody to
perform this is reminiscent of what we
just commentated on this morning isn't
it Robert
yeah it's very similar and I think for
mgd1 you look at addition metal and say
be that hero that Iman Hamilton said you
could be and win that game against
Rochelle Wu because if he does win he is
the higher rated player by a significant
margin that means only one draw on the
other boards would be required but we're
off it's in English from 500 carwana
these two have played each other many
times they drew at the Tata steel event
in uh by kanzei just last month they
play each other in a nail biter in the
speed test Championship which I've been
a car wanna surprise many and won that
matchup so it's a new day it's a new
game and by the way is that a new outfit
for arches that's an mgd1 shirt yeah I
was uh noticing that as his cam was
being pulled up there mg D1 little Pro
chess League logo pretty slick I don't I
can't remember it and now I'm wondering
if everyone has been wearing this
t-shirt the entire match but maybe it's
just him
yeah I have not looked but that actually
is some drip for uh the MGD one Squad
just a t-shirt with the pro chest League
logo and their team's logo and right now
the team is on the verge of taking this
match Knight G3 played and we see a
trade of Bishop so opposite colored
Bishops not just the draw this isn't an
end game
um a month what do you make of this
opening do you think it was a good
choice for carwana in a must win game
and Arjun has more time than he started
with
yeah I you know surprisingly
I would probably say Yes
um the reason is that games with
opposite Bishops tend to last a really
long time so you are going to get a lot
of gameplay out of this one Bishop on D3
Knight we'll go back to H4 if it gets
attacked and you know King side castling
there is definitely still life in this
position I think I've seen this in the
protest League before can't remember the
players right now but I've definitely
seen this exact line uh been essayed so
far and for black it's tough to just
trade pieces right there's not a lot of
you know squares where you can get your
Knights to to immediately challenge
things white plays Bishop D3 and the
Bishops aren't going to take each other
I don't know how the knights are gonna
challenge one another either so nice
thing for Fabi is I think he's keeping
pieces on the board here so much so he
just played A3 he doesn't want to deal
with maybe bishop before
takes that out of the equation no pin on
that Knight and C5 not really going to
be possible with the D5 Pawn being loose
but not easy for black to play there are
no Pawn breaks at the moment and white
with a pawn structure aiming towards the
queen side maybe a Carlsbad a pawn
minority attack up the queen side and
for black pawn structure aiming towards
the king side maybe we'll see F5 join
the party to limit the scope of this
bishop on F1 but you already have to
think about potential night sacks and
things of that nature so uh Arjun he is
going to take a minute here and while he
does why don't we zoom out because every
single St Louis Archbishop player
they're looking at the boards they need
to win their games in the top right
Nicholas Theodore against Amin Tabitha
Bai I feel like a good start for the
archbishops the exact type of position
it's going to be dynamic and the bottom
left well we only have seen a few moves
in the Catalan between harika and
varujanakobian
yeah exactly there's not much that is
developed in that particular game yet
but obviously a Min and Nicholas
Theodore this is a super important game
I think we should probably jump there
Robert
let's do it because I mean just lost in
the third round two Fabiano while he had
the white pieces and we see that we have
this Dynamic it's kind of a king's
Indian structure but instead of striking
the center with E5 we just see the pawns
on C6 and D6 not striking just yet and
well I'm on this pin on the Knight and
F3 is black going to take white can't
play H3 now because D4 is hanging at the
end I guess my big question is this
trade on F3 is that actually good for
black to hand white the pair of Bishops
well it's never a good feeling to do
that but I definitely think that's the
intention especially when I see move
like Knight D7 here it just takes away
the diagonal shortens it from chh3 so
after H3 there's no words for that
Bishop to go of course as you mentioned
HD right now does actually drop that
deep on so we'll see moves like Rook D1
we'll see moves like Bishop E3 from
White looking to over protect and guard
that deep on and black in the meantime
playing C5 and I was wondering after D5
if we would see just Mass exchanges but
no he's taken and I wonder if if uh
black is intending to still take that
Knight on F3 now that this exchange has
happened Robert I'm playing H3 in a
heartbeat I'm gonna give me that pair of
Bishops we have a maroxy bind uh Pawn
structure these great pawns on C4 and E4
it's a sicilian this is actually a
sicilian right now and so black will try
to take advantage of some of these dark
squares but white will have a pair of
Bishops you just play H3 you swap here
you take back you bring your Bishop back
to the G2 I just feel like for theodoro
he needs to build a lead on the clock
that's what caused a mean time to buy
against carwana and if you're a theodoro
you're one of the best Blitz and bullet
players on the site play quickly play
confidently but I actually think I made
a mistake so I just want to say one more
thing Bishop takes F3 there might be
Bishop takes Knight over here I'm gonna
show this on the analysis board because
Amman I think we often consider these
moves out of the question but if you
have to take like this this is exactly
what happens if I would want
yeah and it's not so easy to make
threats here yeah we got Bishop H6 but
that's it you know it's just one Bishop
one move one threat
um then the reality sets in if Rook C8
Queen C7 is coming C4 is just loose so
yeah it does look like Queen takes F3
way back at the beginning would be the
preferred move but it actually looks
like uh that's all on the board plus
Knight C6 has been played
what a strange opening a mean tablet
he's chilling look at that guy he is
just hanging out playing some chess and
ooh can you take on C3 I think you can
and there he goes and I want to say
Theodore's face because I feel like he
did not even expect this at all and he
hasn't reacted but he clearly wasn't
looking out for that night
well let's remember I think his game
against Mattel he kind of reacted on a
delay to that missed Knight H5 move so
maybe the reaction is coming we just
have to stay tuned he'll be here in a
couple business days Bishop takes C3
there's Bishop C5 but like this can't be
rhyming Bishop B2
this is definitely good for black right
is Inbox just gonna be up a pawn Rook B1
the bishop slides back and you can't
even take on B7 because if you do you're
gonna lose your piece this bishop is
still under attack don't forget that you
just can't take it because the Queen the
queen will slide to C8 hit the rook and
the bishop will be lost
um very confusing
this is a bad day for Nicholas theodoro
he is not playing his best chess no
because you know what's happened Robert
is basically you have the same
structural deficiencies and there's the
reaction by the way he's not happy you
have the same structural deficiencies as
if you took that uh Bishop on C3 except
you're down a pawn and black still has
the dark Square Bishop so it's like
worse in every single way
yeah let's just bring up an analysis
board to show you how uh it is true what
amount is saying oh now he's getting
completely desperate with E5 but at this
moment you can take here so now at least
you have the pair of Bishops for your
troubles that one on E3 can knight can
go to H6 you have this bad Pawn
structure but you at least have two of
them rather than one as we see in the
game so you get absolutely nothing for
this Pawn that has been captured but
perhaps it's for 95 Queen B7 price yeah
tricky I say as a question rather than a
statement yeah that's a big question
mark
um because I'm looking at that position
and you know there are some ideas if 95
Queen B7 Rook B8 for example you could
maybe like
take on B8
and then take on A7
um that's that's one idea
you're saying just swap everything down
here and then after yeah A7 Bishop
covers the eight Square
yeah and and look even if I lose my C
Pawn here is white I think I still have
winning chances because at Bishop on G2
with that pawn motoring up the board as
soon as it gets from A4 to A5 Bishop B6
A6 a7a it's all covered
yeah that could be very dangerous so
that's the one hope that Nicholas
Theodore has at the moment it seems like
he missed Bishop takes C3 and then
allowed Bishop takes B2 uh but he is in
bad shape so let's go away from this one
we'll see if a mean tablet to buy can
take it and if he does then one draw
would be needed on another board and
well Rochelle woo on board four in the
bottom right our position looks
perfectly good to me I see actually
nothing bad about her position so maybe
for the St Louis archbishops they can
rely more they're fourth board and that
means they need to strike on boards one
and board three
yeah it definitely does look like
Rochelle um as expected by the way
because you know she has been uh
basically started with her toughest
games and finished with in terms of
ratings that is her easiest pairing so
it makes sense that she's having her
best game here but she's definitely
delivering that board does not look too
scary I'm looking over at the VAR Cobian
board and hey that's a you know very
comfortable slight Edge or VAR in that
game as well so you know slight Edge for
Fabi slight Edge for VAR and then
hopefully trying to to maintain some
equalities in the other two boards
Robert is that the recipe for success
I think it will have to be just because
of the positions we have Rochelle Wu
very solid why don't we go to that game
uh between varicobian and harika
dronavalik to explain to everybody why
the eval bar tends to like Black's
position in this line and last one was
H3
you're not gonna take you're just gonna
wrap the bishop around to H5 and if G4
go to G6 induce more weaknesses
white feels like you're a couple moves
behind you already need this Pawn on B4
you need to be able to strike on the
queen side over here so I feel like for
VAR at some point he'll look the E4 push
as well if his Bishop gets kicked in
this diagonal
yeah that's a I mean that's definitely
true that white feels slow here but you
know by the same token black doesn't
have the pawn on A5 so even getting to
play the move B4 seems like it's usually
an achievement in these kind of
positions
um and yeah I guess she just uh played
it straight away I think it's the only
chance because without before you're
definitely not doing anything maybe you
want to play A4 and B5 to follow up
maybe B5 and Rook takes but
I mean you have to try something here I
love vars position but at least B4 is
there for harika and uh you just have to
watch out for E4 as you mentioned by
black
because E4 push is really important
because if you can uh play E4 you're
gonna explode the board so that you're
going for the square and white is not
really that easily capable of stopping
it I mean what do you play E4 right now
if you take then this Knight comes into
E4 and into see through the fork but the
D4 Pawn is also loose Amman so ah it's a
really a tough decision for a Cobian
that's right yeah Rook d8 is I mean very
logical I can only assume B5 is the
intention here C5 is another attempt but
you have to be very sure what you're
doing after C5 because C5 the bishop
moves away and if you follow up with B5
your C Pawn is suddenly a little bit
loose so you need to calculate that
whole line out before you go for these
Pawn pushes never easy to push upon here
I think B5 would be a strategic blunder
because the hands block the dark squares
but C5 and B5 oh she goes for B5 first
but I like what you were saying about C5
to lead the way but now Knight B8 Knight
D7 Knight C5 and this D3 Pawn is just a
permanent weakness in in White's Camp so
I really like how Cobian is playing and
that's good news for the archbishops
because if we actually just zoom out of
here for a second just keep our eyes
across the four boards look at the top
right that's an opposite color Bishop
position where I feel like Nicholas
theodoru is no longer really worse so if
varusian acopian can take this game with
the black pieces he's going to need to
win for the archbishops to have a chance
look at the bottom right as well I'm on
Rochelle Wu has had a tough day so far
maybe she'll be the hero that St Louis
needs
that's right I think VAR is playing
tremendously based on the positions that
we see on the boards right now VAR needs
to win this like not gonna sugarcoat
that he needs to win that position
um a hundred percent but it's it's about
Rochelle Wu on that uh on that word for
matchup this is so important the Knight
on D5 is super strong but white is about
to execute a very important plan getting
rid of the Knight on D4 leaving uh
Aditya with the Knight on D5 that's a
lot better than the counterpart on D6
plus there's an A4 A5 sort of long-term
plan for white to gain open files
counter play so I think this is a really
crucial part of the game eval Bar says
hey don't worry about it but my brain is
kind of saying hey this is a really
critical moment to make sure to play
accurately and keep that uh bar around
uh even and she does she strikes with F5
saying go ahead take my Pawn but after a
knight recaptures on F5 likely the D6
Knight H4 is hanging in addition to the
queen being under attack on E3 let's
just show a quick variation that if you
think you're going to take this Pawn
after Knight takes oh my Pawn's under
attack let's go over here then this
Knight comes into E2 with check the King
has no choice but to step to the corner
and then Knight F4 is possible you're
happy to trade pieces here because now
three is weak the e-files open your
queen is just so misplaced and true
let's not forget the queen can slide
over to A4 as well to pick up the queen
side
yeah love all these variations they look
good for black I mean it makes sense
though right all the pieces are so well
placed Rooks Knights Queen I mean what
are you complaining about in Black's
position this looks like a perfect
opportunity to strike with F5 and she
sees the moment
and what is a digital going to do here
because uh F4 followed by F3 looks like
a devastating attack for blacklists open
up this King on G1 if you take on D4
can't black just take back with either
pawn and the queen is threatened and
then F takes E4 next so this looks like
trouble for white but the evil bar still
hovering around the center
it's it's impressive I'm not exactly
sure why I'm thinking tactically
no I don't know maybe I almost want to
say f re
ugh tough move to make but I'm with you
actually F3 seems to hold everything
together I would be afraid at some
moment of dropping this H4 Pawn but it
looks like somebody can't handle that
for the time being but right now it's
about the clock as well Aditya down
under five minutes still a teeny bit
ahead on the clock and he takes it up
I'm shocked by that mm-hmm oh
does it
Knight E2 to F4 is easy to underestimate
but very strong if Rochelle finds that
idea
I feel like it's not the only move that
gives her an advantage like she could
play for E4 to bring her Rook into the
game and attack this Pawn H4 the Queen's
just offside over here
yeah absolutely and the thing is E4
there is Knight takes on D4 and of
course you can't take with the Knight I
have to take with a pawn there but even
that's not that bad and if a black Brook
ends up on e4 White's gonna have to play
the rather strange looking G3 right how
do you defend H4
that doesn't look good so maybe take on
B3 first just to give no play and then
E4 I think it's your point it's a good
one uh but yeah this is looking very
nice for Rochelle Wu at the moment she
needs to convert this position uh
actually if we you know look across the
four boards and we have to pay attention
to everything that's going on here
because the St Louis archbishops need
three out of four points and the top
right Nicholas theodoro is no longer
worse at all against a mean time it's a
buy in fact if anyone's better it would
be Theodore but I do think we're gonna
see a draw shortly on that board a month
yep yep I agree and that's not a bad
result for theater considering how
poorly it started for him uh you have to
also think that hey team mgd1 I mean he
knows it's seven to five so he's
probably thinking okay look I'm making a
draw with black like comfortably this is
a good result for the team as well so
you might have gone into this game
Thinking hey I'm fine with a draw yeah
the draw will be guaranteed with Rook A1
back to A2 there's nothing that white
can do but bring the king back and forth
and oh I don't think white has any
winning chances because of this threat
and your a pawn is stopped so I think
that this game will be a draw it seems
like uh the result is all but guaranteed
so we'll just want to show the position
although I mean maybe I mean it's
playing for a little something something
I don't think he'll get it but it's a
good game a good save I should say for
theodorus let's get out of here just
because other games are I see the evil
bars going up and down seesawing uh the
only one that has remained stable is the
carwana our generic Icy game that one
looks very even so let's uh maybe tune
in because it might be our last time
yeah this uh this game at the moment
looks like uh easily the closest and
most dull of any of the matches uh with
this game trending towards a draw
um you know still chances but trending
towards a draw and we already know
there's a draw on hand and you're likely
you know could even just be taken in uh
theodorous game that's already eight
points for team mgd1 with those two
draws so it does mean that the pressure
is on Rochelle and varusian kobian to
win their games and honestly Robert
those aren't guarantees anymore because
the evals are flipping left right and
Center that's what happens in Rapid
chess uh we do think that Fabiano if
anyone has winning chances just because
he is a knight against a dark Square
bishop and Black's pawns are on light
squares but it seems like Arjun is
Comfortably holding although he's down
under two minutes so actually let's get
out of here I know we're hopping around
to each and every game but I see what
you're saying I'm on bottom left
varoujana kobian he's no longer better
or if anything it looks like a great
opportunity for harika because he missed
a tactic so let's actually dive into
that position and it all stems from this
beautiful Bishop on G2 harika she might
be the hero that mgd1 needs themselves
because after Rook takes Knight we're
gonna see a swap of everything and
Knight C6 you think wait a second I'm
already at one piece give me the second
piece on d8 black looks great get I have
two modded pieces for a rook but now I
give up my Rook for your queen thanks to
the bishop on G2
and the worst part about this is even if
you take Black's Queen and you put it on
D6 like a square that's safe it's still
winning for white
because you're actually mated there on
the back rank but yeah that's a that's a
really good variation and it must have
been did she just take the pawn on E5 is
that the last move yeah so it must have
been all based on that tactic oh Bishop
went to the worst Square keeping the
back rank a problem for black I think
she saw it I think she saw that tactic
realized with the bishop on F5 that Rook
A8 Bishop C8 was available and said okay
G4 let me see where you're gonna go with
that piece and was waiting in the wings
Bishop H7 and Uncorked this tactic
really nice yeah
really really good stuff from harika
Jordan Valley now whoa VAR is not under
a minute he goes for this but I guess
he's a take on D3 or something right
wait then I can take it back what am I
talking about so what's he going for
it's almost like Queen E5 Knight C6
Queen D6 Knight d8 and then take on D3
something weird like I mean I definitely
don't trust it Rook A8 coming in next
but
I don't know
this way but if you take maybe this
one's Bishop takes and he claims The
Rook on E5 is loose and so is the C4
Pawn so is B5 after that okay Varun
complicating matters right now
definitely
yeah no question about that I'm trying
to see if there's a way to simplify
nicely here or arika but not that easy
to do
no and with a mean time to buy securing
the draw a full point for her oh wow
that was sick I turned to see the score
for a second Rook D5 she's you can have
my Rook back but now your Bishop is
threatened and behind it your D4 Pawn is
going to be captured so she turns a
exchange Advantage a rook for a minor
piece into an extra Pawn that's
brilliant so smart so smart especially
when you think of the match strategy
that's just genius
that I mean that's just a clincher like
now Rook A6 go after this Pawn on B6 it
feels like uh White controls the entire
board the bishop on D5 clearly better
the counterpart on G6 and she swings to
the E file can't blame her uh but wow
she's just up a healthy Pawn Yeah VAR is
uh in serious trouble now but you know
what I was just uh sneaking a peek at
our uh four board view
um Robert and it looks like Fabiano
caruana is he's got serious winning
chances in his game as well which is
amazing news for the Archbishop
yes so let's go to that game because
suddenly it seems like the archbishops
if they can survive on the other boards
but they need wins they don't just need
draws on two of the other boards but
Fabiano caruana in the top left we're
gonna dive in there in Arjun aragaisy's
time travel I think it's just a winning
end game just trade Queens bring your
knight to the D7 square and then March
your king over at some point
yeah and he's he's spending his time
here how much time he has a minute plays
H6 wow
sickening this one's checkmate and
now it's just Knight D7 he just changed
the move away trade Queens in Knight D7
that's nice and simple
oh wow that's also just brilliant I
think leads to Checkmate right that's
right yeah Knight D7 is like very uh
very good as well
yeah it's amazing mate on f8 King has to
go to G7 wow Fabiano you know looking to
win this game and go to three and a half
out of four uh Arjun we thought that he
was just even it was but time was not
his friend so Fabiano caruana wins which
means that if varu janakobian can
somehow survive and if Rachelle Wu could
score a victory uh then the archbishops
have a chance but as we Zoom away from
this one uh it's not looking good for St
Louis despite that fobby win no Fabi I
mean he did all he could there Theodore
with the draw and that was from a really
bad opening so I mean all things
considered that was a good good result
VAR had an amazing position but right
now has just been outplayed by harika
after spotting that tactic it is looking
really bad for the archbishops and if
harika can win this it's all over
and look at harika's lead on the clock
her domination of pieces against her can
almost not even move here it's black
and Rook C7 I'm not sure what the threat
is but I like it now Queen takes B6 can
be played the rook's no longer intact
great move though by VAR F5 you need to
start creating chaos if you have any
chance in this one that's right that's
right
and well I mean what is the best move
for white because if you take the H5
Pawn is loose maybe there's some chances
there I was honestly looking at like I
was thinking of G5 G5 with H6
I'm trying to play Queen E5 mate
yeah that's actually sick I mean you're
just on fire she takes on a five with
the queen whoa it just takes me I wasn't
expecting that and she missed it too you
could see it by her reaction yeah the
thing is like you can still kind of
calmly play Rook B7 and you know you
still got a great position
yeah that's true it feels uncomfortable
to miss a tactic like that but she still
is up a pawn she can go as you just said
win this Pawn on B6 and she remains up a
healthy passer I don't know how you can
stop it watch out do not get checkmated
yeah it's just so difficult for it to
happen white would do well to even play
Bishop F7 to G6 just put that King in a
permanent prison this is always check
main threats oh my gosh if she falls for
this that would be the ultimate Swindle
but no she smartly brings her King up
the board up to F4 and she has it under
control she's just cruising yeah she's
been playing really really well
um in the match but especially in this
game
yeah this is a a great display of
technique from harika drone oh and
speaking of Technology swapping off the
Rooks you can't do anything otherwise
you'd lose your bishop and now it's
easily winning in the bishop and pawn
ending
yeah at least black has an H Pawn but uh
you're right this should not oh my
goodness the technique is immaculate
from harika right now
oh my so good
push it and push it and then bring your
Bishop around to E6 and that's game yeah
not C set well yeah I guess you could
play C7 first but I think it's even more
professional to bring the bishop to E6
beforehand
and you said professional she said
that's me and she just brings her Bishop
back King E7 King E5 your the black king
can't actually inch closer to the pawn
oh you never needed what am I talking
about just promote and stop it she wins
she wins on the board and wow Rica
Joanna volley I'm so impressed by that
game there were so many little moments
there where it looked like VAR was
getting some counter play if you spotted
all the tactics she gave back material
to get rid of counter play this was a
masterpiece game by harika and hey
Robert it wasn't just her that secured
the victory
um obviously Fabby tried everything to
lead the archbishops to Victory but
um mgd1 got it done on multiple boards
yeah mgd1 uh they only needed one and a
half points they decided that's not
enough let's get two and a half so
Fabiano caruana in the Battle of these
superstars of the Chess World he takes
down Arjun era geising what looked like
a pretty level game but when all was
said and done Bobby his Knight against
that dark Square Bishop it was a win for
him Nicholas Theodore played a very bad
opening against Amin taba to buy and was
kind of Lucky to survive but it was good
enough for team mgd1 because harika
dronavali and ditchy mattal a month
those bottom two boards they were
powerful for the Indian Squad
absolutely
um I think the the St Louis archbishops
just got themselves in a hole that they
couldn't dig themselves out of
um Fabiano had a great day he actually
looked I'll be the first to say a little
shaky at the beginning but he quickly
got into stride I mean there's a reason
he's been a champion and MVP before in
the Pro chess league three and a half
points there for Fabi it's just that his
team was not behind him in this one
yeah really great performance by St
Louis archbishop's top board and as you
said the others all had minus scores and
for Rochelle Wu she gave her all but the
other team outridored each and every
single match so uh a good win for a team
mg D1 and well that means they go to one
match win one loss and for the
archbishops this is going to be the
biggest surprise of the early season
they're one match loss away from
elimination
that's right you don't want to find
yourself at the bottom of the standings
at 0 and 3. you get to three losses then
you will be eliminated from the protest
League you will not make it to the
playoffs and I mean it's just insane
that I'm even saying this out loud but
the St Louis archbishops are at risk of
doing just that with another loss next
week Robert
surprising stuff but mgd1 was rewarded
for bringing Amin Tabitha Bai onto their
roster and we're gonna bring a mean
tablet to buy on for an interview so
chat if you have any questions for the
highly rated Iranian Grandmaster please
put them in the chat we'll maybe feature
them so amitabai will be joining us for
an interview after this short break
don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so I first learned about ill Cafe
through my buddy Aaron he was like Hey
me and a group of fellas meet at this
Cafe downtown on Sundays and we play
chess there it'd be really cool if you
could stop by and hang out with us and
you know just feel the vibe and so I
showed up
and it was a nice bike I was like yo ill
Cafe is pretty ill
[Music]
don't do it
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
will not be joining us for an interview
it is extremely late for the Indian team
so we understand and we congratulate in
mgd1 on their excellent performance and
what does this performance earn them
well it gives them a better shot at
making the playoffs let's remind you all
of the standings because three wins and
you're in and a month after two weeks
the full week hasn't finished yet we do
have some matches tomorrow but we know
the three teams at the top we saw the
Shanghai Tigers win their match earlier
today
yeah that was a great man shout out to
GM panty three wins and we in that was a
nice one by you Robert
um absolutely three wins is the target
here for these teams and while we don't
have another 2-0 to speak of of course
we do have an O2 and that is the St
Louis archbishops getting closer to O3
which would eliminate them from playoff
contention but mgd1 getting back on the
right track here moving to one and one
Rob
it is extremely surprising to see the St
Louis archbishops down toward the bottom
of the standings team mgd1 he's asked
okay after two weeks one and one what do
you think you say maybe they've
underperformed but for the archbishops
oh and two they have a lineup lead by
fabina carwana in week one they had
linear Dominguez I guess they just
haven't found a week where they put the
two of them together and right for being
honest Ward four having a much lower
rated board four has not worked out for
them thus far
yeah and who knows what the optimal
strategies the correct strategy we need
more data uh in order to figure that out
so it's not like they're they're doing
it
um incorrectly but hey it might be a
cause for them to switch things up if
it's not working then maybe Shuffle the
lineups try to go for a more balanced
roster I'm sure that they could uh you
know try to make some things up there's
only been two weeks and there's a lot of
players on that roster and some teams
haven't even played two weeks and uh
there will be two great matches in store
tomorrow in All American Clash will be
the second half of the doubleheader
between the but we start with a European
Showdown the Berlin Bears and the
Croatia Bulldogs they start us off at 7
30 a.m Pacific time and I'm on we finish
the day with the Gotham Knights led by
acara Nakamura taking on the California
unicorns that have the likes of lucash
and Sam Shanklin
yeah two extremely exciting matchups um
especially you know Berlin Bears uh
nearly shocked everyone uh when they
played uh the Gotham Knights last time
uh eventually the Gotham Knights picked
things uh up from a crazy first round
and managed to win that matchup but I
think all these teams are we just don't
know enough it's only been one week we
might see some brand new rosters uh
brand new lineups uh from their rosters
that is and that could bring just a
whole different Dynamic so just because
you watched a team maybe take a tough
defeat in week one Robert doesn't mean
anything about their playoff attention
come on I'm gonna put you on the spot
and I'm sorry to do this buddy we've had
a great show together tell me who's
gonna win those matches tomorrow
well
um it definitely like I will say that
while I'm being put on the spot I'm also
not it's a little unfair because I don't
know what lineups they're gonna go for
so if I knew the lineups I would be able
to make a real call but let's just say
going off what we know I'll I'll go for
the Berlin Bears and the Gotham Knights
okay so you're saying that uh Josephine
heinemann who famously defeated Hikaru
Nakamura for the Berlin Bears she will
be playing tomorrow so for all those who
became a fan of hers after that win she
will be in action tomorrow as will
Hikaru of course as he takes on the
California unicorns they have Sam
Shanklin Ray Robson Christopher you in
the lineup so it's going to be an
American Heavy clash in the second half
of the double header but for now all the
action from today has ended among kind
of what are your final thoughts from
what we saw today Shanghai and MGD won
winning with the protest League it
continues to excite
well
um you know I've been a broken record
today talking about how uh lineups that
are just more evenly matched if they get
off to a good start I think they they do
well in the long run in these uh in
these four round matchups and that's
been my takeaway from today those even
lineups are very exciting to watch teams
that are able to field an extremely
strong woman player I mean look at what
we've got as a result you get like 200
rating points for free based on uh you
know counting as a 23.50 for the average
rating so if you can do that I think
that's a big asset and personally I'm
loving these lineups that are a little
bit more balanced across the board where
everybody has a chance to take points
off everybody else versus kind of
throwing a board four into the uh into
the doghouse there with some really
really tough pairings playing like
people's 300 points higher rated every
single round so I I think those are my
two takeaways if you're able to field a
super strong female player of Robert
that's a massive asset to the team and
you know just having players across the
board that can take points and you're
not just saying that we saw that happen
today June when June scored three out of
four for the Shanghai tigers and then
harika dronavali or three for mgd1 she
scored two and a half including that in
very important final round victory over
arugina Cobin so I just want to say that
is a very good point and I want to thank
everybody who has tuned in watch us
throughout this Thursday afternoon at
least in the U.S no matter where you're
watching we appreciate you and your
bosses tell them it's okay I'll write
you a note you should continue watching
chess tomorrow we'll be right back at it
same time same place we will have the
Berlin Bears and the Croatia Bulldogs
starting off the day tomorrow you will
not want to miss the action this is the
protest League thanks to all of you for
watching thanks to our producers thanks
to everybody at chess.com who makes this
happen thanks most of all to Amon
Hamilton you like oh commentator buddy
and the players because without them
this doesn't take place but see you
tomorrow everybody we'll have to have a
night off before we have another fun day
for the protest League
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you